So, easy 60 grind heute.
Noch genau 15%.
Ich weiß nicht, ob wir das packen.
Ich hoffe mal.
So, jetzt machen wir ein bisschen weniger Headbang-Musik an, sondern irgendwas Entspanntes.
Ich mache einfach diese Playlist an von gestern.
Übrigens, wenn der Stream wieder ab und zu mal ganz kurz ruckelt, liegt das nicht an mir, sondern an...
Dreimal dürft ihr raten.
Bäm!
Bäm! Wollte ich nur nochmal erwähnen.
Nur weil wir gerade mal dabei waren.
Wegen denen hier ist das Stream jetzt schon ein paar Mal abgekackt.
Wir müssen das mal anders machen.
Moment, Image hinzufügen.
Moment, Moment, das müssen wir anders machen.
So, Moment, Image, 0.3.D1, 0.3.D2.
Wir reiten ja eh noch.
So.
Jetzt haben wir das Telekom-Logo schön verziert.
So, wir reiten heute mal zu einem anderen Spot.
Ich will mal gucken, wie die XP da ist.
Da habe ich ziemlich viel gegrindet auf 59.
Hier.
Gucken, wie das so ist.
Telekom in 2K17.
Ja, ist echt so.
Fast schon 2K18.
2K18.
Stream ruckelt, jawohl.
Danke, Telekom.
Das macht dir ganz toll, Telekom.
Beste.
4K-Stream wann, sobald Twitch mal ordentlich Bandbreite erlaubt und nicht nur 6mbit.
6mbit ist einfach zu wenig.
Wenn Stream bei allen ruckelt, liegt es an der Telekom.
Naja, also wenn es von mir ausgeht, liegt es sehr wahrscheinlich an der Telekom.
Das Reitgeräusche, die sind laut, oder?
Äh, ich würde sagen, so ist laut genug.
Wie ihr reitet.
Die Spells sind eh laut.
Easy Clap.
Ah, Pets gefüttert, kann losgehen.
Repariert ist auch alles.
That's easy win.
Easy 60.
Am besten sind die, die ihre Worts nur für Subs anbieten.
Ja, das nervt mich auch.
Das ist ein Grund für mich nicht zu subben.
Ich finde das auch bescheuert.
Worts sind oftmals so die Quelle, weil man den Streamer nicht allzu gut kennt.
Und man sich einfach mal so die letzten paar Broadcasts ein bisschen reinzieht.
Um sich anzuschauen, will man da folgen, will man vielleicht subben.
Aber wenn das halt gar nicht geht.
Ich finde es blödsinn, die Subs, also die Worts, Subscriber-only zu machen.
Ich kann mir auch nicht vorstellen, dass es letztendlich unterm Strich was bringt.
Ja, und wie das Serious Max sagt, das könnte ja auch eh jemand das Zeug einfach mitschneiden.
Machen ja ganz viele, ne?
Wenn man mal auf YouTube guckt nach Overwatch Highlights.
Oder da sind ja teilweise ganze...
Sechs Stunden Livestreams von Pros mitgeschnitten und einfach hochgeladen.
Auf Channels, mit denen die halt absolut nichts zu tun haben.
Muss man sich mal überlegen, ne?
Streamt einer sechs Stunden, gibt sich Mühe, irgendeiner schneidet es mit.
Legt auf YouTube hoch und easy views.
Ja, Marv sehe ich auch so.
Ah, ich weiß warum die Musik so laut ist bei mir und bei euch so leise.
Weil ich es wieder falsch eingestellt habe.
Lol.
Kaum macht man es richtig, schon geht es.
Ich muss das jetzt immer im Chrome-Tab, weil OBS, beziehungsweise Shadowplay sonst Musik drin hat,
muss ich das jetzt immer umschalten im Chrome, dass es die zweite USB-Soundkarte verwendet.
Sonst geht das nicht.
Wow.
WTF.
Ich werde gehostet.
Krasser Scheiß. Zielkrampf.
Danke, 110.
110 Viewer.
Jetzt könnt ihr mal im richtigen BDO-Nob zugucken, Leute.
Dem größten BDO-Nob mit der besten Ausrüstung für einen BDO-Nob.
Und noch besser, die Ausrüstung habe ich mir nicht mal selbst enchanted.
Wir machen jetzt Writing-Stream.
Ja, Marvin, das ist echt ein Problem.
Also ich sehe das, wie gesagt, ich sehe das bei ganz vielen Overwatch-Pros.
Die streamen teilweise, wenn du dir X2C und sowas anguckst, die streamen ja teilweise irgendwie acht Stunden gefühlt.
Da gibt es halt auch schon viele Highlights in dem Stream.
Vor allem bei X2C, das ist immer ganz lustig.
Und dann hast du Leute, die machen dann X2C-Stream-Compilation, 10 Minuten, laden das hoch, kriegen irgendwie 80.000 bis irgendwie 150.000 Views
und laden das halt auf ihrem Channel hoch, der mit X2C gar nichts zu tun hat.
Da kann man, da muss man sich schon mal fragen, ist das so in Ordnung, ja?
Also ich bin ja normalerweise, ich mache ja sonst nie so einen großen Aktion nach dem Motto, hier Rechte, da Copyright, hier und da und sonst was.
Weil es ist meistens für den Viewer eigentlich...
Oder generell für uns alle eigentlich nur nerviger macht.
Aber sowas muss ja auch nicht sein, ja?
Valkorion, moin.
Freesy-Carried-Zielkampf, ja so ist es.
Ich streite das ja auch gar nicht ab.
Der Spot sackt immer noch, ey.
Ich streite das ja auch überhaupt nicht ab, dass ich freesy-carried bin.
Und auf der anderen Seite, ich muss freesy-carried sein, weil ohne den Fabian hätte ich ja das Game noch nicht mal angefangen.
Ich habe ja eigentlich das Game nur angefangen, dass ich mal mit dem Fabian wieder ein bisschen MMORPG spielen kann.
Die Mobs halten viel zu viel aus, da mache ich lieber Easy-Naga-Grind wieder.
Schau ich das mal an.
Die sterben ja gar nicht.
Null.
Das ist ja nix.
Das ist gar nicht, warum ich hier früher so viel rumgegrindet habe.
Mal war es es nicht.
Ja, Adio, das stimmt.
Also manche finden das ja auch gut.
Aber bei xQc in dem Fall denke ich mir halt, der hat garantiert was dagegen, weil der lädt selber Stream-Highlights hoch bei sich auf dem Channel.
Und dann finde ich es ein bisschen affig, wenn quasi...
...andere Leute quasi Konkurrenz-Stream-Highlights machen, obwohl du selbst Stream-Highlights hochlädst, die halt mit dir nichts zu tun haben.
Das ist da schon ein bisschen bescheuert.
Mein Pferd beschwert sich, dass es gleich kaputt geht.
Moment, habe ich eigentlich das richtige Zeug an?
Ja.
Oh, ich muss Buff-Food nehmen.
Wo habe ich denn aufgehört?
Ähm...
Casting-Speed, das habe ich genommen.
AP plus 5.
Ja.
Das ist jetzt dran.
Okay, gut.
Ja, wenn das jetzt jemand ist, der einfach nur Livestreams macht und es dem im Prinzip egal ist, dann habe ich ja auch keinen Schmerz damit, wenn einer Stream-Compilations oder Stream-Highlights hochlädt auf YouTube.
Oh, Boss-Bashen.
Aber wenn die Leute halt selbst den Channel haben...
Die Frauen halten...
Ja gut, die Dinge halten immer so viel aus hier.
Sucked.
Alter Lahn.
Ist da eigentlich irgendwie eine schnellere Variante, die zu bashen?
Ich glaube nicht, oder?
Oh.
Soll ich nicht einfach so stehen bleiben und mich hitten lassen?
No damage.
Kann er mal sterben jetzt?
Oh, ein Rosa-Blade.
Jawohl, jetzt bin ich gleich instant rich.
Denkst du, dass das heute mit 60 noch was wird?
Äh, ich weiß nicht.
Ich hoffe.
Also, wir haben ja demnächst Nacht.
Easy.
RNG.
Hat sich schon...
Hat sich schon gelohnt, hierher zu kommen.
Wobei, ich glaube, wir machen nachher wieder Naga-Kreisel-Grind, falls Nacht wird.
Ich würde sagen, wir machen bis kurz bevor es Nacht wird hier.
Dann dürfte es auch...
Dürfte es auch quasi gefüllt sein mit Trash-Loot.
Dann gehen wir das auf den Weg verkaufen.
Dann mache ich Naga-Kreisel-Grind weiter.
Wie lange spielst du?
Ähm...
Also, angefangen...
Wann habe ich denn angefangen?
Also, ich spiele halt kaum.
Ähm...
Ich glaube, ich habe letztes...
Letztes oder vorletztes Jahr angefangen.
Bisschen gespielt.
Ein halbes Jahr nicht mehr gespielt.
Dann Reroll von Bersi auf Wizard.
Man, der Bersi war 56 oder so.
Der hatte nix, ja.
Dann Wizard ein bisschen gespielt.
Jetzt wieder drei Monate nicht gespielt.
Ich habe eigentlich...
Ich bin eigentlich der übelste Noob in dem Game, ne?
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ich kann aber meinen Wizard...
Kann ich die drei Spells drücken, die ich brauche, um die Mobs zu bashen.
Easy.
Das kriege ich hin.
Wizard-Bash kriege ich hin.
Das wäre so ein fetter.
Das wir bashen wieder.
Oh, kann das sein, dass ich meinen Pet nicht...
Doch, ich habe meinen Pet beschworen.
Hauptsache, ganzes Boss-Gear auf 3.
Ja, das ist...
Das ist zwei Sachen zu verdanken.
Einmal, übelstes Klack...
Äh, Klack...
Äh, äh, Luck.
Glück beim Boss-Gear bekommen.
Ich kann da gleich noch was zu sagen, weil das ist...
Ich wusste das, als ich das alles gekriegt habe, gar nicht zu schätzen, wie selten das eigentlich ist.
Na, erzähle ich gleich noch was zu, wenn ich das Vieh hier gekillt habe.
Ähm, und als nächstes...
Das wird es der Fabian.
Also, der Friseur alles enchanted hat.
Wenn mir das der Fabian nicht alles enchanted hätte, ich weiß dann nicht mal, wie man ordentlich enchanted...
Also, ich weiß prinzipiell, wie es funktioniert, aber ich habe keine Ahnung, wo da die besten, ähm...
Also, bei welcher Qualitätsstufe, welche Fail-Stacks, wie man das am besten macht und am optimiertsten...
Ey, man, letztendlich ist es...
Letztendlich ist es random, ja.
Aber umso mehr Versuche du rausholen kannst, umso öfter hast du halt die Chance...
Beziehungsweise kannst du halt deinen random Luck probieren.
Hätte der Fabian mir das nicht enchanted, dann...
Also, wohlgemerkt, ich hätte ja ohne ihn auch nie angefangen, also...
Deswegen.
Ich zeige jetzt...
Ich muss jetzt gleich schon mal meine Items zeigen.
Und zwar...
Also, übelst, übelst Mega-Luck, ne?
Ähm, wo fange man an?
Ach ja, äh, Helm habe ich...
Habe ich auch Jai's Helm am Start.
Liegt in Velia im Vault rum.
Ähm...
Also, Jai's Helm habe ich gesniped aus dem Auktionshaus.
Also, aus Marketplace.
Sogar On-Stream.
Und...
Einfach reingelackt wieder.
Ähm...
Die Rüstung...
Habe ich aus einem Daily Reward gezogen.
Den haben wir letztens enchanted.
Selbst aus quasi auch Daily Rewards und Boxen der letzten paar Monate.
Das ist halt...
Naja, halt...
Random Loot.
Die haben...
Die Beaks haben wir auch gesniped aus dem Auktionshaus.
Auch On-Stream.
Ich glaube beim Friseur auf dem Stream.
Den haben wir auch aus dem Auktionshaus gesniped.
Und...
Jetzt kommt der Hit.
Äh...
Den haben wir auch gesniped.
So.
Und...
Die Maskenschuhe, die habe ich aus der zweiten Questrolle gezogen.
Die ich überhaupt gemacht habe.
Jemals in BDO.
Ich habe...
Ich...
Ich habe einfach mal...
Random...
Komm hier.
Ich mache jetzt mal die ganzen Black Spirit Quests.
Und irgendwie in der zweiten Woche oder so die dritte Rolle...
Also man kriegt ja dann irgendwie immer ein paar Packages zum Aufmachen, wenn man den Boss gekillt hat.
Und...
Ähm...
Da habe ich aufgemacht und so...
Instant Schuhe.
Und ich war so...
Nice, so schwer ist das doch gar nicht.
Und wie gesagt, ich wusste das damals überhaupt nicht zu schätzen, wie selten das eigentlich ist.
Ja?
Und ich habe so...
Ja, ich weiß gar nicht, was das Problem ist.
So schwer ist das doch gar nicht.
Easy und so.
Ja.
So.
Und...
Nächsten Monat.
Wahrscheinlich so am...
Wahrscheinlich irgendwie so 7. Januar oder so.
Mal gucken, wie die Daily Rewards...
Ups.
Wie die Daily Rewards ausfallen.
Habe ich dann 70 Shakatu-Seals gesammelt aus den Daily Rewards.
Hier, da.
Morgen gibt es noch eins.
Oh, die müssen wir gleich zusammen aufmachen.
Die habe ich auf dem Bersi schon liegen.
Morgen kriege ich nochmal 5 Shakatu-Seals.
Dann habe ich 65.
Das heißt, im Januar habe ich 70.
Dann kann ich mir meine Dande kaufen.
Und dann habe ich easy Boss-Gear alles fertig.
Bis halt hier auf noch besseren Schmuck.
Alles fertig.
Komplett.
Ohne zu spielen eigentlich.
Das ist halt...
Glück.
Das kann man gar nicht mehr Glück nennen.
Aber ich glaube, in BDO habe ich irgendwie eh so ein Glücks-Buff auf meinem Account.
Wir haben jetzt ja ein bisschen Naga-Crunch gemacht die letzten Tage.
Auch 3 Seraph-Necklace und alles getroppt.
Easy.
Lacker-Streamer-Friend-Carried.
Ja, richtig.
Wir haben uns das Lack quasi aufgeteilt.
Der Fabian hat sein Lack mitgebracht beim Enchanten.
Und ich habe mein Lack mitgebracht beim Items überhaupt erst bekommen.
Jetzt musst du nur richtig suchten wie Friesi.
Ne, kann ich ja gar nicht.
Deswegen spiele ich...
Das finde ich echt gut an BDO.
Du hast schon deine Vorteile, wenn du 24-7 suchtest.
Ist gar nicht die Frage.
Aber du wirst nicht total abgehängt.
Also es ist jetzt nicht so mega casual, dass du quasi...
So wie Final Fantasy Online.
Also das 14er.
War das 14?
Ja.
Im Prinzip wurdest du da ja künstlich verlangsamt, dein Procrast.
Selbst wenn du viel spielen wolltest, hat dir nichts gebracht.
Aber hier bringt es dir was, wenn du viel spielst.
Äh, Moment.
Wo sind denn die Mobs hin?
Da stellst einer rum.
Was soll denn das?
Aber du wirst auch nicht total abgehängt, wenn du es halt casual-mäßig spielst, wie ich.
Ich habe überhaupt keine Zeit, 24-7 zu suchen.
Das klappt nicht.
Ich meine, ich muss immerhin noch arbeiten gehen.
Vier Tage in der Woche.
Plus mich um meinen YouTube-Channel kümmern und da auch Content produzieren.
So, und ab und zu will ich auch mal was anderes machen als das.
Und vielleicht auch noch was anderes als BDO spielen.
Dazu kommt, dass ich ja auch noch Overwatch spiele.
Also im Prinzip...
Im Prinzip...
Ich kann das Game gar nicht 24-7 suchen.
Und trotzdem funktioniert das ganz gut.
Also das haben sie wirklich nicht schlecht hingekriegt.
Da kann man nichts sagen.
Bam.
Ja, wie oft auf deinem YouTube-Channel kommt oft Content?
Guck mal nach.
Da kommt ziemlich viel.
Guck mal nach, wie viele Videos diesen Monat gekommen sind.
Mehr konnte ich eigentlich kaum machen.
Da sieht man schon mal, wenn quasi schon mehr als so nicht drin ist.
Und ich hatte den ganzen Monat Urlaub.
Da kann man sich vorstellen, wie das ist, wenn ich nach vier Tagen die Woche arbeiten gehe.
Da ist halt 24-7 suchen BDO nicht drin.
Außerdem muss ich sagen, ist BDO jetzt auch nicht das Spiel, was ich wirklich 24-7 suchen will.
Aber in 2K17, ja.
Ja, und weißt du, was das Schlimme ist?
Da hat es geschrieben.
Timbo, weißt du, was das Schlimme ist?
Nicht nur Arbeit in 2K17, sondern auch Arbeit in 2K18.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was ihr alle wollt gerade.
Ich habe bestimmt diesen Monat 10 Videos hochgeladen oder so.
Das ist im Vergleich so viel, wie ich sonst gefühlt in einem halben Jahr oder so hochlade.
Moment, was will denn der hier?
What?
Ist alles weg?
Kein Obst.
Geh mir die andere Rotation ab.
Ich kann nicht mehr arbeiten.
Wie gesagt, wir machen das eh nur, bis wir voll sind.
Wenn wir voll sind, dann verkaufen wir das und wechseln für die Nacht den Spot.
Habe ich überhaupt noch Black Spirit Buff?
50% Scroll?
Nee.
Nee, WWPD, irgendwelchen Beef interessiert mich nicht.
Sollen sich alle anbeefen, wenn sie da Bock drauf haben.
Ganzer Kindergarten da.
Also mich interessiert das so überhaupt nicht, wenn sich da irgendwelche Leute beefen auf YouTube oder Twitch oder sonst was.
Manche Sachen finde ich ganz witzig, ja.
Aber auch nur, wenn man die Streamer guckt.
Ansonsten ist mir das total egal, wenn sie sich da irgendwie zoffen.
Haha, Flexinatus.
Tja.
Ja, manchmal dauert es halt ein bisschen länger.
Ich gebe ja auch zu, der Twitch-Name ist jetzt nicht sonderlich intuitiv mit mir in Verbindung zu bringen, ja.
Das liegt aber einfach daran, dass es nie geplant war, eigentlich auf dem Account zu streamen.
Und ich dachte mir, als ich mir dann überlegt habe, hey, er fängt doch an zu streamen, dachte ich mir so, hey, behältst du den Account?
Weil, das ist gar nicht so schlimm, wenn es die Leute gar nicht direkt erkennen.
Weil die, die es interessiert, die finden das.
Vor allem, ich habe es ja auch schon ein paar Mal auf YouTube gesagt und so.
Und die, die nur rumnerven wollen, die haben nicht genug Energie zu gucken.
Und die finden es nicht und nerven dann auch nicht.
Also eigentlich ist es ganz gut, dass ich hier anders heiße.
Oh.
Oh, das ist ja ein Boss.
Ich sollte vielleicht mal hingucken.
Oder Boss-Elite-Viech halt.
Violent-Viech.
Ist ein grausames Ding.
Ganz violent.
Haha, WMPD, ich weiß gar nicht, was du da machen wolltest.
Moment, du wolltest irgendeine VR-Geschichte, VR-IKEA-Einrichtung oder so, wolltest du machen, ne?
Naja, ich kann dir da gerne helfen beim Programmieren.
Müssen wir bloß einen ordentlichen Vertrag machen vorher.
Easy.
Wobei ich sagen muss, ich würde wirklich mal gerne was für VR programmieren.
Einfach, weil ich es noch nie gemacht habe.
Auf der anderen Seite, ich habe von 3D-Sachen relativ wenig Ahnung.
Könnt ihr euch noch daran erinnern, wie schwer wir uns getan haben im Stream, als ich mit DirectX BDO aufnehmen wollte und in Mini-Fenster zeichnen?
Das haben wir ja vor ein paar Monaten im Stream gemacht.
Da habe ich quasi versucht...
BDO aufzunehmen.
Also das, was OBS macht im Endeffekt.
Wollte ich mal nachprogrammieren und gucken.
Da haben wir uns richtig schön abgebrochen im Stream, bis das funktioniert hat.
Auf was basiert VR überhaupt?
Das kommt drauf an, was du dir für eine Brille kaufst.
Also...
Und dann vermute ich mal, dass es vom jeweiligen Hersteller irgendein Entwickler-Kit gibt.
Also sprich, egal ob du jetzt irgendwie ein Oculus kaufst oder eine HTC-Brille oder was auch immer.
Da wird es wahrscheinlich dann ein Entwickler-Kit für geben.
Das es dann halt mit der Hardware ganz besonders toll funktioniert.
Halt um die Spezialitäten der jeweiligen Hardware auszunutzen.
Ansonsten machst du das wahrscheinlich ganz normal Direct3D, wie man das unter Windows für Games halt macht.
Oder du kannst es wahrscheinlich auch mit OpenGL machen, das ist ja dann letztendlich egal.
Wobei unter Windows Direct3D eindeutig zu bevorzugen ist.
Warum halten das Viech so viel aus?
Ich habe das Gefühl, die sind früher schneller umgefallen.
Jetzt muss ich mir einen Backattack machen.
Wenn das weiter in der Rate droppt, muss ich sogar noch, bevor die Nacht da ist, mal zum Auktionshaus den ganzen Krempel verkaufen.
Max, hast du den neuen Helden-Release von Jeff Kaplan im Stream gesehen?
Gab es da einen neuen Held?
Ich habe gesehen, wie Jeff vor dem Ofen gesessen hat und nichts gemacht hat.
Ist Jeffs Ofen quasi der neue Held oder was?
Kannst du einen Clip schicken, ja?
Gibt es echt einen neuen Overwatch-Held?
Hast du gar nicht die Gratis-Markt?
Doch!
Irgendwo habe ich die.
Das ist ja soweit.
Ich habe noch nie eine Maid verwendet.
Da gibt es doch irgendwo dann auch so eine Scroll, die man einlösen muss.
Die liegt, glaube ich, noch irgendwo auf dem Bersi rum oder so.
Abgeholt haben wir sie.
Das Zeug schmüllt ja aber.
Ich glaube, wir haben sie.
Wir haben sie.
Das Zeug schmüllt ja aber echt ganz schön den Inf zu.
So geil ist die XP jetzt auch nicht.
Aber bald ist Nacht, dann zünden wir wieder alle unsere Buffs, die es gibt.
Dann geht es ab.
Also in der Nacht kriegen wir wieder easy 90% hin.
Und danach ist einfach nur noch grind bis zum Umfallen.
Ich gucke mir den Link gleich an.
Du kannst mit grind nichts anfangen.
Ist halt Geschmackssache.
Wobei ich finde,
grind gibt es halt in jedem MMO.
Und mir ist das lieber,
oder ich sage mal so,
was mir noch lieber wäre,
wenn es Gruppengrind wäre.
Gruppengrind ist eigentlich das, was ich in MMOs am besten finde.
Aber wenn man mal jetzt von anderen MMOs ausgeht,
wenn du dir jetzt mal WoW anguckst,
irgendwas oder Final Fantasy oder es ist im Prinzip egal was.
Da grindest du ja auch.
Da grindest du halt Quests bis zum Umfallen.
Und die Quests sind halt, wenn man ehrlich ist, auch nicht spannend.
Ich glaube MMO-Quests könnten wir auch innerhalb von 2 Stunden uns 100 Stück ausdenken.
So die Standard-MMO-Quests.
Die sind halt einfach dumm.
Sammle 10 Blumen.
Versorge, keine Ahnung, 50 Soldaten mit ihrem Abendessen.
Du rennst dann halt rum, was auch immer.
Das ist halt auch grind.
Aber halt grind in anderer Form.
Am besten finde ich Gruppengrind.
Das macht mir in MMOs eigentlich am meisten Bock.
Und ich meine damit jetzt nicht Dungeon-Finder-Gruppengrind.
Dungeon-Finder finde ich immer noch so eines der bescheuerten Ideen,
die sie jemals hatten in MMOs.
Aber das ist doch super monoton, oder nicht?
Ja, schon.
Es ist ja im Prinzip in Diablo auch,
wenn du immer mit den gleichen Monster haust.
Aber das Kampfsystem in BDO ist...
Und ich spiele Wizard, ja.
Wizard hat schon somit das Einfachste, was du machen kannst.
Du läufst gegen den Gegner, drückst drei Spells,
und der Gegner ist tot.
Das Kampfsystem in BDO macht es aber immer noch ganz interessant,
auch wenn du das vier Stunden am Stück machst.
Oder fünf Stunden oder sechs Stunden am Stück.
Das ist überhaupt kein Ding.
Zumal man es ja auch ein bisschen weniger monoton machen kann,
als immer am gleichen Spot.
Manchmal, wenn man mehrere Helden hat,
kann man natürlich auch wechseln zwischendurch.
Was wollte ich?
Ich wollte eben noch irgendetwas sagen
zu Dungeon-Finder, genau.
Ich finde Dungeon-Finder sind somit die blödeste Idee,
die sie hatten bisher in MMOs.
Also seit WoW mit diesem Mist angefangen hat.
Weil Dungeon-Finder,
also eines der größten Komponenten,
die so ein MMO hat,
ist ja neben diesem offensichtlichen,
was du hier hast,
irgendwie Mobs farmen,
Items verbessern und sonst was,
ist in MMOs, wo es unterschiedliche Server gibt.
In BDO ist es jetzt halt mittlerweile
ein großer Server.
Aber sag mal, in MMOs, wo es unterschiedliche Server gibt,
hast du ja auch irgendwo bei MMOs
so eine soziale Komponente drin.
Also sprich, du kennst halt die Leute,
die auf deinem Server spielen.
Du weißt, wer ist ein guter Tank,
wer ist ein guter Heiler,
wer ist ein guter was auch immer.
Das weißt du halt.
So.
Und diese ganze Komponente,
oder auch generell so,
du organisierst dich irgendwie in der Gilde
oder sonst was.
Oder es gibt Spots, wo sich die Leute treffen
zum Leveln und so Sachen in der Richtung.
Das wird mit Dungeon Finder komplett rausgenommen.
Zu Gunsten dafür,
dass man halt mal easy einloggen kann,
30 Minuten simple Dungeon grindet
und dann wieder ausloggt.
Nimmt es halt die komplette,
so diesen kompletten sozialen Aspekt,
den es früher in MMOs gegeben hat, weg.
Dungeon Finder.
Deswegen finde ich Dungeon Finder kacke.
Total bescheuerte Idee.
Gegrönt wird das Ganze natürlich dann noch,
und das geht ja meistens Hand in Hand,
von Dungeon Finder für Instanzen.
Also sprich instanziertes Dungeon Zeug,
zusammengewürfelt mit anderen Leuten
von anderen Servern.
Dann hast du es nämlich nicht nur
die soziale Komponente von deinem Server
aus dem MMO rausgenommen,
sondern auch noch komplett verwürfelt
mit anderen Leuten.
Also das heißt,
die Leute, die du mit denen da zusammenspielst,
im Dungeon,
über den Dungeon Finder,
die siehst du danach wahrscheinlich nie wieder,
weil die von irgendeinem anderen Server kommen.
Das heißt, du kannst erstens auffüllen
wie die Axt im Wald,
und zweitens erzeugt es auch überhaupt keinen,
irgendwie so ein Gefühl,
man spielt zusammen.
Ist einfach kacke, Dungeon Finder.
So, und da bin ich froh,
dass es sowas hier nicht gibt.
Hier gibt es auch keine Instanzen.
Bei BDO würde ich halt sagen,
warum es das alles nicht gibt,
liegt einmal daran,
weil sie es nicht wollen,
und ich glaube auch,
weil sie es nicht können.
Also technischer Seite sieht man halt,
an BDO oftmals,
dass da sehr viel mit heißer Nadel gestrickt ist.
Und es ist natürlich einfacher,
einfach eine große Welt zu machen
und da Leute drin rumrennen zu lassen,
als eine instanzierte große Welt zu machen.
Easy Catry Bash.
So, wenn ich die Mobs hier tot habe,
guck ich mir den Link gleich mal an.
Steam oder Standalone Version?
Ich würde sagen, ist egal.
Aber vielleicht haben wir irgendwelche Pros im Chat,
die sagen können, was besser ist.
Ja.
Weil im Prinzip,
wenn du mit Steam anfängst,
darfst du auf den Steam-Servern spielen
zum Einstieg.
Und wenn du mit der Standalone Version anfängst,
darfst du auf den Einsteiger-Servern der Standalone anfangen.
Also macht eigentlich keinen großen Unterschied.
Ja.
Jeff verarscht irgendwie Leute im Stream,
wenn ich das richtig sehe, oder?
Also wenn das das ist, dann habe ich das gesehen.
Das ist das, woran er dann auch erzählt,
dass die Kekse nicht echt sind und die Milch hier ewig rumsteht
und sowas.
Dann habe ich das gesehen schon.
Und statt die Leute zu verarschen,
sein Game besser machen.
Was gibt es denn bei Steam für BDO-Versionen?
Weil wir haben ja gestern mal ein bisschen gerechnet
und festgestellt, diese
die Advanced-Version
oder wie das heißt, lohnt sich von den Inhalten her,
wenn man es ein bisschen spielt.
Mit zweimal Value-Packs, Inventar-Erweiterung
und sowas.
Gibt es die über Steam auch?
Ja. Aber testen kann vorher definitiv
nichts schaden, wie gerade jemand im Chat geschrieben hat.
Testen kann man auch ohne irgendwelche
Sachen sich zu kaufen.
Also man kann ein Spiel allgemein spielen, ohne sich was zu kaufen,
aber manche Sachen sind halt sehr sinnvoll.
Inventar-Erweiterung,
Storage-Erweiterung, Pets und sowas.
Das erleichtert
das Leben schon ungemein.
Was stört mich an Overwatch?
Das vor allem, was mich an Overwatch stört,
ist das verkackte Ranking-System.
Aber da will ich jetzt nicht wieder von anfangen,
weil erstens rege ich mich da wieder auf
und zweitens erzähle ich das jeden Stream.
So, und neben dem
verkackten Ranking-System regt mich auch auf,
dass es so ewig dauert, bis sich was tut in dem Game.
Ich meine, du kannst doch
nicht die Leute drei Monate irgendeinen Crap
spielen lassen und nicht mit ihnen kommunizieren.
Muss man sich doch nicht wundern, wenn da keiner mal Bock drauf hat.
Weißt du, wenn Blizzard wenigstens sagen würde,
ja Leute, ähm, wir haben
jetzt mal hier analysiert, so und so viel
Pickrate von dem Held ist uns zu hoch.
Wir schauen gerade, was wir tun können.
Das wird voll und ganz reichen, ja. Das wird die Spiele auch
schon mal glücklich machen. Die wissen, hey, Blizzard hat's
mitgekriegt, alles gut. Aber Blizzard sagt einfach
gar nichts. Macht halt ab und zu
irgendeinen Developer-Update, was dir auch nicht
wirklich viel weiterbringt.
Und am besten war immer noch,
ähm,
der, ich hab vergessen,
wie der heißt, der,
der, der, der Overwatch-League
Obermacker.
Ähm, der hat ja,
hat sich ja in so ein paar Videos
und Podcasts in letzter Zeit
rumgetrieben und Overwatch-League
Promote und ein paar Sachen dazu erzählt.
Und
am besten war's,
und er hat auch so eine
AskMeAnything und sowas
auf Reddit gemacht. Und da waren wirklich
interessante Fragen dabei, so nach dem Motto,
ja, wie ist es denn jetzt eigentlich? Ist es Pros
wirklich nicht erlaubt, andere Spiele
zu streamen und sowas? Ich meine,
das ist für Pros, wenn man sich mal so jemand anguckt
wie Seagull oder sowas, ist es schon
wichtig zu wissen, darf ich nur Overwatch streamen
oder darf ich nicht, weißt du?
Ähm, und es gab
halt auf die ganzen interessanten Fragen mal wieder
keine richtige Antwort. Da kam dann immer
so, weißt du, da kam immer so diese Standardantwort.
Boah, das ist ja toll, dass ihr diese Frage
stellt. Wir freuen uns, dass ihr so aktiv seid
und euch so sehr mit dem Spiel
beschäftigt. Und wir sind
gerade in engen Diskussionen
mit den Spielern, wie wir das handhaben.
Das ist so eine Antwort, die ganze Idee
ja im Endeffekt auch sparen, weißt du?
Sagt ja
halt gar nichts. Und am besten,
am besten war, wo jemand
gefragt hat, ähm,
ich weiß nicht mehr, um was es genau ging. Es lief aber
darauf raus, so nach dem Motto,
äh, also irgend so ein Sonderfall, so nach dem
Motto, wenn jetzt zwei Leute
den Payload gleich weit pushen, bla bla bla.
Also halt quasi sowas, wo es eine Regel
für geben müsste.
Und dann lief es darauf raus, so nach dem Motto,
ja, okay, äh, woher weiß man denn,
wie, wie das denn gehandhabt
wird, gehandhabt wird in der Overwatch League?
Und da meinte der Typ halt so,
ja, dafür gibt es das Overwatch-Regelbuch.
Und, äh,
antworten die Leute dann so drauf, ja,
okay, das ist ja cool, da könnten wir ja nachgucken.
Ähm, wo ist denn das Overwatch-Regelbuch?
Wo kann man sich das angucken? Ja, das liegt hier neben
mir. Ey, das bringt es dir halt auch nicht.
Ich meine, es ist schon interessant zu
wissen,
wie denn die Regeln bei einem Event sind.
Also auch für Zuschauer
ist das interessant.
Ich meine, du kannst dir doch in anderen Sportarten
auch die Regeln angucken.
Ja, man soll nicht nur ein Held spielen. Genau!
Das ist auch so ein Kritikpunkt, den ich an der ganzen
Sache habe. Auf der einen Seite wird erzählt,
man soll nicht nur ein Held spielen,
allerdings,
und ich sehe das genauso, man sollte nicht
nur ein Held spielen, weil ich meine Grandmaster
äh, ist quasi
Großmeister, das heißt
nicht Mercy-Links-Klicker.
Ähm, aber auf der anderen Seite
wird, ähm, quasi
Switchen nicht belohnt und vor allem Crewplay
nicht gefördert oder sonst
was. Oder halt Teamplay
nicht gefördert.
Null? Du hast so eine komische
Dynamic-Queue für alle
und das war's.
Gibt es
ein ordentliches, ähm,
Gilden, Clan, äh,
Community-System oder wie auch immer
man das nennen mag
und dementsprechend auch eine Rangliste
dafür, wird es um ein Vielfaches mehr
motivieren.
Ne, mir geht's gar nicht darum, dass es keine Helden gibt,
die man nicht zusammenspielen kann.
Ich meinte, vom Game an sich wird es
nicht gefördert, dass Leute
sich jetzt, äh, zum Beispiel zu Gruppen
zusammenschließen und sagen, hey, wir wollen
jetzt zusammenspielen und uns verbessern.
Das Einzige, was es gibt, ist, nach dem Spiel dieses
wollt ihr im Team spielen.
Das ist auch das Einzige.
Überlegt euch mal, wie geil das in Overwatch wäre,
wenn es
ingame gefördert wird,
dass du,
wie auch immer man das nennt, Clan-System,
Community-System,
das ist eigentlich vollkommen egal, Gruppensystem,
wie auch immer, wenn du dann
deine eigene Community, deinen eigenen Clan
aufmachen könntest, mit festen Leuten
und quasi diesen Clan
auflevelst.
Aufleveln in Form von, du spielst
halt gegen andere
6 Decks.
Das wird das Ranking
viel einfacher machen, das wäre
auch deutlich motivierender, weil du halt
immer mit den ähnlichen Leuten spielst.
Ich meine, das ist utopisch für ein Amateur-Team,
dass man, ähm, also ich meine
mit Amateur-Team wirklich Amateure,
Leute, die halt auch nicht jetzt unbedingt jeden
Tag 5 Stunden spielen, ähm,
dass du da immer die gleichen 6 Leute hast.
Deswegen wäre es ja gerade gut,
wenn es so ein System gibt,
wo du halt sowas wie Communities
oder Clans machen kannst.
Und diese Community, beziehungsweise
diesen Clan, wo du dann sagst, hey, hast du 10 Leute drin,
hast halt quasi eine Gruppe aus 10 Leuten
und
machst dann halt ein 6 Deck abends draus
oder wenn du halt genug Leute online hast und spielst zusammen
und den ratest du halt als
Einheit. Fertig.
Dann kannst du das raten wie ein 1 on 1.
Und das wird, das wird so viel mehr motivieren.
Overwatch ist ein Game, das macht eigentlich
nur Bock, wenn du es im Team spielst.
Und so richtig Teamplay gibt's
einfach in der Solo-Q
Rangliste nicht.
Das höchste der Gefühle ist mal,
dass du irgendwie eine Hanzo-Saria-Kombi machst
oder sowas. Also ich finde es
am sinnvollsten, wenn es eine richtige Solo-Q
gäbe und eine 6 Deck
Team-Q. Und nicht,
wo man sich einfach anmelden kann, random
mit einem 6 Deck,
sondern halt mit einem Community- oder
Clan-System dahinter. Das wäre richtig geil.
Und das würde mit Sicherheit auch motivieren.
Guck mal, wie geil das wäre. Ich meine,
du musst ja dann nicht dieses Master-Grandmaster-
Diamond-Sonstwas-System beibehalten.
Aber wenn du dann,
wenn dann quasi dein Clan
GM-Clan ist oder sowas, das wäre mega cool.
Das würde auch motivieren,
die Leute zusammenzuspielen und sich zusammen
zu verbessern. Das ist ja das, was in Overwatch
Spaß macht. So, wir reiten
mal Richtung Wüste, dass wir gleich
Dings, Naga-Crime machen können.
Spiel doch einfach zu 6.
Ich sehe da ein Problem nicht. Hast du mal
...
6 Deck gespielt?
Das lohnt sich null. Und es ist
auch nicht wirklich motivierend.
So mit dem System aktuell.
Also, und das
Geile ist halt, man könnte so viel machen.
Wenn du jetzt 6 Decks
spielst, hast du erstens
Q-Time der absoluten Hölle.
Und pro Sieg
kriegst du dann 2 SR.
Yeah! Deswegen bin ich
immer noch für reine Solo-Q
und für ne
Clan-Q
oder wie auch immer man das nennen mag.
Ah, der Stream ruckelt wieder, sehe ich. Yeah!
Telekom, nice!
Das macht ihr gut, Telekom.
Wie mich das abfuckt, dass das immer laggt.
Wie, das ist nicht Sinn der Sache.
Ranking spielen, ohne
im Ranking aufsteigen zu können, ist nicht Sinn der Sache.
Nee, dann verstehe
ich Ranking wahrscheinlich falsch.
Wenn du zusammenspielst und dich zusammen
verbessertest, dann solltest du auch zusammen im Rang aufsteigen.
Was der Sinn eines
Ranking-Systems ist.
Ja genau, das ist das Problem. Das kann durchaus
sein, dass du mit Solo-Leuten gematcht wirst.
Deswegen fände ich ne reine, es ist vor allem
wäre es auch viel einfacher,
wenn du quasi ne Team-Q
hast, also mit Team-Q meine ich 6-Stack.
Und, also wenn du auf der
einen Seite deine Solo-
Flex-Q, die kann man ja meinetwegen beibehalten,
wobei ich es schöner fänden würde, wenn du ne richtige
vollständige Solo-Q hättest.
Und wenn du auf der einen Seite eine Solo-Q hättest,
auf der anderen Seite hast du deine
Team-Q, deine 6-Stack-Q,
dass das Rating,
für diese Teams wäre viel, viel einfacher.
Alter, Telekom, kriegt ihr euch mal bald
ein? Das Ruckeln ist doch nicht normal,
ey.
Ich seh's auch, ich hab total viele,
äh, total viele Framedrops hier beim Upload.
Man sieht ja auch,
es ist, bei mir ist hier nix, äh,
nix Rendering-Lag, das ist einfach, weil
der Upload rumspackt.
Das Todes.
Ohne Kacke, ey.
So, so hat es doch
die letzten Tage auch nicht rumgeruckelt, oder Leute?
Das ist heute, gefühlt ist es
heute ganz extrem.
Richtig. I'm, oh, das kann ich nicht
aussprechen, I'm so uncreative, lol.
Das, ich find, ich versteh auch nicht,
warum Blizzard sich nicht einfach an
anderen Games orientieren kann.
Ich mein, LOL hat mittlerweile auch ne,
ne Rollen-Q drinne, hab ich noch nie
ausprobiert, keine Ahnung, wie gut das funktioniert,
aber man sieht, es funktioniert.
Ähm, Spiele wie Dota haben auch ne Solo-Q
und ne Team-Q.
Also man könnte sich vieles von anderen
Spielen abgucken, wo es funktioniert.
Und in MOBA, was
5 gegen 5 ist, oder 6 gegen 6,
sollte jetzt vom Ranking her eigentlich
nicht viel
Unterschied sein, so intern, wie das mathematisch
funktioniert, als Overwatch.
Und du hast noch nen Vorteil,
wenn du Solo-Q machst,
ähm, hast du, hast du natürlich einfacher
die Leute zu matchen, aber worauf ich raus will,
wenn du ne Team-Q machst, ist es ziemlich
einfach, eben die Teams zu raten.
Du musst ja dann nicht Spieler 1, Spieler
2, Spieler 3, Spieler 4, Spieler 5,
6 raten, du ratest dann
Team A und Team B.
Wenn Team B gewinnt, war
Team B besser, bekommt
Team B und nicht die Spieler,
sondern Team B, also quasi
die Gaming-Community oder der Clan
bekommt dann halt Punkt.
So, und was man dann noch machen könnte,
so, wo man mal sieht, es gibt halt
mega, mega viele Sachen, die man, die man
machen könnte, ja, und Sachen,
die, die, die fallen ja nicht nur mir
ein, die fallen total vielen Leuten ein. Ich find's halt auch schade,
dass da, dass da Blizzard nix dazu
sagt, ist, du könntest dann auch sowas wie
automatisch generierte Turniere machen.
Du könntest ohne Probleme
dann sagen, okay,
nachdem es jetzt ja hier Clans, was auch
immer gibt, ähm, könntest
du automatisch generierte, äh,
Turniere am Wochenende machen, wo du
sagst, hey, ähm, kannst du, gibt's
doch in StarCraft, glaub ich, auch mittlerweile, oder
was StarCraft? Ich weiß
nicht. Aber es gibt einige Games, wo das gibt,
da hast du automatisch generierte Turniere, musst du dich
anmelden, und
da könntest du dann sogar Diamond-Turniere
machen. So, jetzt mal die ganzen
Tempel zählen. Sag mal, Leute,
habt ihr nur ich den Eindruck, oder laggt's heute mehr als sonst?
Es ruckelt heute mehr als die letzten
Tage, ne? Wohnt sich das
überhaupt zum Marketplace? Oh, fuck!
Moment, gibt's hier überhaupt ein Marketplace?
Hier gibt's keinen, oder?
Der nächste
Marketplace ist in Altinova.
Na, dann leg ich's mal
hier in Vault rein. Hier sollte's halt so
blub, äh, hier sollte's schon ein bisschen Platz haben.
Ah. Wird später
verkauft. Easy
Money, Easy Life. Da
Golden Dagger wird noch verkauft.
Nochmal Easy 5 Millionen.
Ich guck gleich, Chat.
Reparieren, zack.
Golden Dagger, so.
Damn.
Jetzt haben wir wieder ordentlich Money. Easy Money, Easy
Life haben wir hier. Okay.
Ja, sind wir eigentlich ready für
Naga-Crime im Kreis.
So, äh, ich muss mal Chat lesen, hab
paar Sachen hier nicht mitbekommen
jetzt. Problem wäre dann, wenn
man nicht immer diese gleichen sechs Leute hat.
Naja. Ist
ist...
Ich weiß nicht, ob das ein großes
Problem ist.
Weil ich mein, du könnt's ja, du
deswegen mein ich ja, du könnt's sowas wie Clan
Community machen, wo du halt zehn Leute oder so
drinne hast, weil es halt als
äh, Gelegenheit
beziehungsweise Amateur-Spieler schwierig
ist,
immer die gleichen sechs Leute zu kriegen. Aber selbst
wenn's immer die gleichen sechs Leute wären, fänd ich
auch nicht schlecht. Aber auf der anderen
Seite, wenn du halt nicht immer mit den
gleichen sechs Leuten spielst, wär ja auch nicht so schlimm.
Es wird dann halt die Gruppe geratet.
Und ja, du könntest natürlich dann einen viel
besseren Spieler in den Clan oder in die
Gruppe holen, dann würdest du halt
steigen damit.
Okay, ich mein, die Gruppe spielt ja dann auch besser.
Das würde dann beispielsweise
auch dazu führen, dass man so Sachen
wie Triple Tank ordentlich im Rank spielen
kann. Was halt schwierig ist,
ohne ordentliches Teamplay und ohne Supports,
auf die du dich verlassen kannst und
äh, Reinhards, die meinen, sie müssen
flanken oder was auch immer.
Das geht halt nur, wenn du mit einem gewissen Maß
an Teamplay daran gehst, was es halt
so im Rank nicht gibt.
Und ein gewisses Maß an Teamplay kann
es in diesem aktuellen Rank auch gar nicht
geben, weil es ganz entscheidend und wichtig
dafür ist, dass man die Spieler
kennt, mit denen man spielt. Dass man weiß, wie sie
in speziellen Situationen reagieren
und was sie machen. Das weißt du halt
von, äh,
dem Typ, mit dem du noch nie
gespielt hast, im Rank nicht. Oder
selbst wenn du mit dem öfter spielst, weißt du das nicht.
Nein, die Spieler sind
höchstens mit schuld.
Ich bin
am Einen diese Sache mit, die Spieler ist schuld.
Das ist genauso wie diese ganze Toxic-Geschichte.
Blizzard ist dafür verantwortlich,
beziehungsweise ist es egal, ob es jetzt Blizzard ist
oder der Hersteller ist dafür verantwortlich,
die Rahmenbedingungen so zu stecken,
dass es sich gut entwickeln kann.
Ja, dass die Spieler manchmal ein bisschen
über die Stränge schlagen, dass hier
dass die Leute auch mal ordentlich
toxic sind, sieht man auch in anderen MMOs,
MOBAs, was auch immer.
Aber die Rahmenbedingungen müssen vorhanden sein.
Und wenn die nicht vorhanden sind,
wie beispielsweise das Reporting-System
in Overwatch, was teilweise
in sich widersprüchlich ist,
sind die Rahmenbedingungen einfach nicht da.
Wobei, zum Beispiel, was ich meine mit
das, ähm, ich, Leute,
ich gebe zu, es hat mit BDO jetzt überhaupt nichts
zu tun, ja. Wenn ihr was zu BDO wissen
wollt, vom größten BDO, vom best
ausgerüsteten, größten BDO-Loop,
könnt ihr gerne fragen, ich beantworte
es dann auch. Ähm, was wollte
ich denn sagen? Fuck.
Mit was habe ich jetzt angefangen?
Ah, genau, das Reporting-System.
Also, was ist, es gibt zum Beispiel
totalen Widerspruch im
Reporting-System. Ähm,
zum Beispiel, ich bin mir nicht mehr sicher aus dem Kopf, welche
Kategorie das ist. Ich glaube, ich glaube, entweder
ist es Griefing oder Teamplay. Ich glaube, es ist Teamplay.
Bei Teamplay steht drinnen,
ähm, wenn jemand
offensichtlich nicht das
Objective spielen möchte,
dann ist das ein Reporting-Grund.
So.
Ähm, wenn jemand
allerdings einen nicht optimalen
Held pickt, ist das
kein Reporting-Grund. Was ich übrigens
auch so sehe. Ein nicht
optimaler Held ist selbstverständlich nicht
automatisch ein Reporting-Grund.
Also, nur weil jetzt jemand gut mit Hanzo ist
und Hanzo mal pickt, heißt es nicht, dass man den
automatisch bannen muss. Aber,
es gibt offensichtliche Picks,
die quasi gleichzusetzen
sind mit, möchte nicht das Objective spielen.
Zum Beispiel auf Hanamura
Attack Torbjörn.
Das geht einfach nicht. Und das ist
faktisch nicht das Objective
spielen. Und solange du quasi schon ein
Reporting-System hast, wo quasi
absolut unklar ist, was Sache ist,
das meine ich mit, die Rahmenbedingungen stimmen
einfach nicht. Plus das, was ich
am Anfang gemeint habe mit Patches,
die teilweise Monate dauern,
Helden, die keinen Spaß machen,
zu spielen, gegen sie zu spielen, mit ihnen
zu spielen. Ja, Black Reaper,
das Problem kann es natürlich geben.
Also, wenn sich rausstellen sollte, es funktioniert
überhaupt nicht, okay.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall ein Versuch, das
Spiel besser zu machen. Und ich glaube,
in Overwatch, sagen wir mal so, in Overwatch und LoL
kann man, denke ich, was Teamplay anbelangt,
ziemlich gut vergleichen.
Wobei
ich halt denke, wenn man das ordentlich
umsetzen würde, dürfte
eine Team-Queue die größte
Motivation sein, die es gibt.
Weil ich meine, ich habe ja den
Unterschied am eigenen Leib erfahren,
wie das ist, in organisiertem
Team zu spielen
und in der Solo-Queue.
Beziehungsweise halt in der
Dynamic-Queue.
Es ist einfach ein Riesenunterschied, wie du
zusammenspielst. Und Overwatch,
was Overwatch ausmacht,
ist gerade ja auch mit das Teamplay.
Overwatch hat zwar viele Helden,
die unterschiedlich
anspruchsvoll zu spielen sind,
aber bis auf wenige Ausnahmen,
also sowas wie Tracer, Genji,
Ana und sowas, sind die meisten Helden
jetzt relativ simpel zu lernen.
Die meisten, nicht alle.
Also das, so das richtige,
das richtige Skill-Cap,
was das nach oben treibt in Overwatch,
ist Teamplay.
Teamplay, was in
Ranked so nicht stattfindet.
Und was extrem motivierend
ist, wenn man eben mit
festen Leuten spielt und
geile Aktionen reißt, die man alleine
nicht reißen konnte, weil man eben
sich blind versteht.
Das ist geil, das macht übelst
Bock. Und Blizzard
sagt ja auch selbst, Overwatch ist eigentlich ein Spiel,
was man am besten mit
Kollegen, was auch immer, mit Freunden,
sonst wie, zusammen im Team spielt.
Deswegen verstehe ich nicht, dass gerade sich das
nicht widerspiegelt im Spiel.
Heute bei 95%.
Heute bei 100%. Easy Rekt.
Easy.
Übrigens,
schreibt mich mal wieder an, wenn Buff Food dran ist.
Ich glaube, als nächstes ist mir Mediamil dran.
Und ich brauch Black Spirit.
Exp.
Wat?
Hab ich keine Energie mehr?
Ich hab keine Energie mehr.
Ich will gar keine Black Spirit expolen.
Sag mal, Leute, hab ich das Gefühl,
ich hab schon dreimal gefragt, wahrscheinlich habt ihr auch schon
drauf geantwortet, ich hab's wohl nicht gesehen,
dass es heute mehr ruckelt im Stream und mehr
laggt als sonst?
Also das würde ja dafür sprechen, dass die Telekom
heute wieder irgendwie komische Dinger macht.
Muss gleich nochmal meine BDO-Stats gucken.
Jetzt hab ich
seit ein paar Minuten dürfte es nicht mehr ruckeln, oder?
Jetzt hab ich nämlich keine Dropped
Frames mehr. Und Upload
alles grün. Aber es müsste jetzt eigentlich
seit ein paar Minuten nicht mehr geruckelt haben.
Gestern hat's gefühlt gar nicht geruckelt.
Das ist total tagesabhängig.
Ja, Akimopros, ist so.
Und ich behaupte mal, jeder, der
auch ein bisschen nur versucht hat, Overwatch
ernsthaft zu spielen, und mit
ernsthaft meine ich jetzt gar nicht, dass man versucht,
irgendwelche Cups, Turniere, sonst was zu gewinnen,
sondern einfach mal versucht,
quasi mit definierten
Rollen im Team mit den gleichen Leuten
sich einzuspielen und
mal ein paar Sachen zu probieren.
Oder mal auszuprobieren, die halt
nur klappen, wenn man im Team spielt.
Es kann auch so was Simples sein, wie
nen Boost mit der Mei-Wall oder sowas.
Dann sieht man, was es für ein
geiles Gefühl ist, wenn man zum Beispiel
was ja mal ne Zeit lang voll
im Trend war, sich mit der Mei-Eiswall
bei Eichenwalde
bei Eichenwald über
den ersten
Chokepoint drüber liftet.
Das ist einfach nice.
Hast du noch Ultra-High-Quality
auf BDO aktiviert? Ah!
Der Sebarro!
Da hat er recht!
Klar, das hab ich doch gestern angemacht.
Ist er müde, durch das Spiel zu gucken?
Ja, kann ich verstehen.
Der Naga-Kreisel-Grind
ist wahrscheinlich nicht so das Spannendste
für Leute zuzugucken, die nicht BDO spielen.
Aber das Schöne am Kampfsystem von BDO ist,
das macht Spaß.
Ich hätte das ja am Anfang auch nicht
für möglich gehalten.
Moment, es gibt ne Energiesparfunktion
in dem Spiel?
Moment!
Unten sagst du?
Wo genau?
Wo ist das?
Wo ist die Energiesparfunktion?
Ist das das neue COD?
Ja, Fantasy Warfare.
Ich bin zu blöd, ich find das nicht.
Graphic Card Low Power Mode
oder so heißt es.
Äh!
Oh, dieses Optionsmenü ist so geil
in dem Game.
Siehst nix.
Hier ist es schon mal nicht.
Hier!
Okay.
Allerdings, wie gesagt, es lag wahrscheinlich
nicht am Game oder so, ne?
Dass es geruckelt hat.
Es war Telekom Upload.
Ich mein, wir haben Overwatch
mit den gleichen Settings gestreamt
und 300 FPS.
Da war am Anschlag der Rechner
und es hat nicht geruckelt.
COD Fantasy Warfare.
Wo wir da gerade dabei sind,
das wäre wirklich ein Szenario,
was ich mir gut vorstellen könnte, ne?
Das wäre einfach mal was Neues.
Es müsste kein
Call of Duty sein.
Hat jemand damals,
so 2006 rum,
äh, ähm, wie hieß es?
Dark Messiah of Might and Magic gespielt
in Multiplayer?
Das war quasi
ein klassenbasierter
Fantasy-Shooter.
So mit Zauberer, Bogenschütze, Nahkämpfer.
Ich glaub sogar Stelzer.
Das hat
übertrieben Bock gemacht, das Game.
Der Multiplayer.
Bis dann der Hersteller nach ein paar Monaten
gesagt hat, oh Mist, der Multiplayer
ist ja voll erfolgreich.
Ähm, ähm.
Ne, den wollen wir jetzt nicht weiter supporten.
Das kostet uns zu viel Arbeit. Wir patchen ihn raus.
Oder machen die Server aus oder sowas.
Richtig da hängen geblieben.
Max, bist du eigentlich in deiner
Firma Ausbilder für den FISI oder
bildet ein Kollege von dir aus?
Ähm, also ich hab keinen
Ausbilderzettel.
Aber die meiste
Zeit, oder so ein Großteil der Zeit
sind die Azubis bei mir.
Der letzte jetzt nicht,
aber davor die meisten schon.
Und das könnte ich mir als, das könnte
ich mir wirklich als geiles
Szenario oder ein bisschen frischeres
Szenario für nen, für nen Shooter
vorstellen, wenn das im Fantasy,
in irgendeinem Fantasy-Setting wäre. Oder was ich noch cooler
fänden würde, wenn man schon
ein bestehendes Fantasy-Setting nimmt.
Es muss ja nicht immer Herr der Ringe sein.
Aber das erste,
was mir ein bisschen düsterer einfallen würde,
wäre sowas wie Warhammer.
Es muss ja nichts
Neues sein. Und es muss auch nicht immer Herr der Ringe sein.
Und wenn man noch
weniger Fantasy-Elemente
haben will, dann holt man sich
für 50 Billiarden
die Game of Thrones Lizenz für Games
und macht nen Shooter draus. Easy.
Hey man, irgendwo muss
Activision und EA noch mit der Kohle hin.
Da sollen sie mal nen Game of Thrones Shooter
machen.
Voll.
Ist das Setting wirklich
so relevant?
Teilweise. Weil du kannst
manche Sachen einfach sinnvoller
machen in einem Fantasy-Setting.
Anstatt
in einem Real-Life-Setting.
Ich mein,
Bogenschütze in einem Fantasy-Setting
ist schon ein bisschen einfacher zu machen als
ein krasser Bogenstelzer.
Oder ein Zauberer ist in einem Fantasy-Setting
einfacher zu machen als
in irgendeinem Real-Life-Setting.
Doch, ich hab Game of Thrones geguckt,
allerdings nur bis Season 3.
Und danach hab ich mir nur noch die Zusammenfassung
nach jeder Season auf YouTube angeguckt.
Und ich hab's nur bis Season 3
geguckt,
weil, und das ist
für viele der Grund, warum sie Game of Thrones geil finden,
weil mir's irgendwann einfach
zu viel gelabert und
zu wenig passiert ist.
In Game of Thrones wird immer so unglaublich
viel gelabert.
Vielleicht ist es ja in Originalsprache besser,
aber ich hab's auf Deutsch geguckt.
Es wird so viel gelabert und das meistert am Ende
überhaupt keine Auswirkung auf irgendwas.
Und es passiert nichts.
Gefühlt,
eine Folge lang passiert dann was.
Warum sind hier so viele Leute?
Du hast nach der ersten Staffel aufgehört.
Die erste Staffel fand ich cool.
Das war aber was Neues.
Zweite Staffel fand ich auch noch nice.
Aber irgendwie
ist mir dann einfach zu wenig passiert.
Und danach, ich hab mir jetzt ja immer
die Zusammenfassung angeguckt,
dass sich die letzten paar Staffeln
schon gebessert.
Quasi, als die auch mehr Budget hatten dann.
Ich muss mal
den Channel wechseln.
Hier ist zu viel los.
Kurz bevor die Nacht anfängt.
Hier ist nicht so crowded, da gehen wir jetzt hin.
Die letzte Staffel lohnt auf jeden Fall.
Ja, ich hab mir die, ich guck mir immer
Highlight-Videos an.
Letzte Staffel hat ein paar coole Sachen gehabt.
Moment, da ist ja schon
der nächste Typ da am Start.
So, wir machen jetzt unseren Daily-Exp an.
Daily-Exp.
Auf.
Moment, da oben.
So, jetzt werden wir erstmal hier alle Nagas
massakrieren.
Läufst du immer nur im Gleis und tötest die gleichen Gegner?
Fast.
Der Kreis sieht manchmal ein bisschen anders aus.
Aber im Prinzip ist das so.
Ja.
Der Grind ist halt real.
Vorhin war ich noch an einem anderen Spot.
Gestern war ich mit Fabian zusammen auch noch weiter
in der Wüste.
Aber ich finde so XP-mäßig
und vor allem wie simpel die Mobs
wie leicht man die Mobs
bashen kann, ist das hier ein echt guter Spot.
Wie viele Leute da hinten sind.
Da muss ich jetzt woanders hin.
Oh, da ist ein Boss.
Da will ich nicht hin.
Klingt spannend.
Es ist spannender als es aussieht.
Wobei mir
Grinding ja auch nicht, also mittlerweile
auch nicht mehr so viel ausmacht.
Vor allem mit dem Kampfsystem von BDO
macht es mir echt Spaß.
Lohnt sich nochmal anzufangen.
Nachdem du das Game ja schon gespielt hast,
weißt du ja ungefähr wie es ist.
Da hat sich jetzt nicht allzu viel dran geändert.
Es ist jetzt viel einfacher zu leveln.
Bis zu, sagen wir mal so
bis 60 eigentlich.
Geht viel schneller als früher.
Und du kriegst halt auch mit den Daily Rewards
und so viele Sachen
die es früher schwieriger waren
dran zu kommen.
Also die legen schon Wert darauf, dass neue Leute oder
Spieler aufschließen können.
Als Wiedereinsteiger kommst du auch, darfst du auch
auf Channels drauf, wo es mehr XP gibt.
Das du noch schneller leveln kannst.
Und nachdem du es schon gekauft hast
denke ich, schadet es sich nicht
das Game nochmal anzugucken.
Ich glaube ich habe mich verlaufen.
Moment, wo bin ich denn?
Ne, passt.
Ähm,
Sbarro, das geht,
aber die Gegner hier sind zu schnell tot.
Und die stehen auch schon ganz gut auf dem Haufen.
Haha.
Nockey habe ich noch nie gespielt.
Äh, WWPD,
wenn es das ist, was du mir geschickt hast,
dann ist es doch der Chef, der einfach nur
blödes Zeugs erzählt.
Dass die Kekse nicht echt sind und sonst was.
Oder kommt da noch mehr?
Ich warte bei neuen Overwatch-Heroes
bis es ein Held gibt.
Bis es ein Intro-Video gibt.
Wo man sich dann auch ungefähr vorstellen kann,
was der Held macht.
Ich suche gerade nach einem 54er Crying-Spot.
Ähm,
kennst du dich da aus?
Also, auskennen ist zu viel gesagt.
Aber ich kann dir sagen, wo wir gelevelt haben.
Und das sah ganz gut aus.
Einmal,
mal gucken, dass hier keine Mobs am Start sind.
Einmal weiß ich nicht,
ob man mit 74, äh,
mit 54 hier schon,
Moment,
ob du hier schon hin kannst,
oder wahrscheinlich noch nicht.
Entweder da, oder,
oder da,
oder wenn das gar nicht geht,
dann kannst du zum Catfish-Spot gehen.
Wenn ich jetzt wüsste, wo der ist.
Hier unten irgendwo, ne?
Wo ist der Catfish-Spot?
Da haben wir nämlich gelevelt damals zusammen.
Das weiß ich noch.
Weiß nicht, wo der Catfish-Spot ist.
Hier, da. Der ist auch gut.
Zum leveln.
Gib dick Exp und Geld.
Für low, low AP
und low Level.
Hier ist er schon wieder so voll.
Fuck.
Ich hab meinen XP-Buff gezündet.
Ich kann jetzt hier nicht so lange rumfackeln.
Meinst du Catfish ausreichend für 54?
Ganz ehrlich, ich kenne keinen anderen Spot.
Ich weiß, mein Gear sieht
relativ gut aus, aber ich bin auch noob in dem Game.
Aber leveln geht schnell.
Also bis 56
kriegst du easy hin.
Wir gehen jetzt anders.
Wir machen das jetzt vorbei.
Wo laufe ich hin?
Wir machen jetzt die Runde da hinten.
Gehen jetzt hier vorbei
und dann nach hinten wieder.
Gucken wir mal, ob da irgendwo frei ist,
wo man kreiseln kann.
AP ist bei 112.
Da müsstest du das eigentlich ganz gut packen schon.
Ach nee, nee, sorry.
Falscher Name, vergiss es.
Äh, Buff Food, Buff Food.
Was ist jetzt das da, ne?
Kannst du mal das
Karten-Interface erklären,
warum es diese Striche zwischen den
Spots gibt?
Äh...
Du meinst die...
Du meinst diese...
Das da!
Diese weißen...
Bögen.
Oder?
Meinst du das?
Das ist, dass du...
Warte mal.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich ein Node hab, wo ich dir das dran zeigen kann.
Aber du kannst ja
Nodes aufleveln.
Mit Energie.
Du kannst ja spezielle Nodes verbessern.
Und du musst dafür
alle Nodes auf dem Weg
haben.
Also du musst quasi auf allen Nodes auf dem Weg
Punkte investieren.
Und dass du halt siehst, wie der Weg ist.
Wie du diesen Node erreichen kannst.
Dafür sind die Striche da.
Also...
So, dass du jetzt hier irgendwas
investieren kannst,
musst du erst auf dem...
Guck, hier sieht man es.
Musst du erstmal den investieren.
Dann hast du einen Punkt, dass du da
bei dem nächsten Node was reinstecken kannst.
Dass du halt siehst, welchen
Weg du quasi
ausbauen musst, um zum jeweiligen
Node zu kommen, sind die Striche da.
Ich versuch das gleich nochmal.
So.
Okay.
So, hier habe ich quasi schon
Contribution Points reingehauen.
Und da sieht man, das ist quasi von hier
ist jetzt Gold geworden.
Jetzt dürfte ich quasi da auch
Punkte reinstecken.
Du dürft hier keine Punkte reinstecken, ohne da nicht
Punkte reingesteckt zu haben.
Du investierst in Nodes,
um dort Arbeiter
zu platzieren.
Und für dich Sachen abbauen zu lassen.
Oh, fuck.
Das ist ein Boss. Da will ich jetzt nicht hin.
Warum ist hier so voll?
Die sollen sich mal alle... Die sollen sich verpissen.
Du kannst an Nodes
kannst du Arbeiter für dich Material abbauen
lassen.
Wie voll es hier ist. Ich hätte doch den Server nochmal
wechseln sollen.
Sag mal. The fuck.
Warum ist es hier so voll?
Hallo Yoshi.
Aufwisser. Move dich.
Ich glaube hier ist jetzt ein bisschen weniger los.
Hoffentlich. Moment.
Jetzt geht es weiter.
Hinten geht es weiter.
So.
Hat dir die Erklärung was gebracht auf der Map
jetzt? Also ich muss sagen
mit diesem Workout-Node-System,
bis auf die paar Punkte, die wir da ausgebaut haben bei mir,
kenne ich mich auch nicht sonderlich gut aus.
Es gibt halt wohl
ein paar Nodes, die sich richtig lohnen, weil da
Material abgebaut wird, was es sonst nirgendwo
gibt.
Ne, PvZ spielen wir an Silvester durch.
Da haben wir auch noch
was zu tun.
Aber es gibt zum Beispiel richtig gute Spots.
Fabian hat gemeint, hier unten ist
einer der besten. Fuck.
Wo war der jetzt?
Der hier glaube ich. Ja.
Das hier ist wohl einer der wichtigsten
Spots oder wichtigsten
Nodes, weil dort
unten dieses Trace
Trace of Dingsbums Zeugs
abgebaut wird. Das muss wohl eines der
besten Nodes sein, die man so haben kann.
Willst du dich zu Silvester nicht
zukippen? Ich weiß es noch nicht genau.
Aber eher nicht.
Eher nicht.
Und wenn nicht,
dann mache ich Silvester streben.
Scheiß auf
Relive. Brauche
Relive.
60 Kryten.
Das kann doch der Fabian sagen können, oder?
WWPD, welches Bier trinkst
du am liebsten? Ich trinke eigentlich gar nicht gerne Bier.
Also wenn es was
Alkoholisches sein muss.
Ich sagte, die meisten
Sachen schmecken mir nicht so richtig gut.
Wenn es was Alkoholisches sein muss, dann Whisky.
Also ordentlich.
Hier ist zu wenig Lowes.
An Mobs.
Na das mit Easy
90 in der Nacht war
wohl ein bisschen sehr
optimistisch geschätzt.
Ich mobs da.
Da ist schon wieder die nächsten Leute am starten.
Ey, da fuck.
Ich wechsel jetzt nochmal den Channel.
Wie ist es eigentlich dazu gekommen, dass du wieder BDO spielst?
Weil ich mit dem Fabian
wieder MMO spielen will.
Spielst du eigentlich noch mit der Zowie Maus? Ja.
Mit der
Zowie EC2
A.
Beste Maus, die ich je hatte.
Was mir an der gut
gefällt ist, dass es einfach simpel ist.
Ich hatte ja
vorher Logitech G502.
Das war auch an sich, also von den Features
her steckt die Zowie Maus immer locker in die
Tasche. Also Feature mäßig war
die G502 das Beste, was
ich je hatte. Aber die war
mir einfach zu schwer. Das was ich bei der
Zowie gut finde, die kann nichts
im Endeffekt. Die hat zwei
Tasten nebendran, ein Mausrad und
links und rechts Maustaste.
Fertig, mehr hat die nicht. Die kann nichts.
Aber was
sie kann, kann sie gut und
sie ist leicht. Und
liegt gut in der Hand.
Äh, Sibaro kann ich machen, ja.
Hier ist ein bisschen mehr als an Mobs da.
Übrigens, jetzt ruckelt das
Game gerade, das liegt nicht an der Telekom.
Das liegt an BDO.
Äh,
Yoshi, ich trink auch kaum was.
Also wirklich wenig.
Wie gesagt, eigentlich nix.
Und wenn's was
Alkoholisches sein muss, dann
am liebsten Whisky.
Und davon trinkt man ja auch nicht viel.
Also davon trinkt man, vor allem wenn es halt
was Gescheites ist. Das kostet halt auch
ein paar Euro.
Dann
haut man sich davon jetzt ja auch nicht die halbe
Flasche rein. Nur ein
kleines bisschen.
Ah, hier sind schon viele Mobs.
Wie viel hast du eigentlich
für die CPU bezahlt?
Hab keine
Übersicht, was der eigentlich normalerweise kostet
ohne den ganzen Aufpreis wegen Verfügbarkeit.
Äh, mittlerweile ist er verfügbar.
Der 8700K. Mittlerweile
kriegst den.
Ich hab ein bisschen
mehr bezahlt als 399.
Bisschen mehr.
Also mit Versand irgendwie 420
oder so.
Ich hab aber halt, ich hab halt 3 Shops
pre-ordert. Und hatte
Glück, dass ich einen der ersten gekriegt hab.
Ich hab den jetzt ja schon 2 Monate
oder so in dem Dreh. Ich weiß gar nicht mehr.
Müssen wir mal gucken, wann ich das Video hochgeladen hab.
Okay, also die 88
packen wir.
Ups, nicht hängen bleiben, Wubbler.
Moin, hast du schon von dem
neuen
MMO-Projekt gehört? Das sieht voll nice aus.
Was von wem?
Project TL.
Nö.
Was ist Project TL?
Wann kriegst du einen Sub-Button?
Ich hab mich nicht drum gekümmert bis jetzt.
Gar nicht.
Noch gar nicht drum gekümmert.
Das sollte glaube ich
ehemals neues Lineage werden.
Oh, Lineage, das ist ja, ey, wenn einer BDO
Grind schon schlecht, schon schlimm
findet, dann ist das für ihn aber gar nichts.
Aber ich bin bei neuen MMOs
immer ein bisschen vorsichtig.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, welches das war, aber
irgendeiner, irgendein MMO, was 2018
rauskommt, hat ja auch vor ein paar Monaten
so einen Trailer gemacht, der ein bisschen für Aufruhr
gesorgt hat, wo sie erzählt haben, so
dynamisches Event-System und
bestes hier, bestes da und bla bla bla bla.
Da häng ich mir immer, mal abwarten.
Mal abwarten, Jungs, wenn das Game rauskommt.
Was da noch von der ganzen Sache übrig
ist, was ihr euch da so ausgemalt habt.
Übrigens hab ich euch schon das Neueste
erzählt. Ich hab gestern Anruf gekriegt von
dem Typ, der mein Klo
eingebaut hat.
So, jetzt kommt's, jetzt kommt's, jetzt kommt's.
Ähm, mein Klo kann
unter seltenen Umständen
anfangen zu brennen.
Hat er mir erzählt.
Stellt euch das mal vor.
Der Klo kann quasi
die Wohnung abfackeln.
Was, in welchem Jahrtausend
leben wir denn, bitteschön?
Dass man Angst haben muss,
dass sein Klo die Wohnung abbrennt.
Ja.
Ist echt der Wahnsinn, oder?
Also der Klo brennt
nicht die Wohnung ab, sondern die
Düsen, was?
Die Düsenspül, äh,
Düsenreinigungsflüssigkeit
ist anscheinend leicht entflammbar
und kann dazu führen,
dass das Klo
anfängt zu brennen.
Geil, oder?
Was kannst du dagegen machen?
Ähm, es gibt eine Anleitung
vom Hersteller, da sagt man,
man soll die Flüssigkeit entfernen
und drauf scheißen, wenn das Klo
eine Warnung ausgibt,
dass Flüssigkeit fehlt.
Und es wäre alles gut
auch ohne Flüssigkeiten.
Sobald sie eine neue, nicht so leicht
entflammbare Flüssigkeit haben,
kriegt man die als kostenloses Upgrade.
Das muss man sich
echt mal vorstellen, ja.
Jetzt muss man nicht nur Angst davor haben,
dass das Smartphone einem das Bein abfackelt
oder das Bein ankokelt in der Hose
mit dem Akku, sondern
dass sein Klo anfängt zu brennen.
Das ist schon hart.
Das ist echt hart.
Und der Hersteller meinte noch, man sollte
am besten jedes Mal den Klo ausschalten.
Das sehe ich aber nicht ein.
Aber das steht auch nur als Empfehlung da.
Also es reicht wohl, wenn man die Flüssigkeit rausmacht.
Das sehe ich nicht ein,
mein Klo quasi ein- und auszuschalten
jedes Mal, bevor ich drauf gehe,
weil ich meine, dafür habe ich ja so ein Klo,
dass ich die Funktionen benutzen kann.
Und nicht, dass ich jedes Mal einschalten muss
und dann warten muss, bis es gebootet ist oder sowas.
Also ehrlich, ne.
Ne, ne, ne, ne.
Info gleich voll.
Das sind, das sind wahre
First-World-Problems, Leute.
Es wird ja immer so aus Spaß unter alles
geschrieben, so nach dem Motto, von dem man denkt,
es ist nicht wichtig, First-World-Problems.
Aber Leute, das sind die wahren,
der Inbegriff von First-World-Problems,
was ich euch gerade erzählt habe.
Und wer jetzt,
wer hier jetzt neu ist und sich fragt,
was labert der eigentlich für einen Scheiß?
Ihr könnt euch ja bei YouTube
mein Klo-Review-Video angucken.
Da sieht man das
im Detail, was das für ein Klo ist.
Beste Investition, ja.
GenoQZ, der, du kannst, auf YouTube
kannst du mein Klo-Review gucken.
Oder wollen wir uns,
oder wollen wir uns das nach der Nacht
on-Stream nochmal angucken zusammen?
Oder wollen wir uns das nach der Nacht
on-Stream zusammen angucken?
Mittlerweile kann ich auch ein bisschen
mehr dazu sagen, weil ich habe eh nur die Hälfte,
die Hälfte gezeigt im Video,
weil ich damals gar nicht wusste,
wo, dass es den noch mehr
Knöpfe hat.
Immer doch.
Okay, sobald die Nacht vorbei ist im Video,
gucken wir uns, gucken wir uns mein Klo-Video an zusammen.
Dann reacte ich quasi
zu meinen eigenen Videos. Das ist ja auch voll im Trend
zurzeit.
Max reactet.
Zu seinen eigenen Videos,
zu seinen eigenen alten Videos reacten.
Das ist zurzeit voll angesagt auf YouTube.
Machen wir jetzt auch mal.
Quasi Winning Team Joiner.
Ich war letztens mal bei Unge auf dem Channel
wieder, hab festgestellt, jedes zweite
Video reactet der nur noch auf irgendwas.
Scheint echt angesagt zu sein, zurzeit
zu reacten.
Noch mehr als sonst.
Aber das Ausgleich, der er das da macht,
verstehe ich nicht, weil ich verbinde
React-Videos
ja in der Regel so ziemlich mit so
Low-Effort-Content irgendwo.
Und er hat ja früher
Sachen gemacht, wo man richtig gesehen hat,
dass er viel Zeit
und Mühe reingesteckt hat. Jetzt reactet er.
Aber ich mein,
warum nicht, wenn es den Leuten gefällt.
Bam!
Na, auf YouTube geht anscheinend
React auch einfacher.
Aber YouTube Deutschland,
es ist eh, quasi,
alles verloren.
Es gibt einen Trend,
den ich richtig gut finde
auf YouTube. Als ernst gemeint.
Und zwar ist
das im englischsprachigen Raum, in Deutschland
teilweise auch mittlerweile,
ist es, dass
sich
so Science-Channels
durchsetzen. Also
welche, die wirklich auch ordentlichen Content
produzieren. Sei es jetzt,
ich guck das halt ganz gerne, sei es Channels,
die sich irgendwie mit Physik beschäftigen,
Mathe beschäftigen oder irgendwie
das Universum, Schwarze Löcher, sonst was
in der Richtung. Und wo halt auch Leute
dabei sind, die Ahnung haben, wovon sie reden.
Die es nicht einfach nur so Buzzword-mäßig
machen und dann irgendwie Sachen
erzählen von Wikipedia,
wie manche Fakten-Channels. Ja, das ist auch
so ein großer Schwachsinn. Ich suche mir irgendwo
eine Seite, wo was steht und lese das dann
vor, sondern auch wirklich ordentlicher Content.
Und
das hat
relativ viele Views zurecht.
Also finde ich so ein kleiner Trend auf YouTube,
dass sich auch mal ganz
Gutes etabliert.
Oh, mein Inf ist voll.
Das geht nicht.
Es ist Nacht. Mein Inf darf jetzt nicht voll sein.
Da...
Fuck.
Okay, wir schmeißen mal ein bisschen was weg. Nicht viel.
Irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 400 oder so.
Bis zum Ende der Nacht reicht.
Reicht wahrscheinlich nicht.
Aber ich guck schon,
seit es YouTube gibt,
guck ich gerne
irgendwelche Science-Channels.
Vor allem, wo es um irgendwelche Weltraum-Stells
geht.
Das finde ich echt interessant, was es da mittlerweile alles gibt.
Und es ist halt geil,
was man mittlerweile alles
feststellen kann, wenn auch teilweise nur
indirekt so.
Ey, man muss sich mal vorstellen, man kann
mittlerweile
Rückschlüsse darauf ziehen,
aus was sich quasi die
Atmosphäre anderer
Planeten zusammensetzt,
die...
Ich weiß nicht, wie viele Lichtjahre weg sind.
Das ist schon voll abgedreht, oder?
Es geht, es geht
zur Zeit nur für Planeten
mit einer gewissen Größe, also irgendwie so
Jupiter-mäßig.
Aber, muss ich das mal vorstellen,
da ist irgendwo am Arsch der Welt,
im Universum, kreist da ein Planet
um irgendeine Sonne.
Und um irgendeinen Stern.
Und wenn er da vorbei fliegt, können wir das
analysieren und darauf
Rückschlüsse ziehen, aus was
das besteht.
Das ist so abgedreht, dass das funktioniert.
Ups.
Das ist geleckt.
Ich habe ein
Pure Forest Breath. Was ist das?
Ist das Selten?
Horse.
Irgendwas fürs Horse.
Denkst du, es gibt Aliens?
Ähm...
Wie fange ich denn da jetzt am besten an?
Ey, easy!
John ist vierte!
Lull!
Also es ist die Frage, was man als Alien sieht.
Also sprich,
was auf unserem Niveau
oder weiter, technologisch,
oder ob schon reicht, wenn
irgendwo ein bisschen was rum
klippert.
Also, wenn man sich überlegt, wie viel
wie viel Planeten wir
in den letzten Jahren, oder wie viel Planeten
in den letzten Jahren entdeckt wurden,
wie gesagt, weil ich alles noch aus Youtube-Videos,
bin kein Astrophysiker oder so,
wie viele Planeten in den letzten Jahren
entdeckt wurden,
die wahrscheinlich,
ich meine, die sind ja immer ein bisschen weiter weg,
da gewesen ist noch keiner,
die wahrscheinlich nicht zu nah und nicht zu weit
von ihrem jeweiligen Stern weg sind,
also wo es potenziell
flüssiges Wasser geben könnte,
und
in Anbetracht
der Tatsache,
wie groß allein schon das Universum ist,
was wir sehen können,
dann die Frage ist auch noch, wie viel
wie geht es danach weiter?
Wahrscheinlich einfach
genauso, noch mehr
noch mehr Universum, halt bloß
von uns nicht zu sehen.
Wobei sich dann natürlich die Frage
stellt,
wenn wir jetzt ja sagen, okay, wir haben schon so und so
viele Planeten gefunden, die theoretisch
Leben haben könnten,
ja, also sprich,
es könnte eventuell flüssiges Wasser geben,
es ist nicht zu warm, es ist nicht zu kalt,
dann ist die große Preisfrage,
wo es dann auch fast schon ein bisschen
philosophisch wird, und wo keiner so richtig
aktuell eine Antwort drauf hat,
wenn er die Chance recht...
So, was wollte ich denn jetzt machen?
Ich wollte Zeug verkaufen, ne?
Das Universum breitet sich schneller
wie Licht aus, keine Ahnung.
Also am Anfang
muss es sich ja definitiv schneller
wie Licht ausgebreitet haben,
was ja auch in Ordnung ist,
weil sich Lichtgeschwindigkeit
quasi ja nur auf das Licht im Raum
bezieht,
und nicht auf die Ausdehnung
des Raums quasi selbst,
aber wie das aktuell ist,
keine Ahnung.
Welches Note Level und Mob Level hast du
bei Nagas?
Also Note Level habe ich nichts
gelevelt, ich habe auch keine Energie gerade,
und Knowledge müsste ich mal
nachgucken. Also ich habe es zumindest
nicht irgendwie auf S oder so
einfach random, was es so gegeben hat.
Habe ich eigentlich wieder
genug Energie, um Black Spirit
zu kaufen? Nope.
Ähm, Cryptoker,
den kannst du verkaufen, du kannst mit
einem goldenen Deck ja eh, das ist
Sell Item. Aber die 5 Millionen
würde ich natürlich nicht im Inventar behalten,
sondern, ähm,
in irgendeinen Vault legen, weil Silber ist
schwer in dem Game.
Ne, nicht in einem Tag, in 2 Tagen.
4 Seraphs, übelst Glück gehabt.
Also, soweit ich in einem
YouTube Video gelernt habe, Patrick,
wo wir dabei sind,
dass ich den Trend gut finde, dass ich
solche Channels ganz gut entwickeln,
widerspricht
es sich nicht, dass das Universum
sich schneller als Lichtgeschwindigkeit
ausdehnen könnte.
Es kann sich nur innerhalb
des Universums nicht schneller als Licht
bewegen. Weil es also
heißen würde, du könntest nie von der einen Seite
zur anderen Seite fliegen. Du würdest
nämlich nie ankommen.
Wenn es sich schneller ausbreiten würde.
Äh, nein, hier wollen wir nicht runter.
Aber wirklich Fragen
dazu beantworten kann ich nicht, weil ich habe davon
YouTube Videos geguckt.
Auch kein Plan.
Äh, Sunisan, ob man das kann,
ist, äh,
bin ich mir nicht sicher, ob das
nicht noch zur Zeit im Raum
der Spekulation liegt.
Man vermute das, ja.
Also, wir können es definitiv nicht.
Äh, Yoshi, doch, klar.
Lichtgeschwindigkeit
ist überall gleich.
Also, nein, das ist Schwachsinn.
Äh, im jeweiligen Medium,
was du betrachtest, ist die Lichtgeschwindigkeit
immer gleich.
Also, wenn du dir
das jetzt, wenn du dir Licht im Wasser anguckst,
ist das immer gleich schnell.
Und wenn du dir Licht anguckst, äh,
halt im Vakuum, ist das immer gleich
schnell. Und es ist egal,
ob das ein Hightech-Laser ist,
oder
die Aldi-Taschenlampe.
Da fliegen halt irgendwelche
Photonen rum.
Und die fliegen halt mit Lichtgeschwindigkeit.
Lichtgeschwindigkeit ist nur davon abhängig,
in was.
Also, in Wasser ist es langsamer als
in der Luft.
Deswegen ist Glasfaser, deswegen ist, das ist
Debaro, das ist eine gute Sache,
deswegen ist, äh,
Licht
bei, über Glasfaser
auch nicht so schnell, wie wenn du es
quasi in der Luft übertragen würdest.
Aber wir kriegen in Deutschland
eh nie flächendeckend Glasfaser, deswegen ist es
egal.
Äh, irgendjemand hat gefragt,
was ich, was ich in Außerirdischen
fragen würde, wenn ich ihn treffe?
Ähm,
also, ich denke,
ups, oh, fuck, Moment.
So.
Ähm, ich, ich denke, da gibt's,
je nachdem, wer das fragt,
gibt's da natürlich unterschiedliche Ansätze. Wenn irgendein
Wissenschaftler was fragen würde, wäre das wahrscheinlich
irgendwas Wissenschaftliches. Ähm,
also, ich, ich, ich weiß nicht, ob ich ihn
irgendwie was, was, so Knowledge,
wissenschaftliches-mäßig fragen würde, was uns halt
was bringt. Äh, oder
irgendwas Soziales oder so, keine Ahnung.
Aber eine Sache, die mich
wirklich interessieren würde,
bei einer Außerirdischen Zivilisation,
die müssen's
ja weit gebracht haben. Ich meine, die haben's
immerhin geschafft, irgendwie von ihrem
Planet wegzukommen,
und sind so weit rumgekommen, dass sie es
geschafft haben, mich zu treffen.
Wo auch immer das dann stattfindet, ja.
Mich würde eigentlich
interessieren, wie sie's geschafft haben,
also, wie es ihre Zivilisation
geschafft hat, so an einem
Strand zu ziehen,
um das zu bewerkstelligen.
Das würde mich interessieren.
Weil das sehe ich ja bei uns
auch so als eines der größten Probleme.
Wir können in der Regel
nur an einem Strang ziehen,
wenn uns jemand,
so sinnbildlich gesprochen, so das Messer
an den Hals hält. Dann können wir an einem Strang ziehen,
ansonsten machen wir uns
lieber gegenseitig platt.
Na, also, mal angenommen,
es kommt jetzt irgendwie die Meldung,
hier, ähm, wir müssen alle sterben,
weil Asteroid einschlägt in zwei Jahren.
Da könntet ihr mal sehen,
wie sehr es die Menschheit schafft,
an einem Strang zu ziehen.
Das würden wir hinkriegen.
Weil, wenn wir es nicht hinkriegen, sind wir alle am Arsch.
Und am Arsch zu sein,
setzt unglaubliche Motivationsschübe
frei.
So, aber sobald
wir es geschafft hätten,
diese Gefahr abzuwenden,
würden wir uns wieder die Köppe gegenseitig einschlagen.
Deswegen würde
mich bei, wenn ich irgendwie
einen Alien was fragen könnte, würde ich mich fragen,
wie die es geschafft haben, dass sie alle
an einem Strang ziehen
und sich nicht gegenseitig platt machen.
Weil, ich meine, man könnte das Ganze
ja noch viel weiter spinnen,
das ist ja schon halber Philosophierungs-
Philosophierungs-Stream.
Man könnte ja quasi sagen, wenn
alle, wenn die gesamte Menschheit
an einem Strang ziehen würde,
dann bräuchtest du ja auch kein,
oder ich fang mal anders an, wenn man sich mal
anguckt, was so die Ausgaben
sind, die man hat, ist
Security, Militär
und sonst was in der Richtung ja immer relativ hoch.
Wenn man das
quasi schaffen würde, an einem Strang zu ziehen,
könnte man das ja weiter spinnen
und sagen, hey, dann bräuchte man ja auch
gar kein Militär mehr,
weil du müsstest dich nicht verteidigen
oder sonst was.
Du könntest das Geld dann quasi für bessere
Sachen investieren. Leider
ist die Welt halt nicht so.
Und nachdem es immer noch genug gestört hat,
die Leute gibt, brauchst du halt doch wieder
welche, die aufpassen,
dass, wenn was passiert,
dass du halt noch dem
was entgegenzusetzen hast.
Valkorion, ja genau.
Also wenn wir den Bruce Willis schicken,
dann wollen sie mit uns wahrscheinlich nichts zu tun haben.
Ich finde,
wir sollten den Marcel Skorpion schicken,
oder sowas.
So ein bisschen, weißt du, so kultureller
Austausch der Jugend
zwischen den Aliens und uns.
Und ich meine das gar nicht,
weil es irgendwie schlecht oder so.
Also ich habe gegen
Marcel nix.
Ich kenne ihn auch nicht wirklich.
Von den ganzen Typen auf YouTube,
die so, na, da bei jüngeren
Leuten angesagt sind, glaube
ich, wäre der wirklich noch einer der
Besseren dafür,
um ihn zu den Alien-Jugendlichen zu
schicken zum kulturellen Austausch.
Wir sollten davon absehen,
HerrTutorial oder
Bibi oder so dahin zu schicken.
Dann schicken wir lieber Marcel hin.
Oder wie heißt die eine,
die Merkel interviewt hat,
die dann irgendwie gemeint hat,
ja, das war jetzt mein erstes
Interview. Obwohl dann die Merkel so
gesagt hat, ja und, was machen sie sonst so?
Selbstdarstellung oder wie?
Wer war denn das?
Ich kannte die gar nicht. Wer wäre denn das gewesen?
Ne, nicht Lee Floyd.
Irgendein
YouTube-Grill.
Lee Floyd kenne ich, da war ich wieder.
Und wer das ist?
Das war eine Frau, genau, ich weiß auch nicht, wer.
Fast 90, ja.
Direkt.
Vielleicht kann ich wieder Black-Spirit-Exp kaufen.
Wer?
I-I-Ista-Izik.
Okay, nein, sagt mir
gar nichts.
Du reist, äh, Sunny-Sun, du reist
natürlich nicht schneller, also wenn es sowas wie ein Wurmloch
gibt, reist du natürlich durch ein Wurmloch,
bist du nicht schneller als mit
Lichtgeschwindigkeit unterwegs.
Du legst da die Strecke auch gar nicht zurück.
Du bist dann einfach woanders.
Das ist ja gerade der Sinn
bei einem Wurmloch, was heißt der Witz hinter
einem Wurmloch.
Du bist dann woanders, ohne dass
du quasi die normale Strecke von hier nach da
gelaufen bist.
Dann bist du auch nicht schneller als mit Lichtgeschwindigkeit unterwegs.
Die hat 1,1 Millionen Abos, okay, keine Ahnung.
Wie gesagt, ich kenne mich auf YouTube Deutschland
sehr rudimentär noch aus.
Das ist doch mal hier
heute ein Stream.
So philosophische Sachen und dann auch noch
das Universum Wurmlöcher und
Planeten, alter.
Sind wir hier wirklich auf Twitch
oder was? Was ist da los?
Nee, du bewegst
dich auch nicht dreidimensional schneller als
Lichtgeschwindigkeit. Du bist einfach hier, dann gehst du durchs
Wurmloch durch, dann bist du woanders.
So, und bis wir dich dann sehen können,
dauert es halt, bis das Licht von dir, weil
du bist jetzt woanders, wieder bei uns
ist. Und je nachdem, wie weit du weg bist, dann
kann das auch noch weiter dauern.
Ich hab letztens bei
Spacetime, war das glaube ich, ein Video
über Wurmlöcher geguckt.
Also du bist nicht schneller als Lichtgeschwindigkeit unterwegs.
Weil du legst
ja gar nicht so viel Weg zurück im Endeffekt.
Aber ob's
das alles so gibt und
ob wir jemals da
irgendwie in dieser Richtung was finden werden
oder gar
selbst irgendwie sowas, das
war's mal nicht.
Es gab ein Experiment,
wo wir grad bei schneller als Lichtgeschwindigkeit
sind. Es gab ein Experiment,
das war glaube ich
in Italien oder
ich glaube, es wurde irgendwie von der Schweiz
nach Italien über die Alpen oder so
irgendwelche Sachen geschickt. Und die sind
dort, wenn sie also auf
die Uhr geschaut haben, schneller
angekommen, als sie dürften,
wenn sie sich mit Lichtgeschwindigkeit bewegen.
Im Nachhinein hat sich aber rausgestellt,
die Uhren gingen falsch.
Vielleicht soll ich mich mal entmuten.
Die Uhren
gingen nicht falsch in der Schweiz, die Uhren in Italien
gingen falsch.
Ich bin ziemlich sicher, war das
in Italien, wo sie das
empfangen haben. Kann ich mich noch dran erinnern,
dass irgendwas in Italien war da.
Haben sie sich falsch gemessen.
Das war zwischen Cern und Italien genau.
Und die Uhren in Italien waren falsch.
Also wenn ich heute
60, dann morgen easy 60.
Was 93?
Ne, du hast dich glaube ich verguckt.
90. Ziemlich genau
90.
5000 Follower habe ich voll.
Jo stimmt.
Seit gestern, ne? Easy.
Geht ab.
Moin Ciro.
2000.
Was macht denn der komische Streikser
an meinen Mobs hier?
Was macht der an meinen Mobs?
So geht's nicht.
Ist immer noch alles weg hier. Suckt aber.
Oder wir leben wirklich in der Matrix.
Kann ja alles sein.
Und irgendwann kommt der Auserwählte und basht alles.
Easy.
Der hat dann quasi Hex an.
IRL.
Warum sprintest du nicht?
Zu faul mit Shift zu drücken.
Also, SunnySun, du kannst
nach aktuellem Kenntnisstand
nichts schneller,
oder was heißt nach aktuellem Kenntnisstand,
ja, du kannst nach aktuellem Kenntnisstand
nichts schneller beschleunigen
als Lichtgeschwindigkeit.
Und selbst die wirst du nicht erreichen.
Sondern vielleicht nur 99, ganz viel
999.
Sollte es
möglich sein, ist nicht so,
dass es nicht nach aktuellem Stand nicht möglich ist.
Es würde
unserem aktuellen
Verständnis vollkommen widersprechen.
Das heißt,
das ist im Prinzip einfach
Spekulation
und Fantasy.
Wenn man sich das überlegt.
Was wäre, wenn in dem Fall.
Also, du könntest theoretisch
in die Zukunft reisen, wenn du
schnell genug unterwegs wärst.
Allerdings kommst du dann nicht mehr zurück.
Ob es dir das dann bringt,
ist wieder was anderes.
Hier ist alles weg.
Die sollen abhauen.
Okay, machen wir jetzt anders.
Wir gehen jetzt wieder da hinten an.
An diese eine Düne und
bashen da die Mobs.
Stell dir mal vor, du reist in die Zukunft
und es gibt keine Menschen mehr. Ja, wäre schon scheiße.
Und du kommst nie wieder zurück.
Eine Zeit für dich ist
kein Unterschied.
Deswegen ist ja auch so,
Reise in die Zukunft ist ja
ein blöder Ausdruck dafür eigentlich.
Machst ja nicht schwupp und bist da.
Du musst einfach nur schnell genug sein.
Zeit für dich bleibt gleich.
Beziehungsweise für
dich vergeht halt die Sache drumherum.
Du musst immer schneller.
Ich weiß auch nicht,
was heute ist.
WTF?
Oh, Food.
Okay, hier waren wir jetzt.
Ja, Exp.
Aber wie wir auf die ganze
Sache eigentlich gekommen sind,
ich finde es gut, dass YouTube-Channels,
die sich mit sowas beschäftigen, zurzeit so ein bisschen
einen Boom haben. Zumindest im englischsprachigen
Moment, wo laufe ich hin?
Zumindest im englischsprachigen
Raum.
Und ein bisschen in Deutschland auch.
Hier ist ja gar nichts mehr an Mobs.
Ah ne, die sind einfach nur ausgefadet.
Wie gesagt, außer
YouTube-Videos dazu,
habe ich da auch keinen weiteren
Hintergrund.
Eigentlich wollte ich nur sagen, ich finde es gut, dass solche Channels
erfolgreich sind.
Jetzt habe ich den Twitch-Bildungs-Krieg ausgelöst.
Alter, das überhaupt schon
auf Twitch, ja?
Über Sachen wie
Wurmlöcher,
Wurmlöcher-Zeitreihen, Sonnensystem,
was auch immer diskutiert wird. Hallo,
wo sind wir hier gelandet? Das ist Twitch.
Das ist Copypasta,
Copypasta, Spam, Pogchamp,
Lul, Spam, keine Ahnung.
MeWeep, MeSpam,
ModBucker, IfBan, keine Ahnung.
Aber nicht sowas.
Jetzt ruckelt das Game wieder. Was ist da los?
Ich habe mir gestern Abend Sushi bestellt.
Könnten wir gleich nochmal bestellen.
Ich habe hier übelst Bock drauf.
Gestern haben wir Krabben-Rolls gehabt,
heute würde ich Krebsfleisch-Rolls nehmen.
Hast du Rolls?
Rolls.
Max Punch,
das wird nur,
man denkt es wird eintönig,
wird es aber nicht, weil das Kampfsystem
recht unterhaltsam ist.
Und außerdem sind die Mobs hier halt absolut trash.
Die können halt nichts. Ich mache zwei Spells,
die sind down.
Es gibt auch ein bisschen anspruchsvollere Mobs.
Aber die geben gut Exp.
Ist das nicht in allen Client-Gebieten so?
Ne.
Es gibt Gebiete, die sind besser mit der Gruppe,
also sind die Mobs für einen alleine
vielleicht nicht unbesiegbar, aber
nicht effektiv, weil man zu lang braucht.
Oder es gibt auch Gebiete,
da musst du mit Gruppe hin.
Aber ich sage es nochmal, ich bin Noob in dem Game.
Der bestausgerüsteste Noob.
Und das ohne,
dass ich einen Account gekauft hätte.
Das ist mein Account.
Einfach nur RNG-Glück.
Moment, warum ist unsere Info schon wieder voll?
ETF?
Wer war noch erst abgeben?
Okay, ich sprinte jetzt auch mal.
Okay, man hat ja gerade im Chat gemeint,
ich würde nicht sprinten.
Jetzt wird gesprintet.
Und teleportiert dabei.
Ja, deswegen streame ich das ja auch gerne.
Weil,
kann man nebenbei Chat lesen
und über irgendwie Gott und die Welt labern.
Und dabei schön im Kreis
grinden.
Oh, es ist 17.59 Uhr.
Telekom schlägt gleich zu,
wenn wir Pech haben.
Hoffen wir mal, dass die Telekom
heute nicht zuschlägt.
Gestern hat sie zugeschlagen.
Hier.
Ja, so war das gemeint, Marv.
So war das gemeint.
Über Gott und die Welt
hatten wir es ja beim Weihnachtstream schon.
Das reicht.
Warum denn Telekom?
Weil ich zwischen 17.00 Uhr und 19.30 Uhr
öfters mal DSL-Synchronisierung verliere.
Weil weiß nur die Telekom warum.
Aber sie wissen es nicht.
Weil sie kacke sind.
Weil sie ihre Sachen nicht im Griff haben.
Wow!
Dafuck! Was war das gerade für ein Ruckler?
Alter!
Ich habe mich gebeamt.
Achso, warum Telekom als Provider?
Weil sie die einzigen sind,
die mir diese Bandbreite hier anbieten können.
Also ich habe bei der Telekom
VDSL 100.
Das heißt ich habe 100 Down und 40 Up.
Davor hatte ich Unity Media
150 Down
und
5 oder 6 Up.
Und 5, ich glaube 5 Up.
5 Mbit Up hatte ich.
Das war schon zum Streamen
eigentlich zu wenig.
Und zum Uploaden auf Youtube
da wo ich eigentlich hauptsächlich aktiv bin
war es halt auch
nervig. Da hast du teilweise 1,5 Stunden
oder so gewartet bei einem bisschen größeren Video.
Und jetzt kann ich
in richtig guter Quali
1440p
60fps
kann ich die Videos rendern und auf Youtube hochladen.
Innerhalb von 15-20 Minuten
mit 40 Mbit Upload.
Und ich wäre auch gar nicht zur Telekom
gegangen, hätte Unity
Media bei mir. Warum sind jetzt alle Leute?
Nachts waren die noch nicht da.
Ich wäre auch bei Unity Media geblieben.
Also ich bin ja noch bei Unity Media.
Der Vertrag läuft ja noch.
Aber das wird gekündigt.
Ähm
Ich wäre ja auch bei Unity Media geblieben,
wenn die irgendwie eine sinnvolle Alternative
anzubieten hätten. Haben sie aber nicht.
Was ich für eine Ultra-Fans
auf der Mail halte, ehrlich gesagt.
Moment, wo bin ich denn hier überhaupt?
Die schicken mir immer Werbung so nach dem Motto
hier, es ist Zeit zu
upgraden, bla bla bla.
Und da habe ich mal nachgeguckt, was die haben.
Die haben jetzt
400 Mbit down.
Nice. Braucht eigentlich
braucht man nicht wirklich.
Mit 10 Mbit up.
Und das ist ein Verhältnis,
das sehe ich nicht ein.
Vor allem ist der
Upgrade für mich als Content Creator
sehr gut.
Wo bin ich denn hier überhaupt?
Von 5 auf 10
ist halt, naja,
von 10 auf 40 im Upload.
Das macht sich richtig bemerkbar.
So und 400 runter
brauche ich nicht.
Ich kann eher mit 100 runter
statt 150 leben und dafür 40
statt 5 up.
So und früher hatte Unity Media noch
so eine Option, dass du quasi sagen konntest,
hey, ich möchte noch mehr Upload haben.
Dann hätte ich quasi sowas machen können wie
400 runter und 20 hoch.
Das hätte ich mir auch noch gefallen lassen.
Hätte ich gesagt, okay, 400 runter ist nice,
20 hoch ist auch eine gute Verbesserung
von 5, aber
gibt es nicht mehr mit den neuen Tarifen.
Also, scheiß auf Unity Media.
Und wieder Telekom.
Mit den, ja genau Obito, so ist es
ja auch. Mit den, mit den, ich will übrigens
zurück zur Stadt, fällt mir gerade ein.
Mit den 400 down kann man
besser Werbung machen.
Das ist es.
Und der Gag ist ja eigentlich,
bei 400 runter und 10
up, ich gehe mal davon aus,
dass es diese 10 up
auch nur gibt, weil du sie
rechnerisch brauchst, um 400
down ordentlich
überhaupt ausnutzen zu können.
Man müsste
das mal nachrechnen.
Man müsste das mal nachrechnen.
Wie viel Upload man braucht, um 400
down ordentlich verwenden zu können.
Müsste man mal nachrechnen.
Also hängt er von, hängt er eigentlich von
zwei Sachen ab.
Oder, wir waren zwar
ganz simpel, ich musste jetzt ja nicht
alles im Detail
technisch erklären, aber es ist ja so, wenn ihr was
wenn ihr was bekommt,
beziehungsweise wenn ihr was schickt,
schickt euch die andere Seite oder ihr der
anderen Seite
in der Regel eine Bestätigung, dass es angekommen ist.
Man kann das auch mit einem
Paket machen, für mehrere Pakete, die man
bekommen hat, aber irgendwann muss man
eine Bestätigung schicken, weil sonst macht
die andere Seite nicht weiter.
Und deswegen braucht
man ein Mindestmaß an Upload,
um überhaupt einen
Download ordentlich ausführen
zu können. Also sprich,
rein Download, ohne Upload geht
nicht. Funktiert nicht, weil du keine
Bestätigung verschicken kannst. Du kannst der Gegenstelle
nicht sagen, habe bekommen.
Müsste man mal ausrechnen.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, diese 10 MBit
ab hast du auch nur, dass du überhaupt
ordentlich downloaden kannst.
Sonst hätten die dir wahrscheinlich auch nur einen
Upload geben oder so, wenn es gehen würde.
Musik ist gerade ein bisschen nervig.
De de de de de de de
So, Vault.
Den ganzen Krempel weg.
Ja, Cryptoker, ich wollte
es jetzt nicht komplizierter machen,
als es sein muss.
Und so ziemlich alles im Internet ist TCP.
So was man so normal macht.
Jetzt mal von
Games oder vielleicht eventuellen Streams
oder so mal außen vor.
Aber selbst da ist vieles TCP.
Hast du schon
was bei BDO gecached?
Ja, habe ich schon.
Paar Sachen.
Ich habe mir, also es ist nicht
übermäßig viel, aber ich habe mir ein paar
Sachen geholt.
Ich musste gerade mal überlegen, was wollte ich jetzt machen.
Goldbarren getauscht, bla,
repariert.
Ich habe alles gemacht, kommen wir wieder zurück.
Ich habe mir Pads gekauft.
Ich habe mir
Inventarplätze,
Storageplätze und
Gewichtserweiterungen gekauft.
Und ich habe mir ein paar
Artisan Memories zum Enchanten gekauft.
Also ich habe jetzt keine tausenden
Euro ausgegeben oder so.
Aber auch nicht komplett Free2Play
oder halt
Buy2Play, sondern ein bisschen was habe ich schon reingesteckt.
Mein CSGO-Hype,
das ist ja schon Jahre her.
Ich habe jetzt CSGO vor 2 Jahren oder so mal intensiv
gespielt. Das lag daran,
weil wir es vorhin von Overwatch hatten, dass es nur
Spaß macht in Gruppe. Ist in CS finde ich auch so.
Richtig Spaß macht es eigentlich bloß,
wenn du mit in
der Gruppe spielst.
Und irgendwie haben wir dann nicht mal zusammen
gespielt. Und mir gingen die
Hacker auf den Sack.
CS ist halt ein Game, da dauert eine Runde auch mal ein bisschen,
bis es vorbei ist.
Aber wenn du dann irgendwelche Hackstars am Start
hast, ist es super nervig.
Und ich rede jetzt nicht von irgendwie
sowas wie, oh der ist besser als mich, der muss hacken.
Sondern ganz extrem
offensichtliche Dinger.
Wo hast du die Rüstung her?
Wenn ich dir das erzähle,
I'm Dazzy
Dizzy? Sprich mal das aus.
Wenn ich dir das erzähle,
dann lass mich aus. Was sagst du?
RNG-Carried-Kack-Noob.
Ich kann dir mal zu jedem Item
erzählen, wo ich das her hab.
Dann greifst du dir noch mehr an den Kopf.
Was ich für ein Glück hab bei meiner
Playtime. Warte mal, ich mach
die Viecher erstmal platt hier.
Also, Offwizard,
das ist echt lustig.
Gaius Helm gesniped aus dem AH.
Den hab ich nicht an, der liegt in
Velia irgendwo im
im Vault rum.
Da ist er, Gaius Helm.
Gaius Helm haben wir gesniped aus dem
Auktionshaus.
G-Spirit-Armor
hab ich aus einer Daily
Reward-Kiste gekriegt.
Übelst Glück. Übelst Glück gehabt.
Es hat kaum einer was rausgekriegt.
Es haben alle Leute,
die Box war verbuggt, es haben alle
Leute nur Red Nose rausgekriegt.
Und weil die Box verbuggt war,
gab es noch eine zweite Box.
Und aus dieser Box haben wieder 95%
nur Red Nose-Armor rausgekriegt.
Und ich hab G-Spirit-Armor
rausgezogen. Easy.
So, das haben wir gecraftet.
Ähm...
Beaks haben wir gesniped aus dem Auktionshaus.
On-Stream, glaube ich.
Kutum haben wir gesniped aus dem Auktionshaus.
Zaka hab ich gesniped aus dem
Auktionshaus. Und jetzt kommt der Hit.
Mask & Shoes hab ich
aus der zweiten...
ähm... in der zweiten
Woche der Weekly Quest
selbst gezogen.
So, und im Januar hol ich mir dann noch meine Dunder
ab mit Daily Reward-Siegeln und dann
bin ich komplett equipped.
GG Eats.
Ich hab ja überhaupt keine Playtime
so richtig. Das ist halt
RNG-Luck ohne Ende.
Und ich wusste das gar nicht zu schätzen so.
Als ich die ersten paar Items gekriegt hab, hab ich mir gesagt
Ja, Eats. Du weißt gar nicht, was die
alle haben. So schwer ist das doch gar nicht.
Hahaha. Aber mittlerweile
ist mir klar, was ich für ein Glück gehabt hab.
Hat das hier eine Level-Beschränkung?
Nein. Gibt's nicht.
Ja, du Freak. Ich weiß, ich weiß.
Ich hab das ja schon lange, ne?
Ich hab jetzt ja wieder irgendwie drei, vier Monate nicht
gespielt oder so.
Das einzige, was neu hinzugekommen ist, jetzt seit ich
wieder angefangen hab, äh...
quasi...
Das letzte diese Woche so, ist
aus den Daily Rewards, ich hab halt immer
eingeloggen, Daily Rewards geholt,
haben wir halt noch hier
Crescent Guardian Ring enchanted.
Das ist das einzige, was dazu gekommen ist.
Und ich hab halt hier Schmuck gefarmt.
Der ist halt wirklich gut.
Dieser...
Drop-Schmuck.
Aber das ging auch
schnell.
Das kann man auch empfehlen zu farmen.
Das ist echt guter Schmuck im Set.
Easy zu bekommen.
Fünfer Set. Mein dreier Set gibt
Leben. Fünfer Set gibt
Genauigkeit plus 20 und die Stats von den
Dingern sind auch ganz gut.
Also die
Dinger sollte man sich schon farmen.
Und es ist easy, selbst zu farmen. Dauert nicht
lang. Also dauert auch in BDO
Zeit nicht lang.
Grindest du jeden Spot ein paar Stunden,
dann hast du den Kram.
Brauchst du drei, vier Stunden oder so für...
Oder wenn's schlecht läuft,
vielleicht mal zwei Tage.
Geht das Leveln immer so schnell?
Ähm...
Die haben das angepasst vor ein paar Patches.
Also, wo ich zuletzt gespielt hab,
ging das Leveln bis 60
noch viel langsamer.
Und ich habe 50% oder 55%
zu meiner 60 noch auf dem alten Patchstand
gemacht, wo es langsamer ging.
Und das ging wirklich viel langsamer.
Bis 56 Leveln
ist überhaupt kein Ding.
Und bis 58 Leveln ist eigentlich kein Ding.
Der Fabian meinte mal, wenn man
nur von dem Game hat, levelst du auf 58
in einem Tag mittlerweile.
Ein Tag beim Fabian kann halt auch mal 20 Stunden haben.
Aber es geht schnell mittlerweile.
Aber die Schmuckteile farmen
ist...
empfehlenswert.
Es geht einfach und hat gute Stats.
Und kann man lange behalten,
bis man besseren Schmuck hat.
Weil die meisten Leute, da wird's wahrscheinlich
so sein wie ich, die haben als erstes
hier halt eher Rüstungsteile,
Offhand, Mainhand,
Awakening-Waffe und sowas, als
Teile und Schmuck, vor allem Enchanted-Schmuck
kommt dann eigentlich als letztes.
Deswegen ist es besonders gut, wenn man sich die Dinger farmt.
Na jetzt doch mal dem Frisur
seinen Aufruf gefolgt.
Weil das BDO-Spielen...
Der Fabian ist ja auch der einzige Grund,
warum ich das Spiel spiele, also
warum ich überhaupt angefangen habe damit.
Wir haben ja früher schon sau viele MMOs
zusammengespielt.
Und wir haben halt mal wieder einfach eins gebraucht,
wo man halt zusammenspielen kann.
Nachdem ihr ja kein COD mehr spielt
und kein Battlefield oder so.
Und äh...
will er ja auch nicht, weil er BDO spielen muss.
Bleibt ja nur übrig,
dass ich BDO spiele.
Und ohne den Fabian werden meine Sachen
auch noch gar nicht so gut enchanted.
Er hat halt übelst Game-Knowledge,
was das anbelangt.
WTF, wie ruckelt das Game?
Aber ist halt BDO.
Und ich hab halt reingelaggt mit den Items.
Aber Glück gehört in BDO
einfach dabei.
Wo haben die sich denn jetzt geheilt?
Was soll denn das hier?
Easy!
Heute läuft's aber.
Zwei Golden Dagger.
Ein Seraph Necklace schon.
Das geht ab.
Easy Money, Easy Life.
Ich muss jetzt gleich mal was futtern.
Nicht, dass es wieder so läuft wie vor zwei Tagen.
Wo ich das seit 18 Uhr erzählt habe.
Ich muss jetzt was essen und dann irgendwann
um 21 Uhr mal was geholt hab.
Ja, wenn man da so spielt wie der Fabian
hat man neben BDO wirklich keine Zeit
für andere Spiele.
Man muss wirklich casual mäßig spielen wie ich.
Wie gesagt, ich spiele ja nicht viel.
Ich habe auch nicht viel Playtime.
Ich hatte halt übelst RNG-Luck.
Ja, das stimmt.
Aber die machen ja auch viel für das man
nicht total den Anschluss verliert.
Also BDO kann man als Hardcore-Game
spielen und auch als
nebenbei MMO.
Ist eigentlich so eins der größten Stärken von dem Game.
Und vor allem ist es halt auch sehr vielfältig
wie man es spielen kann.
Will ich mal.
Ja, manchmal muss man einfach auch mal
Glück haben.
Gleich 91.
Also ich würde sagen, wenn wir jetzt weiter
grinden, bis zur
nächsten Nacht, dann könnte
das heute noch was werden mit
60.
Wenn man von Battlefield oder CS kommt, hat man hier
halt echt wenig Durchblick.
Man hat generell wenig Durchblick, wenn man BDO
anfängt.
BDO ist relativ komplex,
was man alles machen kann und hat viele
Sachen, die man machen kann.
Und die Erklärungen ingame
bringen einen nicht so wirklich weiter.
Also man wird zwangsläufig,
wenn man einsteigt, bisschen Zeit mit
Guide lesen, Guide gucken und so verbringen.
Wie gesagt,
ich blick bei vielen Aspekten von BDO ja auch
nicht durch.
Im Prinzip, was ich kann, ist mit meinem Wizard im Kreis laufen
und drei Spells machen und Mobs killen.
Aber,
das reicht erstmal.
Ich habe auch noch einiges von der Weltkarte nicht
aufgedeckt.
Hier, da, ja.
Mein Worker-System ist noch nicht richtig
ausgebaut.
Contribution Points, Energie noch nicht richtig
hochgelevelt.
Spielt ihr demnächst mal zusammen? Gestern Abend haben wir
zusammen gespielt.
Am Wochenende gehe ich mal von aus, ja.
Das ist ja
eines der Gründe, warum ich überhaupt BDO spiele,
dass wir wieder zusammen MMOs spielen können.
Wenn du nicht gerade Ultra-IL-Stells machen musst
und keine Zeit hast, spielen wir am Wochenende zusammen.
Eigentlich keine Spieler hier.
Mensch, ich habe gerade das Wassergrill
beschworen. Ich will nicht das Wassergrill.
Ich will
den Feuertyp.
Hier sind definitiv noch andere Spieler.
Gehe ich wieder zurück.
So, ich werde jetzt gleich mal
auf Klo
danach was zu essen holen.
Ich denke, ich bin so in
fünf Minuten wieder da.
Erstmal die Mobs hier killen.
Ich würde sagen, ich logge um.
Ich logge um auf den Bersi, nicht,
dass ich hier AFK jetzt irgendwie noch gekillt werde
von irgendwelchen Mobs.
So, ich logge mal auf den Bersi um.
Und wo habe ich hier meinen schönen Text?
AFK.
Ich bin in zwei, drei Minuten
wieder am Start.
Was sagst du zur Lemoria-Rüstung?
Ist das das aus dem 9-11-Gebiet?
Kein Schirm davon.
So, wähle hier
Aussicht.
Habt ihr irgendeinen schönen Musikvorschlag
für die Zeit, wo ich AFK bin, den ich anmachen kann?
Lass mal gucken, was haben wir denn
schon?
Weiß was wir machen.
Machen wir den hier.
AFK.
So, wieder am Start.
Ich hoffe, euch ist der Master Chief
erschienen.
So.
Ich bleibe
jetzt hier mal in Velia stehen.
Hätte ich mal mein Kochkostüm
oder so dabei, dann könnte ich ein bisschen Bier
craften.
Ich bleibe mal kurz in Velia stehen, haue mir hier mal
ein bisschen rein.
Heute keinen Sushi.
Also, wenn es noch irgendwelche Fragen im Chat gibt,
ich habe jetzt Zeit, quasi
die ganze Zeit Chat zu lesen,
bis ich fertig essen bin, also ich denke mal so
fünf Minuten oder so,
brauche ich jetzt. Ne, nicht Social Eating,
ich mute mich, wenn ich futter, weil
ich mag selbst keine
Essensgeräusche, aber ich will mich
auch nicht ins Ohr schmatzen.
Also, wie gesagt, ich bin da, ich esse
noch was.
Was Interessantes im Chat steht, sage ich auch was.
Yo, bin ich, Mr. Unlocker.
Bin ich.
Weil gerade jemand
was wegen der Musik über Halo im Chat geschrieben hat.
Ich glaube, das Problem von Halo
aktuell ist einfach
noch nicht mal so sehr, dass
der Entwickler gewechselt hat, sondern dass die Xbox
One eine scheiß
Plattform ist. Mal
gucken, wie das beim nächsten Halo wird, ob das
auch auf dem PC rauskommt. Sie haben ja gesagt, quasi
Xbox exklusiv
wird es ja so nicht mehr richtig geben.
Schauen wir mal.
Ich meine, Crossplay
kannst du nicht wirklich machen
zwischen Konsole und PC.
Aber
ein richtig
geiles Halo
auf dem PC,
richtig Support und so, ich glaube,
das könnte der Reihe wirklich neuen
Hype geben.
Weil
eins muss man sagen,
so Ranking eSport technisch,
war Halo der beste Titel, den es hier auf der Konsole
gegeben hat, fand ich.
Ich habe ja ganz was vergessen.
Ich habe ja vorhin gefragt,
ob wir uns, als ich
das erzählt habe, dass ich
eine Warnung vom Hersteller gekriegt habe, dass
mein Klo anfangen kann zu brennen.
Habe ich dann gesagt, hier,
wer sich interessiert dafür, was das für ein Klo ist,
weil ein paar gefragt haben,
guckt euch das YouTube-Video an.
Und da haben wir gesagt,
wir gucken es uns zusammen an. Das können wir doch jetzt machen,
während ich esse. Ich reacte,
mal zu meinem eigenen
YouTube-Klo-Video.
Das machen wir jetzt.
Moment.
Ich reacte.
Fenster,
Window Capture,
Firefox. So.
Jetzt kommt es.
Da ist es.
Okay.
Nix Klo-Review. Moment.
Ich mache die Musik aus.
Lol.
So, Jungs und Mädels, hier ist dann natürlich
jetzt tatsächlich soweit, dass ich ohne Scheiß
ein Video von meinem Klo mache.
Ich meine, ihr wisst ja, das ist kein normales Klo.
Das ist ein Special-Klo mit Special-Funktionen.
Wir fangen mal vielleicht
bei der einfachsten Sache an.
Ich meine, Deckel an Absenk-Automatik,
das haben aber mittlerweile echt viele.
Das ist nichts Besonderes mehr. Das knallt halt nicht mehr so.
Easy. Hat jeder. Jeder. Das ist überhaupt nichts Erwähnenswertes.
Na, easy. Ist das.
Hallo, Re-Rowlands.
Was geht?
Wir gucken uns gerade...
Ich reacte zu alten Videos.
Wir gucken uns gerade das Video von meinem Klo an.
Ich muss euch echt ehrlich sagen,
mir geht das schon fast ein bisschen langsam.
Ja, das heißt, ich hätte da immer ein bisschen Nachstand.
Was er noch hat, ist
eine echt geile Beschichtung innen drin.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, aus was das Ding genau besteht.
Das Ding ist jetzt
zwei Monate so in Benutzung, aber außer die Wasserperlen,
die man da drauf sieht, es bleibt nichts hängen.
Gar nichts. Das ist halt echt geil.
Das Ding kann man kaum sauber machen.
Das ist aber echt geil.
Ich musste noch nie ein Klo so wenig putzen wie den.
Muss gar nichts machen. Das ist echt geil, das Ding.
Die haben da irgendwie eine echt geile Beschichtung in den Klos.
Also für Leute, die nicht gerne Klos sauber machen,
ist das auf jeden Fall
eine super Geschichte.
Aber was das eigentlich richtig special macht,
ist, das ist immer nur ein Ding, was man da hinten dran sieht.
Und ich werde euch das auch gleich...
Lauter? Müssen wir es lauter machen?
Moment.
Kann ich machen.
Was das eigentlich richtig special macht,
ist das silberne Ding, was man da hinten dran sieht.
Jetzt besser, ne?
Und ich werde euch das auch gleich demonstrieren, wie das alles funktioniert.
Da muss man ein bisschen tricksen.
In diesem silbernen Ding eingelassen ist einmal
ein Föhn,
eine Düse. Da kann man sich den Arsch mit abspülen lassen.
Die Düse kann auch ein bisschen weiter rausfahren.
Da können sich die Mädels auch noch an anderen Stellen abspülen lassen.
Und es hat
eine Absauge-Technik.
Das heißt, es klingt dann auch noch ganz anders.
Man zieht das Ganze und zieht es dann ab.
Das aber... Ey, ohne Scheiß, Leute.
Das ist übelst geil.
Ich hatte das ja damals neu.
Das ist ja schon zwei oder drei Jahre alt.
Dieser Ventilator
da dran, der quasi
den ganzen Krams nach außen bläst.
Ja? Das ist die beste Erfindung.
Du sitzt da drauf
und es ist
nichts einfach.
Wie man das Ding bedient?
Entweder bedient man das Ding
über die Knöpfe.
Man sieht schon, das ist ein bisschen doof.
Da muss man hier drum rumgreifen
und alles. Jetzt Achtung.
Das ist ein bisschen special.
Man macht hier auf. Bäm.
Ohne Scheiß, Leute.
Das ist ein Klo mit Fernbedienung.
Sachen gibt es, oder?
Wir gehen jetzt mal da ein bisschen...
Hat schon mal ein altes iPhone.
Übrigens, hier unten, ne?
Ich habe das überhaupt nicht gecheckt.
Man kann das hier unten ausklappen noch
und da unten drunter sind noch mal so viele Knöpfe
als hier drauf.
Da kann man Temperatur einstellen,
Winkel einstellen,
alles Mögliche.
An den Knöpfen da unten, die sieht man gar nicht.
Die zeige ich gar nicht.
Also, was man hier drauf sieht, ist
einmal war hier oben natürlich so eine Anzeige.
Also, passt alles.
Sieht man alles Mögliche.
Ach guck mal, das Licht ist ein bisschen scheiße.
Man sieht wenigstens spiegelt sich mein iPhone.
Ich glaube, so sieht man das ganz gut.
Wasserstrahl weniger,
Wasserstrahl stärker, Wasserstrahl an,
Fönabzug an,
Damenspülung an,
Absaug,
Intensität hier unten drunter.
Da kann man irgendwie den Wasserstrahl noch einschalten.
Man kann es auch irgendwie heizen lassen.
Heizen kann man mit den Knöpfen hier unten drunter.
Man kann das hier unten runterklappen.
Da ist dann noch ein Knopf drauf, wie es heizen soll.
Ausgeschaltet, eingeschaltet, wenn man drauf sitzt
oder immer an.
Funktioniert.
Und es funktioniert ja auch gar nicht,
wenn man nicht drauf sitzt.
Ich habe es gesehen, ich habe da drauf geklickt,
es passiert nichts.
Man muss das Ganze jetzt ein bisschen faken.
Bei dem Klo wird mitgeliefert so ein Testding.
Ist schon geil, ne?
Das kann man dann hier draufsetzen.
Sieht dann so aus.
Dann haben wir den Deckel runter,
dass das Ganze auch fest ist, dass das Ganze hält.
Zeit habe ich immer noch.
So, und nun müssen wir mal schauen, wie wir das jetzt hier
halbwegs gescheit machen,
weil man muss das Ganze hier neben hin halten.
Da ist nämlich irgendwie eine Lichtschranke oder sonst was drin.
Ohne das funktioniert es nicht.
Aber jetzt finde ich...
Guck mal, guck mal, was man hier sieht.
Damals hatte ich noch einen
eine Decke vorm Fenster hängen,
weil der Rollladen noch kaputt war.
Und jetzt hier, da ist es. Bäm!
Und dann sollte eigentlich jetzt
gleich der Föhn angehen.
Man sieht es hier unten rechts, der Föhn ist an.
Föhn?
Kein Föhn. Föhn mal drücken.
Föhn geht nicht.
Ach, ich bin weggegangen.
Ich bin aus der Lichtschranke rausgegangen.
Das ist natürlich blöd, da müssen wir es nochmal kurz spülen.
Und diesmal bleiben wir über
der Lichtschranke drüber.
So, machen aus. Und jetzt sollte der Föhn eigentlich klar angehen.
Ja.
Mach Sprüh-Action.
Ja, jetzt wird geföhnt.
Da sieht man den auch.
Da föhnt es vor sich hin.
Dann machen wir den Föhn jetzt nochmal kurz aus.
Man sieht hier, man hat ja auch so einen Absaug.
Das ist so asiatisch.
Naja, die Asiaten wissen halt was Gutes.
Dann stinkt es nicht im Bad.
Sehr praktische Geschichte.
Also es ist auf jeden Fall eine Sache,
das muss jeder selbst wissen,
um so viel Geld für die Geschichte auszugeben.
Das ist ein...
Wie heißt das Ding nochmal genau?
Das ist ein Geberit Aqua Clean 8000 Plus,
glaube ich.
Das ist so wirklich das Premium-Modell,
was die haben. Den gibt es von denen nicht.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, was es gekostet hat.
Immer noch.
Also schon ziemlich teuer.
Muss jeder wirklich selbst wissen,
ob das was für ihn ist.
Ich glaube, das stimmt auch gar nicht,
was ich erzählt habe.
Das ist eine angenehme Geschichte.
Das ist wirklich eine Sache,
die ist richtig cool.
Und kann man sich überlegen.
Aber es ist jetzt nicht eines der Top-Sachen,
die ich mir anschaffen müsste,
wenn andere Sachen noch irgendwie fehlen würden.
So.
Jetzt habt ihr auch mal den Klo gesehen.
Der ist auch gar nicht so ultragroß.
Also das geht schon.
Er hat eigentlich ganz normale Größe.
Hier oben ist dann noch die Spüle dazu.
Sieht auch immer ganz normal aus.
Ich glaube, die Gäste finden das gerade geil.
Ja.
So.
Und wie wir drauf gekommen sind,
für alle, die sich jetzt denken,
what the fuck,
was will er denn hier von uns.
Mir hat heute der Hersteller,
gestern,
hat mich der Hersteller angerufen,
dass das Klo brennen kann.
Und ich habe mir gedacht,
das ist doch eine gute Idee.
Ich habe mir gedacht,
das Klo kann sich entzünden.
Weil der Düsenreiniger da drinnen ist,
zu leicht entflammbar ist.
Na geil, oder?
So, jetzt habe ich damals das angeguckt
und ich habe gesagt,
ich esse nebenbei,
aber ich habe jetzt noch kaum etwas gegessen.
Also, ich futter mal weiter.
Gartenstellt als nächstes.
Ne, ne, wir machen jetzt hier
einen kleinen Maxi-Reactor zu seinen Videos.
Schaust du The Grand Tour?
Ne.
Ich habe noch keine 60 gepackt.
Ich habe jetzt, glaube ich,
91% und muss gerade etwas futtern.
Was es gibt,
ja, nachdem es gestern
richtig geiles Sushi gab,
habe ich mir kurz überlegt,
ob ich mir heute noch einmal
eine Runde Sushi bestellen soll.
Also, anstatt Krabben-Rolls,
heute dann Krebs-Fleisch-Rolls.
Äh, Schwachsinn.
Anstatt Garnelen-Rolls,
Krebs-Fleisch-Rolls,
habe ich mir jetzt einfach Salami-Brötchen gemacht.
Also, nichts tolles.
Hast du jetzt doch wieder Bock auf BDO?
Jo. Habe ich wieder.
Mr. Unlocker, ich glaube,
es gibt eine
PvP-Rangliste oder sowas.
Und ja, wo du glaubst,
ich habe in dem Game auch schon Kohle ausgegeben.
Jetzt zwar keine Tausender oder so,
aber auch schon
den ein oder anderen Euro für Inventarplätze,
Storage, Pads,
ein bisschen Artisans-Memories.
Bist du wirklich eine Kack?
Ich bin eine Katze, nein, ich bin ein Keks.
Das sollten aber mittlerweile alle mitbekommen haben.
Bringen die Pads auch Boni?
Ja.
Also,
erstmal das Wichtigste
an Pads ist, dass sie
für dich Loot aufheben.
Können wir gerade mal Pad füttern.
Das ist das Wichtigste.
Äh, Common Sense, ja genau,
das ist das Game, wo der Fabian im Video was erzählt hat.
Ähm,
dass sie für dich Loot aufheben ist das Wichtigste.
Umso höheres Tier die haben und Level,
umso schneller machen sie das.
Ähm,
man kann mittlerweile 5 Pads draußen
haben und
die Pads haben aber auch noch Zusatzfähigkeiten.
Also der Igel hat zum Beispiel,
dass du mehr Fisch-XP
kriegst, also für die krassen Fischer,
Fisch-Craft-Leute unter uns.
Und, ähm,
dass du ein bisschen mehr
Lifeskill-Exp kriegst und sowas.
Und halt das hier, das ist wo manche sagen,
das wäre quasi Pay-to-Win.
Dass du mehr Zeug sammelst,
wenn du den Igel draußen hast.
So, die Katze,
also quasi Katz-FPS plus In-Game,
heißt ja auch genauso,
hat Koch-XP,
Life-XP
und das ist das beste Gathering-Level.
Richtig Glück gehabt.
Der China-Farmer DesertFox,
der hat auch Gathering-Level,
also auch wieder schön RNG-Luck gehabt.
RNG-Stream-Hund
hat, ähm,
naja,
geht so.
Der Pinguin hat auch jetzt
nichts so tolles, aber
wenn man AFK fischt,
ist der ganz gut.
Da fischt man schneller, wenn man AFK ist.
Aber es sammeln
alle Loot ein.
Als Anfänger sollte man sich zuerst den Igel holen.
Ne, nicht unbedingt.
Den Igel, den gibt es nur Pay-to-Win.
Also den gibt es nur, den gibt es nur im Shop.
Über, in so einem Paket.
Das, was in dem Paket
drin ist, an sich ist auch so ganz gut.
Ähm, du kannst
den Igel aber halt nicht upgraden.
Also wenn du zwei Pets von einer
Art zusammen verkuppelst,
quasi, weiß gar nicht,
ging hier irgendwo über das Menü,
dann kriegst du da ein neues,
ein neues Tier raus,
was eine Chance hat,
quasi ein höheres Tier zu
sein, also ein höheres, ähm,
höheres Level, standardmäßig
zu haben und eine höhere Stufe
quasi zu haben
und andere Fähigkeiten.
Du kannst danach auswählen, was du für Fähigkeiten
du quasi von Mutter, Vater behalten willst
und wie es aussehen soll und sowas.
Aber Pets sind
äh, ziemlich Pay-to-Win in dem Game.
Also du kannst sie dir
zwar über Marketplace kaufen, wenn da mal einer
was reinsetzt, aber ansonsten halt eher über den Shop.
Ja, und Tier ist definitiv
nicht egal, weil es gerade irgendjemand
geschrieben hat im Chat, definitiv nicht.
Ich war in, in Pilla mit dem, mit dem
Friseur, jeder vier Pets draußen.
Er damals mit seinen vier Tier-
drei Pets und ich mit meinen vier Tier-
eins Pets. Seine Pets haben quasi
fast, haben viel mehr gelootet als, als meins.
Viel, viel mehr.
Und jetzt dürfte es ziemlich ausgeglichen sein.
So, ich muss jetzt aber endlich mal fertig essen,
dass ich weiter Cryten kann.
Ups.
Na, wo du klaut, so schlimm
ist das nicht. Also, du kannst
in BDO verdammt viel Geld ausgeben,
aber wenn du dir so die,
so diese, wie nennt man das so, Quality of Life
Sachen kaufst, quasi
Pets, Inventarplätze, Storageplätze
und so, da gibst du
Value Packs, da gibst du halt mal irgendwie
so 30, 40 Euro aus.
Dann bist du, oder sag mal so,
sag mal mal, du gibst Vollpreis aus,
sag mal so 60 Euro,
dann hast du eigentlich alles, was du brauchst
erst mal.
Und mehr cashen kannst du immer.
Ja, wo du klaut,
du musst dir nix kaufen,
also du kannst dir keine Instant Level,
Instant Gear oder sowas kaufen,
aber,
und das meiste kriegst du auch
ingame so, aber so Sachen
wie Storage, Erweiterung und Inventarplätze
und sowas, ist schon sinnvoll.
Oder Pets,
Pets kriegst du theoretisch
aus dem Marketplace auch, aber doch relativ selten.
Manchmal
sind in den Rewards Pets dabei,
aber wenn man das ernsthaft
spielt, wird man
relativ schnell merken, was einen nervt
und
sich dann dort noch ein bisschen
was kaufen.
Aber wie gesagt, man muss,
also, dass es extrem teuer ist, stimmt nicht.
Der Fabian hat ja letztens irgendwie im Video
erzählt, ich gebe jeden Monat
100 Euro für BDO aus,
erstens glaube ich nicht, dass ich jeden Monat 100 Euro für BDO ausgib,
und man muss im Monat
definitiv keine 100 Euro
für BDO ausgeben, das ist vollkommener Blödsinn.
Brauchen wir nicht.
Das Zeug verschwindet ja nicht.
Und, wie ist 240 Hertz Monitor so?
Ja, gut Patrick,
das kann ich mir, ja doch,
ich kann es mir vorstellen, dass er das macht.
Ja, schon.
Und zum Einstieg,
wenn du dir das Game einfach nur angucken willst,
wo du klaut, brauchst du gar nichts.
Wenn du eine Weile gespielt hast,
wird er dann schon
feststellen, dass es dir auf den Keks geht,
zu looten, oder
dass dein Inventar zu klein ist.
Worauf ich ingame warte, ich versuche eigentlich
mein Abendessen zu futtern die ganze Zeit.
Und dann weiter meinen Wizard zu leveln.
Aber ich kann schon mal wieder umloggen, ich bin eigentlich fertig.
Was ist 144 Hertz
Lightboost?
Also, mit Lightboost
ist gemeint, dass dein
Monitor
die Hintergrundbeleuchtung ausschalten kann.
Also an- und ausschalten kann.
Ganz kurz natürlich nur, ja.
Hoffentlich sind die ganzen Typen hier
weg von eben.
Jo, da warte ich drauf, Patrick.
4K,
145 Hertz, G-Sync, HDR,
HDR auch noch, bitteschön, ja.
Hat er.
Das erste Mal seit Jahren, dass ich mir einen neuen Monitor hole.
Moment,
da sind wieder Leute.
Könnt ihr mich nicht einfach mal
hier in Ruhe grinden lassen.
Statt meine Mobs zu killen.
Weil ihr seht,
wenn man von oben mit einem Satellit drauf
gucken würde, würde da
Max stehen auf den Mobs.
Die stehen quasi in Max
Formation. Deswegen sind das
meine Mobs. Weil welchen
Bufffood sind wir denn jetzt eigentlich wieder?
Exp, ne?
Sind bei Exp.
Weißt du, warum du nie Wizard spielst?
Naja, ich
benutze von dem Wizard ja auch gerade 3 Spells nur.
So
unmobil ist Wizard gar nicht.
Der Teleport ist ganz gut.
Und du hast diesen Speed und
damit läufst du auch relativ schnell.
Ich wüsste es halt nur machen.
Das Ding könnte ich auch mal machen.
Das bringt glaube ich auch Movement Speed.
Max, du spielst BDO. Ja.
Spiel BDO, weil der Friseur BDO spielt.
Und wir endlich mal wieder ein MMO brauchen,
dass wir zusammen spielen können.
Der Fabian ist ja quasi mittlerweile
Deutschlands größter BDO Streber.
Kann das sein, dass ich falsch
laufe gerade? Ne, ne, ne.
Passt alles.
Also übrigens nochmal zu dem Monitor,
wann der nächstes Jahr rauskommt, ne?
Oder hoffentlich. Der sollte eigentlich schon dieses Jahr rauskommen.
Also 144 Hertz.
Und also
144 Hertz, HDR, G-Sync, 4K.
Das Ding ist
übertrieben teuer.
Und ich gedenke auch
nicht in 4K
144 Hertz zu spielen.
Höchstens halt das Game gibt das her.
Dann werde ich das auch machen. Moment.
Ist schon wieder alles weg. Leute, könnt ihr nicht mal abhauen?
Sollen meine Mobs in Ruhe lassen?
Ähm, sondern
mein Plan ist Desktop in 4K
und Spiele
in Auflösung so niedrig,
dass ich 144 Hertz packe.
Ähm, Mr. Unlocker, den gleichen
Bildschirm habe ich auch. Kannst du
Lightboost machen mit?
Funktioniert. Gibt es ein extra Programm für?
Kann man machen.
Das einzige Problem bei Lightboost ist,
umso aggressiver du das stellst, umso dunkler
wird dein Bildschirm.
Was mich ziemlich nervt.
Also ich habe noch keinen deutschen Stream
gesehen, der mehr Zuschauer hat als der von Fabian.
Also der, der
auch auf Deutsch streamt.
An dem bei Lightboost wird eigentlich nur die Hintergrundbeleuchtung
abgeschaltet.
Also, je nach Monitor
können das auch welche, wo es nicht dransteht.
Also dein
BenQ kann das. Wie gesagt, ist der gleiche,
den habe ich auch, Mr. Unlocker.
Aber letztendlich ist es
auch egal, wer da jetzt der Größte
ist. Dann sagen wir halt, dass
alle glücklich sind. Einer der Größten in
Deutschland.
Sind hier oben schon wieder ein Respawn?
Ne.
Es sah nämlich so aus, weil da kann ich meine normale
Rotation beibehalten.
Ne, fuck.
Und ich respawne.
So, Exprank.
Ja, jetzt fahren wir hier einmal
hier oben durch.
Hallo Wizard, kletter mal rauf.
Wird das
Internet langsamer, wenn
ich den Laptop an den Monitor anschließe,
oder kommt mir das nur so vor? Also,
was du für einen Monitor an deinen Laptop
anschließt, hat für deine Internetanbindung
überhaupt keine Auswirkung.
Was soll
das auch miteinander zu tun haben?
Also, ich glaube,
die 60 heute wird echt knapp.
Da müsste ich ja bis 4 Uhr
nachts oder so grinden.
Gucken wir mal, wie viel mehr XP wir nach der nächsten
Nacht haben. Dauert ja noch ein bisschen.
Also, bis zur nächsten Nacht, hoffe ich,
haben wir 93.
Meint ihr, das geht?
Patrick, du machst Barsi-Grind.
Ich dachte, Barsi lohnt sich
XP-mäßig nicht.
Oder machst du für den Gürtel?
Ja, ich glaube, das meint er sogar.
Ernst?
Hat er gestern gesagt, er spielt wieder.
Gibt's auch Bosse oder Dungeons?
Gibt's, ja.
Allerdings nicht so in klassischer
Form Dungeon-Finder und
mit Gruppe in Raid.
Es gibt Bosse.
Das sind halt World-Bosse.
Die
spawnen einmal pro Server.
Gleichzeitig auf jedem Server.
Das heißt, da ist es immer sehr voll.
Also, wirklich, war's nie voll.
Da ruckelt's auch bei mir.
Selbst auf dem neuen Rechner jetzt.
Dungeons gibt's auch.
Allerdings auch nicht instanziert.
Moment, wo ist eigentlich mein Pad?
Max, kannst du mal dein Gear zeigen?
Äh, Ligerion, mach mal Ausrufezeichen
Gear. Das haben wir erst vorgestern aktualisiert.
Das ist aktuell.
Nee, ist nicht aktuell. Aber ich sag dir, was
dazu fehlt, wenn du dir's anguckst.
Ähm, ich hab meine, meine
Awakening-Waffe hab ich noch gelb
gemacht mit so einem Stein.
Die hat jetzt 3 AP mehr als auf dem Build.
Das war's aber. Ansonsten
ist das genau so, wie's da steht.
Wie snipet man denn was vom Marketplace?
Ähm,
du lässt dich, du setzt ne Notification,
wann das Item reinkommt.
Das kannst du beim Marketplace-Händler
machen.
Wobei, ich weiß nicht, kann man Notifications
auch hier setzen?
Ja. Nice.
Moment.
Jetzt kann ich nicht unregistern.
Na super, jetzt hab ich Blackstone-Powder-Register.
Ganz toll.
Das war das aller sinnvollste jetzt ever.
Jetzt muss ich zum Marketplace das wieder rückgängig
machen. Okay, also anscheinend kann man nur
sich anmelden, aber nicht wieder wegmachen.
Kann man, kann man nicht
unregister hier drüber machen?
Nee, das geht nicht.
Na geil. Okay.
Dann nicht. Ähm,
du setzt dich da rein, dass du
ne Nachricht kriegst, wenn das Item
ins, äh, in Marketplace
kommt. Da ploppt dann unten rechts
so ein Fenster auf.
Da steht dann drinnen, dass das Item jetzt
reingesetzt wurde und das bedeutet
innerhalb der nächsten 10 Minuten,
also innerhalb der nächsten
10 bis 15 Minuten erscheint
dann das Item drinnen und dann kannst
du da drauf bieten. Also bieten.
Du kannst quasi draufklicken wie
ich will es haben und wenn du Glück hast,
kriegst du's. Und wenn derjenige das
kriegt und sich nicht rechtzeitig abholt,
dann ist es free for all.
Hat schon wer Mini-Elefanten?
Nee, hab ich nicht.
Ich muss lesen, es ist ne Quest in der
Wüste, aber kein Schimmer.
Was, wenn das Fenster auftaucht? Klick auf abbrechen.
Ah, cool. Schön zu wissen.
Bam.
Boah, das Crawlfragment, das ist echt Glück.
Da hast du
gefühlt 80 Leute,
die, oder 80,
800 Leute,
die wie verrückt ihre linke Maustaste spammen.
Linke Maustaste und Enter-Spam
machen. Das ist echt
das ist richtig Glück.
Sind Quests auch Criten?
Also ich finde schon, dass
man Quests machen auch als eine Form
des Criten sehen könnte, ja.
Wenn ich mir das in anderen MMOs
angucke, wo du quasi von
vom ersten Level bis zu Max-Level
durch die Gebiete rennst und
und, äh, Blümchen sammelst
und Dinger machst, finde ich
ist das schon sehr ähnlich zu Criten.
Wobei, nee, ich glaube ich hab
deine Frage voll falsch verstanden, ne?
Du meinst, ob Quests in BDO
äh, quasi Grinding-Quests
sind.
Gibt's unterschiedliche.
Es gibt Story-Quests,
es gibt, äh, Töte 500
Nagas-Quests,
im Prinzip so wie in eigentlich jedem MMO.
Es gibt alle möglichen
Quests. Das, aber
die Quests sind so wie in jedem MMO.
Nur, dass es sich hier
nur, dass es sich hier insofern mehr
lohnt, Quests zu machen,
also auch wenn du jetzt, äh, sagen wir mal
61 bist, lohnt es sich eventuell
halt in den Low-Level-Gebieten die Quests
zu machen, weil du kriegst
fürs Beenden der Quests, äh,
Contribution Points.
Und mit Contribution Points kannst du
dann deine
äh, Nodes, kannst du in
Nodes investieren, in
in Trading Cards
oder in, in Pferdewagen
oder in was auch immer.
Das heißt, Contribution Points braucht man. Ich hab viel
zu wenig. Muss ich mich
erstmal nach Valencia durchquesten? Nee, nicht unbedingt.
Ich finde einmal
die Hauptquest machen schadet nix.
Das ist halt langweilig
wie Sau, ne? Die Mainquest.
Ich find, ich find, ich find die BDO-Story
fand ich auch echt
langweilig. Ich hab's ja nicht, also gut, ich muss
sagen, ich hab's auch nicht richtig gelesen, aber
das, was ich so mitgekriegt hab aus diesen
Cutscenes und
dem, was die NPCs so erzählt
haben, war die Story echt mega
langweilig. Aber schadet nix
die Mainquest einmal zu machen.
Dann sieht dann Black Spirit cooler aus, dann
und du kriegst auch ein paar
Items, die, naja,
braucht man eigentlich nicht.
Manche Sachen sind ganz gut.
Ich glaub, du kriegst
ein paar Black Spirit Crystals unterwegs, die
ganz nett sind. Wenn ihr die Hauptstory
dann quasi durch habt, sieht euer Black Spirit
so aus. Oder
nicht, also kurz, kurz
vor durch sieht er dann so aus.
Was hat's eigentlich mit dem House-Fame
auf sich? Ähm,
so ganz durchgestiegen bin
ich auch nicht, aber umso mehr
High-Level-Charaktere du auf deinem Account
hast und ich weiß nicht, ob
Equipment auch mit reinspielt,
bekommst du täglich Geld.
Dafür, weil du halt so krass Fame bist.
So, und
ich hab im Prinzip ja nur
nen Bersi auf 56 und nen Wizard
hier auf fast 60
und ich krieg jetzt, äh,
350.000
Gold am Tag.
Das ist zwar nicht viel, aber
wenn man das so macht wie ich,
ich spiel ja nicht wirklich, wirklich viel,
wie gesagt, ich war jetzt 3 Monate
inaktiv, aber man trotzdem
täglich einloggt, kriegt man
täglich die, die, die Reward, Einlogg-
Belohnung plus halt den House-
Found. Wobei ich, ich frag
mich grade, ob man den House-Found nicht auch kriegt, wenn man
nicht einloggt, keine Ahnung. Und
dann, na, sag mal so, nach 3 Monaten
macht's täglich 350k auch aus.
Zwar nicht viel, aber ein bisschen.
Klein viel macht ja auch was.
Wenn man durch ist, sieht er wieder aus wie
am Anfang. Ja, ich hab
die Main-Quest noch nicht ganz fertig, mir fehlen noch
3 Steps. Also ich war jetzt
irgendwie bei, ich hab
die erste Belohnung, die ersten paar Ringe als
Belohnung gekriegt und war dann beim König,
hab abgegeben und hab festgestellt, danach geht's
ja noch weiter.
Also das ist wohl aber ne Main-Quest, die ist nach der,
äh, ist wohl erst reingepatcht worden.
Also die richtige Main-Quest ist, hab ich fertig.
Cancel. Das ist
nice, dass man einfach abbrechen kann.
THX. Wer auch
immer mir das erzählt hat eben.
Solange ich dann keine Benachrichtigung mehr kriege.
33 Millionen nach 3 Monaten.
Ja, das ist nicht schlecht.
Ich mein, du machst ja nix dafür.
Ich find die Standard-Steuerung ist okay.
Ich glaub, eine der Sachen, die ich umgestellt
hab, ist, dass Autorun auf mittlerer
Maustaste ist.
Also wenn ich Autorun machen will, drück ich
die mittlere Maustaste und dann rennt er halt los.
Ansonsten überleg ich grad, was ich umgestellt
hab. Ja, genau, ich hab, ähm,
ich hab Awakening-Waffe und
normale Waffe wechseln hab ich auf
zweiter Maustaste unten.
Und mein Speed-Buff hab ich auf der ersten Maustaste.
Und auf C hab ich Freeze.
Was ich zwar habe und geiler Spell ist,
ich aber nie verwende.
Ach, wir müssen uns ja noch die Daily-Reward-Box angucken.
Oh, das müssen wir machen.
Da ist heut geiles Item drin.
Das müssen wir uns jetzt schnell angucken.
Was benutzt du für Grafik-Settings?
Texturen hoch, äh, Grafik-Qualität
low. Ich hab's gestern
hier im Stream mal gespielt auf, auf
Ultra-High-Settings und, äh,
hier, äh, Super-High-End-Mode,
Improved, alles. Das sieht
schon deutlich besser aus. Lief auch ganz gut.
Aber mir ist es wichtiger, dass
das quasi 144
FPS hat. So!
Daily-Reward-Box. Heute gab's für mich
nämlich hier die, eine, eine
Boss-, eine Boss-Ring, wobei,
ne, eine, halt,
Rare-Ring-Box. Und da gucken wir
jetzt mal rein, was da drin ist.
Es gibt zur Auswahl
Ogre-Ring, Tank-Herz und
Layton-Power-Stone. Ich hoffe ja, es ist ein Ogre-Ring
drin. So.
Gucken. Gucken wir mal, was drin ist.
So. Random-Leertast,
Tasten-Hit.
Ja, freuen tut er sich immer.
Ah, fast, fast
Ogre-Ring. Allerdings,
das Teil ist auch
genug
wert. Wo ist es denn? Da.
Ist auch 80 Milliliter wert.
Ist auch okay.
Leider kein Ogre-Ring drinne, weil,
wenn da ein Ogre-Ring
drinne gewesen wäre, hätten wir probieren können,
den zu enchanten. Ich hab nämlich
noch einen zweiten. Hätten wir gucken
können, ob das funktioniert. Aber, Pech gehabt.
Charakter-Namen. Das ist,
die werde ich nie spielen, die anderen
Charaktere. Meine anderen
Helden sind rein für
Failed-Stacks. Das ist
der Negativ-Karma-
Wizard zum Items-Downgraden.
Und das hier sind einfach Chars,
die ich angelegt hab,
zum Failed-Stacks sammeln.
Ich will nicht das Wasser-Grill. Ich will den Feuer-Typ.
Werde ich eh nicht spielen. Ich spiel
Wizard und vielleicht Bersi.
Irgendwann. Fertig.
Außerdem kann ich mir immer noch einen neuen Char machen.
Kann man den Wizard in verschiedene
Richtungen skillen?
Ja und nee.
Die normalen Skills
gibt's verschiedene Sachen. Also
hast du hier
Erde-Dinger, Feuerball,
Luftgedöns, Blitzkram.
Aber bei den Awakening-Skills,
die man hauptsächlich verwendet, bis
zum Rework,
gibt es beim Wizard eigentlich hauptsächlich
Feuer, Eis
und
Wasser.
Also Feuer- und
Wasser-Spells. Und nachdem
es ja auch nicht viele Spells gibt
und alle ganz gut sind,
gibt's da nicht viele Skill-Möglichkeiten.
Die normalen Spells
werden angeblich überarbeitet.
Bin ich mal gespannt, was da rauskommt.
Weil aktuell
ist es halt so, seitdem es die Awakening-Waffen
gibt, benutzt halt kaum
einer noch. Außer die krassen
PvP-Wizards,
die halt so das letzte rausholen
wollen. Also beim normalen
Level benutzt halt keiner mehr die normalen Spells
so richtig.
Langsam werd ich müde, ey.
Was ist Awakening? Awakening ist die
kriegst du mit 56.
Mit 56
kriegst du für diesen Waffenslot
hier in der Mitte, kriegst du
eine neue Waffe. Und nur mit dieser neuen
Waffe kannst du...
die neuen Skills verwenden.
Ab Level 56.
Also das hat man schnell.
geht mega schnell zu Level. Mittlerweile machst du
die Awakening-Quest, die geht auch relativ
fix. Und dann kannst
du die neuen Skills specken.
Die neuen Skills
brauchen aber relativ viele Skill-Punkte.
Das heißt, man muss halt
ordentlich grinden
danach.
Aber musst du ja eh, weil mit
56 alleine kommst du ja nicht weit.
Hast du Anti-Elasig
an oder aus?
Wahrscheinlich, keine Ahnung.
Aber ich guck mal.
Ich gucke mal.
An. Na was sagst du
Wizardnerv? Ich hab mir noch gar nichts angeguckt.
Hast du mal einen Link?
Was wird denn genervt?
Wenn Wizard zu krass
genervt wird, mach ich mir OP Dark Knight.
Kommt auch das
gleiche raus. Kann ich auch mit
zwei Spells alles own.
Oder Striker.
Was genau wird denn
genervt beim Wizard?
Oder was soll genervt werden?
Oder gibt's noch gar nichts
Konkretes und sie haben bloß gesagt,
wir schauen uns den Wizard mal an.
Weil das sind so Aussagen, die treffen ja Entwickler
laufend. Oder irgendwelche
Marketing-Leute.
Soll ich Witcher auf GOG oder Steam kaufen?
Woher soll ich das wissen,
wo du das besser kaufen sollst?
Kannst du ja auf GOG
kaufen, dann gibt's kein DRM
oder sonst was.
Das kann ich dir nicht sagen, wo du das besser kaufen sollst.
Also ich find's aber nicht schlecht, wenn man GOG
unterstützt.
Zumal das Spiel eh DRM-frei auf GOG
ist. Warum nicht?
Was? Instant
Stun auf Jail?
Also Jail ist ja das da.
Wie? Instant Stun?
Die Gegner werden instant gestunt, wenn sie da drinstehen?
Das wär ja noch
mehr OP als vorher.
Wart mal.
Range AE, Range AE ist das hier.
Muss ich mir mal durchlesen.
Hast du mal einen Link dazu?
Wo das steht?
Achso, ja, mal abwarten.
Mal abwarten.
Ich mein, die erzählen ja immer, generell
erzählen alle, egal welches MMO,
wird ja immer viel erzählt, wenn der Tag lang ist.
Ach, meinst du das hier?
Diesen Knockdown da?
Ja gut, die Range von dem Ding ist ja
auch mega groß.
Das ist doch der Knockdown, oder?
Genau. Ja.
Das aufstampfen.
Ja, die Range von dem Ding ist auch
übertrieben groß. Guck dir das mal an.
Ich kann hier stehen, im Endeffekt.
Bam. Und stun da noch die fast
beide Packs mit.
Beziehungsweise, werf ich's halt um.
60 ist heute noch drin.
Ahhh.
Ich weiß nicht. Es könnte eng werden.
Es könnte echt eng werden.
Aber ich mein, wir sind locker 93
bis, ach 94.
Wir sind 94 bis Nacht.
Das könnte heute echt noch was werden.
Das könnte echt noch was werden.
Muss einfach nur
ausdauernd genug Kreiselgrind machen.
Ne, genau.
Ich hab ja mit 60 erst die Erweiterung. Ist richtig.
Ja.
Ist auch einer der Gründe, warum ich jetzt 60 mache, weil sie
alle Spells auf,
also alle Spellerweiterung auf 60 runtergesetzt
haben. Früher hat ja Wizard teilweise
noch mit, hat glaub ich den letzten Spell
mit 62 gekriegt.
Was vollkommen utopisch war.
Übrigens, ähm,
heute war letzter Tag der Overwatch Season.
Und ich glaub am
31. oder 1.
geht die neue Season los.
Da werd ich Placements machen
auf jeden Fall hier on Stream.
Und
dann mal gucken, wie sehr mich das Game wieder tiltet.
Ob ich weitermach oder nicht.
Aber ich hab nicht mehr gespielt.
Außer das letzte Mal hier vor 2 Tagen oder so
im Stream.
Ging mir viel zu sehr auf den Sack wieder das Game.
Crying ist lieber BDO im Kreis.
Easy Crying.
Eigentlich
müsste ich YouTube Videos machen, anstatt
Kreisel Crying.
Letzte kam am 24.
Ist wieder 5 Tage her.
Und ich hab ja sogar noch eins. Ich müsste
eigentlich nur hochladen.
Eax, du kannst Overwatch Quickplay spielen.
Wenn du dich aufregen willst.
Zum Monitortesten.
Zockst du noch CSGO?
Ach stimmt!
Wo ist eigentlich die Hintergrundmusik?
Ist ne gute Frage, wo ist die Hintergrundmusik?
Da ist sie.
Die haben wir vorhin ausgemacht, als wir uns das
Klo-Video angeschaut haben.
So, jetzt müssen wir mal wieder Loot abgeben.
Max,
hast du die Zarka selbst geabt?
Also, wenn du damit meinst, ob ich
sie enchanted
habe oder aus dem Marketplace
gekauft habe. Aus dem Marketplace hab ich sie nicht.
Also nicht auf Tree gekauft.
Allerdings hab ich sie auch
nicht selbst enchanted.
Sondern der Fabian, also der Friseur hat sie für mich
entchanted.
Und das ohne Accountsharing.
Ich hab damals sogar extra
den BDO Community Manager gefragt,
ob es okay ist, wenn wir das streamen,
wenn ich mich einlogge
mit meinem Account auf seinem Rechner
und er streamt.
Also sind wir echt auf Nummer
sicher gegangen damals.
Dass da jetzt keiner ankommt von wegen
Accountsharing.
Wir haben den Account nicht geshared.
Also die Zugangsdaten.
Das ist das, worum es denen hauptsächlich geht.
Dass keiner irgendwie Passwörter weitergibt
und dann sich aufregt, warum sein Account weg ist.
Und ich muss sagen,
ich war überrascht,
wie einfach es war, einen
Kakao Community Manager
zu kontaktieren.
Hast du bei anderen Games
oftmals mehr Probleme.
Gibt's irgendeine Klasse,
die keine Skills braucht, also einfach draufhauen?
Striker.
So.
Kampel Sellen.
Zack.
Guck mal, wie viel Kohle wir schon wieder gefarmt
haben die letzten paar Tage.
Und im Vergleich zu den anderen
Powersuchtern haben wir ja gar nicht so viel gespielt.
Dazu kommt,
dass ich hier noch dieses ganze Zeug verkaufen kann,
was ich hier noch im Bauch liegen hab.
Das sind ja auch nochmal 10, 15 Mille.
Und wenn man die Seraph
Necklace noch verkauft, die 4 sind das nochmal 100 Mille.
Oder so.
In dem Dreh.
Oder wie viel ist so ein Seraph Necklace wert?
Guck mal, gleich mal.
Muss ich rappen? Sekunde.
Näh.
Ja, nicht ganz. 25.
Das ist nicht ganz eine Million.
Oh, das sei denn, man kriegt Max Preis für.
Dann ist es genau
100 Millionen
für die 4.
Die Fame Sachen stacken sich. Achso, cool.
Das heißt, man muss nicht
50.000 Mails einsammeln.
Doch.
Ich hab, als ich jetzt 3 Monate nicht gespielt hab,
ich hab massig Mails
mit Fame Found gehabt.
Haus Fame Found.
Muss ich
gefühlte 5 Minuten dastehen
und mir angucken,
wie er
Post einsammelt.
Entsaltungskur auf Twitter
am besten.
Natürlich
nur, wenn du irgendwie ein Anliegen hast,
wofür ein Community Manager zuständig ist.
Also jetzt nicht so nach dem Motto,
was wie Hilfe, mein Charakter ist gestuckt
oder so.
Wenn du Fragen dazu hast
zu deinem Stream oder irgendwie
wenn du irgendein BDO
Event organisieren willst, keine Ahnung.
Dafür sind ja Community Manager da.
Nicht irgendwelche technischen Sachen zu fixen.
Man sollte die auch nicht
mit irgendwas nerven.
Davon gibt es eh meisten
schon zu wenig und die haben schon genug zu tun.
Community Manager
ist je nach Spiel
ist das Dauerstress.
Vor allem flamen dich die ganze Zeit
irgendwelche Leute, als könntest du was dafür.
Ich mein klar du arbeitest bei der Firma,
aber du hast ja als Community Manager nicht wirklich
einen Einfluss drauf auf
Balancing Entscheidungen zum Beispiel in einem Game.
Ich glaub ich hab noch nie
so jemand gestressten gesehen,
wie den Call of Duty
Community Manager auf der Gamescom.
Der war echt
Der war
echt mitgenommen.
Aber der hat es auch ernst genommen.
Also er hat es wirklich ernst genommen.
Der hat sich echt Mühe gegeben.
Das hat man gemerkt.
Da kann man über COD sagen, was man will.
Das sagt nix über die einzelnen Leute aus.
Ob man das Spiel scheiße findet oder nicht.
Der hat sich echt Mühe gegeben.
Und dann
kommen die Leute und kopieren irgendwelche Pässe.
LOL
Wobei da drüber ist
Das ist ein anderes Thema.
Ups
Zack
Zack und Feuerpad
Auf was für einer Grafik
spielst du jetzt eigentlich?
Wann zeige ich dir?
Texture Quality High
Gibt es eigentlich sehr High?
Nein gibt es nicht.
Graphics Quality Low mit diesen Settings.
Einfach, dass ich schön 144 FPS habe.
Ich brauche das.
Und Field of View habe ich jetzt auf
60. Ich finde es gerade gar nicht.
Wo ist es denn?
Ich glaube 60.
Das hieß ja noch nicht Vision Range.
Also 60. Ja.
Papapapa
Wie bringt er es auf 144?
Naja, ich spiele auf Low.
Das hast du doch gerade gesehen.
Ich spiele auf Low. Ich habe eine 1080Ti
und 8700K.
Also sprich das Beste, was du aktuell für Gaming haben kannst.
Und wenn man das Beste hat
Muss ich mal überlegen.
Wenn man das Beste hat, was es aktuell für Gaming gibt
und man BDO auf Low spielt
dann kann man auch tatsächlich auf 144Hz spielen.
Ansonsten ist BDO
technisch jetzt ja nun nicht so ein Meisterwerk.
Es ist auf 60 gekappt.
Nein, es ist nicht auf 60 gekappt.
Es ist nur, es hat V-Sync an.
Und V-Sync cappt auf
die Wiederholrate deines Monitors.
Und wenn du einen 144Hz Monitor
dran hast, dann bei 144.
Und wahrscheinlich hast du nur
einen 60Hz Monitor dran, deswegen cappt es
bei dir auf 60.
Was du machen kannst ist, du kannst es auf Fullscreen
stellen und in deinem
Grafikkartentreiber sagen
führ das Game V-Sync aus.
Dann cappt er auch nicht
mehr bei 60.
Die Frage, ob man jetzt dann
natürlich viel mehr braucht, wenn man nur
einen 60Hz Monitor hat, das haben wir da hingestellt.
Aber es funktioniert.
Du hast 144, das kann ich mir einschnitzen.
Dann kann ich mir das nicht erklären.
Also ich weiß, das Game hat V-Sync an
und V-Sync ist immer gleich Refreshrate
des Monitors cappt.
Ah, das sieht bei Aero sich auch so.
Max, kennst du Swift,
die Programmiersprache?
Hab gerade was Lust auf Reddit
dazu gelesen, willst du hören?
Das ist von
initiiert, von Apple.
So irgendwann mal
als Objective-C Nachfolger
gedacht.
Wobei der Kern halt bei Apple viele Sachen
in Objective-C sind und auch weiter
sein werden.
Was hast du denn Lust fürs Gehört? Erzähl.
Bam.
Togens alter.
Wo ist eigentlich der Fabian, frage ich mich gerade so.
Du musst doch schon daheim
sein.
Tremor, hi.
Ich bin mega vergesslich mittlerweile.
Wir haben uns letztens erst eine Liste
angeguckt von Games, die 2018 rauskommen.
Und ich habe schon wieder alle vergessen.
Also was ich hoffe,
also das einzige, was mir so aus dem Bauch raus
einfällt, von dem ich hoffe, dass es
2018 losgehen wird,
ist, ob Camelot Unchained
in die Beta-Phase gehen wird.
Da bin ich echt gespannt drauf.
Vor allem, weil ich da viel
Kohle gebackt habe auf Kickstarter für.
Rein aus Nostalgiegründen für
Dark. An sich im Nachhinein betrachtet
eigentlich viel zu viel und total dämlich.
So viel für absolut
ungewiss, aber gut.
Mehr gönnt sich ja sonst nichts.
Ansonsten weiß nicht.
Müsste ich mal
in mich gehen, ob mir da vielleicht wieder Games einfallen,
die 2018 rauskommen.
Playstation-Spiele gibt es ein paar coole.
Also Last of Us 2
bin ich mal gespannt drauf.
Wo ich allgemein gespannt
drauf bin, ist wie sich die Switch,
ich wollte gerade sagen die Wii, wie sich die Switch
schlägt.
Nächstes Jahr.
Nintendo hat ja große Verkaufsziele
erzählt, ja.
Haben ja ganz groß erzählt, wie viel
Millionen sie verkaufen wollen.
Da bin ich mal gespannt, ob das klappt und
vor allem, was es für Games geben wird.
Für die Switch.
Ob sich das wirklich gelohnt hat, die Konsole
zu kaufen.
Hast du eigentlich Immobilien?
Also außer das Haus, in dem wir wohnen hier?
Ne.
Ja, das kann ich mir.
Monster Hunter World.
Da bin ich auch mal gespannt drauf.
Monster Hunter ist so eine Serie, habe ich nie großartig gespielt.
Aber Monster Hunter World soll sich ja
explizit auch an Leute richten, die bisher mit der
Gameserie
nichts zu tun hatten.
Haha, WWPD,
das ist geil.
Hat irgendjemand
geschrieben,
er hat einen Job gefunden
oder er sucht einen Job
als Swift-Programmierer
und einer hat eine Stelle für Swift-Programmierer
mit die 8 Jahre
Berufserfahrung in der Programmiersprache
Swift erfordern.
Man muss halt dazu wissen, Swift gibt es halt seit 3 Jahren.
Aber Investment-Tipps,
ja.
Wie gesagt, ich investiere ja
nicht in Häuser,
sondern in Luxus-Klos.
Das ist die Zukunft.
Solltest du auch machen.
Damit kann man auch noch was anfangen,
wenn alles den Bach runter geht.
Ah, Sibaro.
Das ist schön.
Das ist nice.
Also wenn die Switch bald geknackt ist, wäre das cool.
Und da muss ich jetzt noch
dazu sagen, warum ich denke,
dass das cool wäre.
Gar nicht mal, dass man da drauf
irgendwelche gehackten Spiele oder so
spielen kann, dazu gehört ja noch ein bisschen mehr.
Ob das dann funktioniert, müssen wir mal gucken.
Geschweige denn, dass ich
irgendwelche gehackten Spiele spielen will.
Die Handvoll Spiele,
die ich auf der Switch spielen würde,
die würde ich mir auch kaufen.
Worauf ich mich freue ist, wenn
die Switch geknackt ist, dass da drauf
endlich mal ein bisschen mehr Software läuft.
Ich meine, die Switch kann nichts,
außer, ich meine, es ist eine Konsole,
die Spiele abspielen kann, die kann nichts.
Außer Spiele abspielen.
Was halt ein bisschen doof ist.
Habe mal so einen Browser drauf,
wo man was nachgucken kann.
Wäre schon ganz gut.
Dann die üblichen Sachen von Spotify
und Netflix und Amazon
Music und so. Wobei das halt auch
nicht auf einmal, nur weil es Home-Pro gibt,
auf der Switch laufen wird.
Muss man mal gucken, die sind da immer sehr
erfinderisch. Bringt das in so
ein Klo denn wirklich? Hast du doch eben gesehen.
Beste. Was hat mich
über WTF, was mich davon
überzeugt hat, ich habe es ausprobiert
und fand das geil. Wir haben jetzt
das komplette Haus, hier wurde ja quasi
nicht neu gebaut, renoviert
komplett.
Also hier im ersten Stock,
wo ich jetzt
wohne, war ja mal ursprünglich
quasi Küche und
Wohnzimmer von Oma, Opa.
Das heißt, da wurde eh alles neu
gemacht. Habe ich mir gedacht, ey, wenn wir
jetzt schon oder wenn ich schon quasi
ein neues Bad bezahlen muss,
dann was mit richtig geiler
Dusche und richtig geilem Klo.
Das mit richtig geiler Dusche hat leider
nicht funktioniert.
Wollte ich erst haben, ich wollte so
eine Schneckendusche haben.
Also wenn ihr nicht wisst, was das ist,
das ist quasi
ebenerdig und
sind halt
gemauert, so halt wie so ein Schneckenhaus.
Also sprich, du kannst
Moment, wo bin ich jetzt hier hingelaufen?
What?
Achso.
Und du kannst quasi in die Dusche
reinlaufen, ohne irgendwie
aufmachen zu müssen und sowas.
Du gehst einfach in die Dusche rein, das duscht
dich und läufst wieder raus. So quasi alles
ebenerdig und es saut das Bad nicht ein.
Das hätte ich gerne gehabt, das war leider zu schwer
für den ersten Stock, aber
das nächste, was ich haben wollte, ist halt
so ein geiles Klo.
Was mich davon überzeugt hat, ist
halt, es ist saumäßig
angenehm, es stinkt
nix, du musst es kaum sauber machen.
Ähm,
es ist halt einfach,
es sitzt sich bequem drauf.
Du durftest jetzt, das klingt
jetzt irgendwie, als würde ich jetzt ein bisschen Werbung machen.
Es ist halt geil. Also zwei
Sachen, die sich wirklich gelohnt haben, da Kohle
zu investieren, zum unabhängig davon
guten Rechner zu kaufen und so, ja.
Also zwei, nennen wir es mal Möbelstücke, die
sich richtig gelohnt haben, da drin was zu investieren
ist, einmal der
Bürostuhl, den ich hier jetzt vor dem Rechner stehen habe und
äh, halt hier das Klo.
Näh.
Du kannst ja den Strahl einstellen.
Ach stimmt, wir haben ja noch gar kein
Stuhl-Kommando, können wir machen.
Könnten wir machen.
Brauchen wir aber erstmal Reflink.
Lull.
Ohne Reflink geht hier nix.
Sellout. Max Sellout.
Läuft auf dem Klo
Spotify und Amazon Music.
Ähm.
Auf dem Klo natürlich nicht, ja.
Aber.
Ich habe ein Tablet im Bad.
Darauf
läuft Spotify und Amazon Music.
Und YouTube und Twitch.
Und das ist mittlerweile so
schlimm, dass ich allen
Ernstes unter der Dusche stehe
und durch die
durchsichtige Wand
von der Duschkabine
mir Twitch angucke.
So gestört ist es
mittlerweile schon, ja.
Ich habe das Tablet gegenüber von der Duschkabine
habe ich dann hingelegt
auf halt
so eine Kommode.
Hochkant. Und dann kann ich quasi
aus, beim Duschen kann ich Twitch gucken.
Das ist, das ist richtig
Next Level, oder Leute?
Das ist wirklich seiner Zeit voraus.
Absolut Next, Next Gen.
Next Gen, Next Level.
Und das ist wirklich praktisch.
Ihr wisst ja, ich gucke quasi gar keinen Fernsehen.
Ich gucke im Prinzip halt
nur Webzeug. Wenn ich Filme gucken will, dann
Amazon oder Netflix oder was auch immer.
Ähm.
Und ich gucke halt hauptsächlich Livestream und YouTube.
Und wenn irgendein,
sagen wir jetzt, wenn Overwatch League läuft
oder irgendein CS Turnier oder irgendwas, was auch immer.
Ne?
Musst halt trotzdem dich noch ab und zu mal duschen.
Ich habe halt das Tablet.
Und wird beim Duschen Twitch geguckt.
Das einzige, was mir jetzt noch fehlt,
das ganze Wasserdicht, das ich im Chat
spammen kann unter der Dusche.
It's Next Level.
Ja. Wir schaffen,
wir schaffen sogar noch mehr.
Ey, das wird heute was, Leute. Guckt mal.
Es ist 19 Uhr 45. Wir haben gleich
94 Prozent.
Und es sind noch
vier Ingame Stunden bis Nacht.
Und Nacht gibt es nochmal mehr XP.
Und dann haben wir wahrscheinlich
auch noch Energie. Für
20 Prozent XP Buff.
Das kriegen wir heute hin. 60 wird heute was.
Also 60 ist in Reichweite. Definitiv.
Ich könnte Pay2Win machen.
Ich könnte eine Golden Bell für den Channel
kaufen. Pay2Win.
Wir gucken mal, wie viel Uhr es ist, wenn ich so
bei 98 Prozent bin.
Dann mache ich vielleicht Pay2Win Golden Bell
für den Channel.
Das stimmt, Alcorina. Da hast du schon recht.
Was, Max? In welcher Lohngruppe
befindest du dich momentan?
Ähm. Du meinst,
tarifvertragmäßig
oder was?
Egal, was du genau meinst, ich weiß es nicht.
Bevor das jetzt wieder für
Verwirrung sorgt,
ich weiß viele so simple Sachen nicht.
Ich weiß auch nicht, wie viel ich im Jahr
verdiene.
Es gibt Sachen, die...
Weiß nicht.
So Sachen, die jeder weiß,
die weiß ich irgendwie nicht.
Genau, wie es da sehbar ist.
Ich weiß es echt nicht.
Ich weiß nur, dass ich jetzt durch die letzten Jahre
YouTube habe ich ganz ordentlich auf was gespart.
Und das wirklich angenehme
von zwei Einnahmequellen,
also quasi, wie gesagt, ich gehe noch vier Tage die Woche arbeiten,
plus halt
die YouTube-Geschichte,
weil ich da letztes Jahr nicht so viel mitgemacht habe.
Ich habe ja kaum was hochgeladen
und war ja kaum aktiv.
Was einfach wirklich angenehm ist,
wenn man zwei Einnahmequellen hat.
Man fühlt sich da unabhängiger
und man kann immer sagen,
hey, wenn ich keinen Bock auf das eine habe, mache ich das andere
und wenn ich keinen Bock auf das andere habe, mache ich das eine.
Und was halt
daraus resultiert ist, du hast halt
zwei Einnahmequellen, hast ein bisschen mehr Kohle
und
im Prinzip kannst du dir einfach, wenn dir
es danach ist,
nach was auch immer es dir ist,
kannst du dir dann
holen. Ich meine, klar, es gibt Sachen,
die kann ich mir auch nicht holen. Ich kann mir jetzt kein 200k
Auto einfach so holen oder was auch immer.
Aber halt so die normalen Sachen.
Sei es
jetzt Wäsche, Trockner
oder
neuen Fernseher oder
was auch immer.
Das geht.
Und solange das geht,
und ich halt die Sachen
nicht einzeln umdrehen muss,
werde ich wahrscheinlich auch nicht wissen,
wie viel ich im Jahr verdiene.
Ab wann hast du
deinem Arbeitgeber gemeldet,
dass du YouTuber bist? Das weiß der nicht.
Der weiß nicht,
dass ich YouTuber bin.
Der weiß nur, dass ich eine eigene
Firma habe
und ich quasi
woanders arbeite,
ohne ihm Konkurrenz zu machen.
Dass ich YouTuber bin, weiß der nicht.
Also das wissen
viele auf der Arbeit mittlerweile.
Ich meine, ich muss dir irgendwas erzählen,
warum ich weniger arbeiten will.
Und warum soll ich mir da irgendwas ausdenken?
Ich habe heute gesagt, ich habe eine eigene Firma,
ich mache da, ich mache
kreative
Videogestaltung, Videobearbeitung.
Und das läuft halt
mittlerweile ganz gut. Irgendwie sowas habe ich
erzählt. Aber dass ich YouTube mache, wissen die nicht.
Ja, Sibaro habe ich
und ich bin der einzige Mitarbeiter.
Deswegen meinte ich doch letztens,
wo wir es irgendwie von Schulsystem und sowas hatten,
dass ich schade finde, dass man den Leuten in der
Schule nicht so grundlegende Sachen zeigt, wie
was muss man dann machen, um eine Firma zu
gründen. Also zu welchem Amt musst du,
wie sieht dieser Bogen aus, den man ausfüllen muss.
Einfach, dass man das schon mal gesehen hat.
Ich meine, es ist ja
viel einfacher, als man denkt.
Man muss es bloß wissen.
Und auch diesen Bogen ausfüllen ist easy,
weil man die Hälfte davon überhaupt nicht ausfüllen muss.
Es sei denn, du fährst
zur See oder bist
Förster. Da musst du mehr ausfüllen.
Warum auch immer
gerade diese zwei Sachen sind.
Mobs abkratzen, please.
Was ist denn ein Pro-Tipp
für Leute, die eventuell eine Firma gründen wollen?
Ähm, naja.
Nicht einfach gründen, sondern einen Anlass dazu haben.
Also einfach eine Firma
beziehungsweise ein Unternehmen anzumelden,
weil man es machen will, hat ja auch keinen Sinn.
Man braucht schon
eine Vorstellung, was man machen will.
Und viele Sachen
kann man ja heutzutage auch, wenn es
eh eher so eine Ein-Mann-Geschichte ist,
kannst du ja auch hobbymäßig anfangen.
Und wenn du dann merkst, es läuft ganz gut
und du damit halt auch Geld
verdienst, was du versteuern musst, nur was dann kannst
du sagen, hey,
jetzt legen wir los.
Ich glaube sogar
Segel-Vlogs können gut funktionieren.
Ich glaube, die meisten Sachen
können gut funktionieren, wenn die
Rahmenbedingungen stimmen.
Also, klar, es gibt so
irgendwelche Nischen-Sachen, so was weiß ich,
Ameisenzüchter oder keine Ahnung.
Wobei selbst, ich glaube,
das meiste steht und fällt damit,
dass man
Sachen, wo andere
Leute eben jetzt
was andere Leute eben nicht täglich machen,
dass man die interessant aufbereiten kann.
Ich glaube,
Segel-Vlogs könnte man übelst spannend
machen.
Aber ihr wisst ja, Video-Editing ist jetzt nur auch
nicht unbedingt so mein Steckenpferd.
Meine Editing-Skills halten sich ja nur
sehr in Grenzen.
Was arbeitest du denn? Also, ich habe
eine Ausbildung gemacht,
vor über 10 Jahren jetzt,
als
Fachinformatiker System-Integration
meiner Firma, bei der ich jetzt nicht
mehr bin. Und
danach habe ich eigentlich
als Linux-Admin
weiter, also das war quasi
ein Linux-Admin-Laden,
wo ich
gewesen bin am Anfang.
Deswegen kenne ich mich auch
mit Linux ganz gut aus
und mache da öfters auch mal
hier im Stream was mit.
Allerdings mittlerweile
kümmere ich mich
um unsere Software-Repos.
Also sprich, das darf
man sich so vorstellen,
wenn eine Änderung
rein soll, dann muss
die ja irgendjemand programmieren.
Der programmiert die dann und reicht die dann
ein, als
Feature-Request quasi,
nicht als Feature-Request, als
wie nennt man das eigentlich?
Als Pull-Request
jetzt mit TF.
Weil entweder mal heißt es Merge-Request, mal
Pull-Request. Als Pull-Request heißt
das auf GitHub.
Da steht dann drinnen
so nach dem Motto, was ist denn für ein Feature
implementiert, was da was
gemacht wurde, blablabla. Da gucke ich mir die Änderungen
an. Ich probiere das mal aus,
ob das alles so funktioniert.
Weil ansonsten merkt man das meistens erst viel später.
Wenn irgendwas nicht funktioniert,
dann schnappe ich mir den Typ und lasse mir
erklären, was er sich eigentlich gedacht hat.
Oder es kann ja auch sein, dass sich zwei
Änderungen widersprechen.
Dass der eine in der Datei das
eingetragen hat, der andere das, und dann
passt nichts zueinander.
Dann muss ich mir so beide schnappen und sagen,
Jungs, werdet euch mal bitte einig, was davon jetzt rein muss.
Dann mache ich
neue Alpha-Versionen, Beta-Versionen,
Release-Versionen,
Hotfixes
für die alten Versionen.
Also eigentlich Versionsverwaltung.
Oh.
Presub, Just K4,
Just Kai, würde ich mal sagen.
Just K4, naja,
Just Kai heißt es wahrscheinlich.
Für die Kohle.
Twitch Prime Sub.
Oder wie sagt das XQC
immer? Prime Sub!
Five months!
Prime Sub!
Oder so ähnlich.
Dumme Frage, was macht man
als Linux-Admin
eigentlich den ganzen Tag?
Klar, Server einrichten, aber das
macht man doch nicht den ganzen Tag.
Was gehört da sonst noch dazu?
Das ist ein sehr weit gefasster Begriff.
Du kannst ja im Prinzip fast alles machen.
Server einrichten macht man
eigentlich kaum.
Man betreut eher Server, die da sind.
Und das hängt halt
ganz entscheidend davon ab,
in welchem Laden man ist.
Man kann sich entweder um Datenbanken kümmern.
Waren auch viele.
Also quasi dann irgendwie so Richtung DBA.
Wenn du in irgendeinem
Hosting-Laden landest, kümmerst du dich
wahrscheinlich um irgendwelche Webserver.
Es ist ganz unterschiedlich, was man da macht.
Im Prinzip kümmerst du dich
um die Systeme, für die du zuständig bist.
Ein ganz simples Beispiel ist
zum Beispiel
du löscht Log-Dateien, weil die Platte
voll wird.
Das ist jetzt ein relativ simples Beispiel.
Aber Sachen in dieser Richtung
machst du eigentlich. Du installierst
nicht den ganzen Tag neue Server.
Und wenn man den ganzen Tag neue Server installieren müsste,
dann hoffe ich,
dass der Laden, der eben das machen muss,
das nicht von Hand macht.
Beziehungsweise die Linux-Admins dort
nicht den ganzen Tag Server von Hand installieren.
Da gibt es ja mittlerweile auch schöne
Automatisierungstools für.
Machst du LDAP? Nein, mach ich nicht.
Entsalzungskur, wenn du deinen
XP-Buff jetzt nicht ausnutzen kannst,
du kannst doch einfach umloggen auf einen anderen Held,
dann behältst du den XP-Buff.
Der läuft, der ist auf den Held
gebunden. Also sprich, der läuft nicht aus,
wenn du umloggst.
Automatisierungsgeil
sollten ja
alle sein.
Also zumindest sollte man das automatisieren,
was halt nervt und was halt sehr oft vorkommt.
Man muss dann immer abwägen, lohnt es sich
jetzt irgendwas quasi
zu automatisieren,
wenn man es vielleicht nur 10 Mal machen muss
und dann wieder im Jahr wieder 10 Mal.
Da kann man sich drüber streiten, ob es dann nicht einfacher
ist, es einfach 10 Mal von Hand zu machen,
dann nächstes Jahr wieder. Aber wenn du jeden Tag
irgendwas machst, mehrfach,
dann lohnt sich das ja
auch richtig.
Aber nachdem ich so oft gefragt werde, was ich
jetzt eigentlich genau mache, muss ich mir das ehrlich gesagt
selbst mal überlegen, wie ich das schön erklären kann.
Ich meine, Leute,
die in der IT arbeiten, werden das zumindest
kennen, wenn sie gefragt werden von
irgendwelchen Bekannten, oder sei es
nur von Oma, Opa,
dann ist so die Standardsache,
die immer kommt, ist, wie?
Du weißt nicht, wie meine Druckerpatrone,
wie man meine Druckerpatrone wechselt,
warum weißt du das nicht? Ich denke, du machst
was mit Computer.
Das kommt ja immer.
Du machst was mit Computer. Das nur, weil man
was mit Computer macht, nicht automatisch heißt,
dass man weiß, wie man die Druckerpatrone wechselt.
Bei gerade dem Modell, was die Oma
hat aus dem Kopf,
so weit reicht das
bei vielen Leuten gar nicht.
Du machst doch was mit Computer.
Oder was auch immer sehr beliebt ist,
teilweise irgendwie, kommt dann einer
an, Max, mein Windows startet nicht
mehr. Oder irgendwie sowas.
Oder was, die sagen ja nicht mehr, mein Windows startet nicht mehr.
Die sagen, Max, mein Computer startet nicht mehr.
Und da bin ich mittlerweile relativ
fein raus. Da frage ich die immer, ja, was hast du drauf?
Ja, halt, die wissen dann gar nicht,
was ich meine. Ja, halt, ne?
Was halt mit Wasser ausgeliefert wurde.
Sagt die, du hast Windows drauf, ne?
Keine Ahnung von.
Bisschen easy raus.
Dann kommt einer, wie ich denke, du machst doch den ganzen Tag
sowas. Sag ich, nein, mach ich
nicht.
Mach ich nicht. Wenn ich den ganzen
Tag sowas machen müsste, also,
Windows-Notebooks fixen, dann würde ich das garantiert
nicht mehr machen.
Sag mal, wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben?
Genau, weil,
was hast du denn für einen Computer? Einen weißen.
Ja, so Antworten kriegst du dann.
Was steht denn da oben?
Ja, und dann gibt es tatsächlich Leute, die sagen dann,
ja, ich hab da irgendwie,
keine Ahnung, Bild von meinem Enkel
über dem Monitor hängen. Ne, ne, so war das
nicht gemeint.
Aber glücklicherweise, im Support arbeiten
hätte ich echt keinen Bock drauf.
Zum End-User-Support.
Da hätte ich echt keinen Bock drauf.
Wie lange hast du ungefähr für dein Gear gebraucht?
Ich kann's dir nicht genau sagen, aber nicht lange.
Wie gesagt, ich hab jetzt auch wieder 3 Monate nicht
gespielt und hatte ja mehr oder weniger, bis auf den Ring
alles schon.
Paar Wochen. Muss man den Friseur
fragen, der weiß das. Oder müssen wir mal den Fabian
fragen, der weiß das genauer. Paar Wochen.
Halt übelst, übelst, übelst
random RNG-Glück.
Und, ich hab ja
vorher schon den Bersi gespielt und AFK
geangelt und sowas. Also ich hatte ein bisschen,
bisschen Crafting-Material und
Ingame-Gold. Allerdings jetzt
auch keine Milliarde oder so.
Irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 250 Mille.
Und Maskenschuhe
und Dim-Tree-Armor
hab ich ja schon gezogen aus
der Box. Und der Quest-Reward
mit dem Bersi noch.
Als ich den mal gespielt hab.
Also insgesamt, keine Ahnung, 2-3 Monate
oder so.
Mit Enchanten und
Crynten und allem.
Also nicht Spielzeit 2-3 Monate, sondern
RL-Zeit mit Normalspielen.
Also nicht lange, ist
übelst Glück. Deswegen sag ich doch,
ich bin der bestgegierte Noob in BDO.
Ne, nicht selber geabt.
Appen lassen.
Ich hab mich beim Fabian eingeloggt.
Mit meinem Account und er hat
für mich enchanted, weil er einfach deutlich mehr
Game-Knowledge hat als ich.
Leute, wir werden,
wir haben 95 vor der Nacht.
L60 ist greifbar.
Ligeria
noch viel mehr Luck.
Also, das Mega-Luck war ja
Maskenschuhe aus der Quest-Belohnung.
So, Dim-Tree-Armor
aus der
Daily oder aus der
Reward-Box zu
weiß ich wann, das war Ostern oder so,
war auch
Mega-Luck.
Aber was fast noch
übertriebener war, ist natürlich
den ganzen Scheiß hier aus dem AH gesniped.
Ne, Jais-Helm
aus dem AH gesniped. Hab ich jetzt nicht an,
leg den Velia rum. Jais-Helm aus dem AH gesniped.
Beak aus dem AH gesniped.
Kutum aus dem AH gesniped.
Zaka aus dem AH gesniped.
Ey, WTF. Das einzige
was ich bis jetzt noch nicht gesniped hab, ist meine
Dunder, aber die kann ich mir eh nächste Woche
oder nächste, nächsten 14 Tage holen.
Weil ich genug Siegel hab.
Easy life. Richtig
easy life.
60 ist greifbar heute.
Ich sag's euch, Leute.
ist drin.
Vor allem, wenn jetzt gleich noch Nacht ist und es nochmal extra
XP gibt.
Besser, eh.
Ligerion, du hast
glaub ich beim
Night Vendor
hast du glaub ich,
kannst du nicht einmal auf zurückhalten drücken
und hast dann irgendwie 20 Minuten Zeit
oder so, noch ein bisschen Kohle
locker zu machen?
So, wir müssen jetzt gleich nochmal Loot abgeben.
Äh, Beatprone
fragt, unterstützt du meine Theorie?
System D wird mit
was? Moment.
System D wird mitunter so gehasst,
weil es den Admins viel Arbeit wegnimmt.
Service Dependencies
werden automatisch, ne, glaub ich nicht.
System D
wird, glaub ich, gehasst, weil es an vielen Stellen
ein bisschen Magic ist.
Und einige Sachen ersetzt, die es ja
schon gibt.
Und quasi
nachbaut oder nochmal
implementiert oder so.
Ich bin prinzipiell nicht gegen System D.
Warum man
allerdings bei System D, also es gibt halt Sachen,
die ich nicht so ganz verstehe, ehrlich
gesagt. Warum braucht man ein Netzwerk
Management Modul und einen eigenen DHCP?
Und einen eigenen DNS?
Wozu?
Das gibt's doch schon tausendfach.
Was ist mit Gnome? Gnome ist
Kacke. Beziehungsweise
GTK ist Kacke. Gnome
ist nicht Kacke. Wer ist
diese Katze?
Äh, meine
Katze?
Katz FPS?
Auch wenn sie nicht
mehr lebt?
Das ist trotzdem eine Katze gewesen.
Welche Distribution
nutzt du beruflich? Ich nutze beruflich
die Kleidung der Distribution.
Meinst du, meinst du jetzt auf den Servern
oder meinst du auf meinem Arbeits-
Notebook?
Also auf, ähm,
auf meinem Arbeits-Notebook verwende ich das gleiche, wie ich
daheim auch verwende. Manjaro mit
äh, i3 WM.
Und
auf den Servern
ist hauptsächlich
Red Hat.
Und ich finde Manjaro mit i3 ist
die beste Arbeitsumgebung, die es gibt.
Wenn man auf
einen, nennen wir's mal
Tastatur fokussierten
Workflow steht,
also da wird nicht viel geklickt.
Wird quasi mehr oder weniger alles über Tastatur
bedient, außer der Browser.
Äh, nein.
Reparieren?
Nope. Gibt es da eine
Max-FPS-Gilde? Nein, gibt's nicht.
Seh ich auch keinen Sinn drin.
Ich bin in der gleichen Gilde wie der Friseur.
Was ich schon seit ich spiele.
Und mit dem Gildengeschehen haben wir beide
nicht viel zu tun.
Wir sind im Prinzip
einfach ganz normale Member und auch da.
Wo rennst
du eigentlich lang in WTF?
Außerdem stellst du hier irgendeinen Typ lang.
Ja, lassen wir den mal rumstelzen.
Wir gehen wieder in unseren normalen Spot.
Der normale Spot ist hier unten.
Da flitzt er, der kleine Wizard.
Da düst er rum.
Guck mal Leute, wir haben vielleicht sogar
96% bis zur Nacht.
Die Nacht dauert ja noch zwei Ingame-
Wow, BDO, ruckel nicht.
Da haben wir noch zwei Ingame-Stunden
bis Nacht.
Von welcher Nacht?
Guckt mal hier oben rechts.
Das ist ja Ingame-Urzeitanzeige.
Und ab 10 Uhr abends
gilt das quasi als Nacht.
Nachts machen die Monster mehr Schaden.
Geben allerdings auch mehr Exp.
Das heißt, nachts
fangen alle immer an
zu grinden, die nicht eh schon grinden.
Wenn sie grinden müssen.
Das wird halt was mit 60.
Ich hab's im Urin.
Na, auf Wizard, kletter hoch.
Weißt du, Port hat sich über
20 Wände drüber, aber da
kommt er nicht hoch. Hallo Kios.
Äh, ich sollte vielleicht
auf dem Bildschirm gucken, dann würde ich auch
Wo sind die Mobs hin?
Dann würde ich vielleicht auch nicht gegen den Felsen rennen.
Deswegen mag ich Wizard-Grind.
Ich kann quasi permanent
Chat gucken.
Und muss abends immer ein paar Spells
drücken.
Easy Clap.
GG Eats.
Was sagst du zu Path of Exile?
Beste Second-Slay-Game.
Gibt kein besseres.
Das einzige, was ich besser finde
zu seiner Prime
Zeit war Diablo 2.
Aber das ist ja auch schon lange
drüber hinweg.
Aber alles
in allem Path of Exile
ist das Beste.
In der Richtung.
Wenn mich nicht alles täuscht,
sind da glaube ich sogar Leute dabei,
die an Diablo 2 dabei gewesen sind.
Path of Exile
ist das, was die Leute sich von Diablo 3
gewünscht haben.
Und was gerade witzig ist,
Path of Exile war vor Diablo 3 raus.
Und hat heute wahrscheinlich
Ja, ich weiß es nicht,
aber ich geh mal von außen gar mehr Spieler.
Ich hoffe mal für Path of Exile
viel, viel mehr Spieler als Diablo 3.
Weil es einfach das deutlich bessere Game ist.
Für alle, die
auf sowas stehen, jetzt kommt man,
wenn man so auf Action-RPG,
steht, man kommt nicht an Path of Exile vorbei.
Wenn man das als Multiplayer
spielen will, ja.
Singleplayer mag es da vielleicht noch die ein oder
anderen Sachen geben, die auch mal ganz nett sind.
Aber
langzeitmäßig Path of Exile
das Beste.
Äh, was ist mit dem Bob los?
Spielst du ab und zu noch CSGO? Vielleicht auch
im Stream? Nein, ich spiele kein CSGO mehr.
Was ist denn das da?
Oh, das wollen wir nicht,
dass es uns angreift.
Das wollen wir nicht, dass es uns angreift.
Nein, wir wollen nicht, dass es uns angreift.
Jetzt geht's wieder.
Muss ich mir merken, da steht ein Boss rum.
Mitten auf dem Feld.
Dass ich den nicht im Eifer des Gefechts jetzt hitte,
weil ich Chat gucke und hier einfach geradeaus renne
und Spells drücke.
9-7.
Path of Exile für Anfänger ist auch gut.
Ich glaube, du wirst
kein aktuelles Hack and Slay finden,
was so vielfältig ist wie Path of Exile
und so gute Guides
und alles hat. Das ist das Beste.
Es ist auch das Einzige, was es gibt, ehrlich gesagt.
Diablo 3 ist der Witz.
Hat mit dem eigentlichen
Gedanke, wie es
naja, wie das Diablo 2
etabliert hat, damals nichts mehr zu tun.
Path of Exile
ist, finde ich, das Einzige,
was es überhaupt gibt.
Und gleichzeitig auch noch das Beste.
Was es geben kann.
Es gibt eigentlich nichts, woran du da kurz meckern kannst.
Path of Exile, finde ich, sieht man auch ganz gut,
da sich Qualität durchsetzt.
Path of Exile kostet nichts.
Kann man kostenlos spielen.
Die Microtransactions, die es gibt, sind rein kosmetisch.
Und das
Einzige, was man sich halt nach einer Weile
kauft, sind noch ein bisschen mehr
Truhenplatz.
Und in puncto Qualität
setzt es sich durch.
Das Side-Release wurde das Game kontinuierlich erweitert.
Immer weiter verbessert.
Immer neue Sachen hinzugefügt.
Und
Fehler behoben und alles.
Und Path of Exile war am Anfang
halt einfach nur da. Wurde ein bisschen gespielt.
Und mittlerweile ist es, hoffe ich mal,
auch finanziell ein Riesenerfolg.
Aber für Spieler und
wie viel das spielen, definitiv.
Aber ich gehe mal davon aus,
Path of Exile lohnt sich finanziell für die Firma
auch.
Weil da gab es ja erst letztens wieder neuen Content.
Und neuen Content produziert sich ja auch nicht
einfach umsonst.
Was sagst du zur Preispolitik von Apple?
Ich meine, Apple hat so
klar gesagt, dass sie das iPhone X extra teuer machen,
damit sich das nicht jeder leisten kann.
Die Preispolitik von Apple ist halt
teuer.
Naja, also die Preispolitik...
Was soll ich dazu sagen?
Die Preispolitik von Apple ist halt nicht unbedingt,
dass es rein vom Gerät her
gerechtfertigt ist, dass das Ding so viel kostet, aber
die wollen halt
in den Leuten das Gefühl auslösen,
sie haben irgendwas Exklusives.
Was sie ja nicht haben.
Wenn man sich überlegt, wie viele Leute ein iPhone haben.
Das ist ja Schwachsinn.
Da ist nichts Exklusives dran.
Exklusiv Geld für Apple, ja.
Aber dadurch, dass es so teuer ist,
fühlen sich halt viele Apple-Leute geil,
wenn sie es sich gekauft haben.
Warum auch immer.
Ich muss sagen, ich finde iOS nicht schlecht.
Es ist halt
teuer, das kann man nicht wegdiskutieren,
die Apple-Dinger.
Ich habe auch ein iPhone 6, übrigens.
Also, nicht so, dass ich es nicht ausprobieren würde
und nicht benutzen würde.
Und die Diskussion, die es da immer gibt,
Android, Apple, ich meine,
das ist eigentlich nichts, das man großartig diskutieren müsste.
Weil du kannst mit allem,
also mit beiden Systemen
das machen,
alles machen, was so der 0 nach 15 Anwender
machen will.
Wenn du mehr machen möchtest, ist es mit Android
deutlich einfacher.
Da in den Tiefen rumzubasteln
und zu frickeln.
Und du kannst auch an viel mehr
Sachen was ändern unter Android.
Was jetzt betriebssystemmäßig ist.
Unter iOS ist es halt
entweder, du bist ein Apple-Produkt,
dann darfst du mehr als andere,
oder darfst du es halt nicht.
Dafür ist iOS konsistenter.
Und ich glaube, das ist eigentlich auch nichts,
wo man großartig drüber diskutieren muss.
Wenn ich mir schon angucke,
ich habe mir ein Android-Tablet,
ich habe ja meiner Mutter ein Android-Tablet
geschenkt zu Weihnachten.
Und wenn ich mir angucke,
wie sehr Asus das Standard-Android
zugesaut hat,
mit ihrem
mit ihrem eigenen UI,
mit ihrer eigenen Software,
die halt nicht nur Apps sind,
sondern auch System-Sachen austauscht,
also System-Settings,
Bildschirme ausgetauscht haben
und
auf der,
wie nennt sich das,
nicht Desktop,
die Startseiten sind halt
ver-Asusifiziert.
Und sogar die Uhr braucht mehr Platz,
weil es die Asus-Uhr ist
und nicht die Standard-Android-Uhr,
also das ist halt eklig,
das geht halt so unter iOS nicht.
Unter iOS bist du eine App
und du darfst in einer App
so ziemlich alles machen,
allerdings sonst nirgends wo was.
Das hat natürlich auch seine Nachteile,
ich mein,
Filesystemzugriff und sowas
ist unter Android natürlich viel einfacher.
Oder von einer Anwendung auf die andere
Anwendung zugreifen,
das geht ja unter iOS nicht,
also Dateisystemmäßig, das funktioniert nicht.
Du kannst eine Anwendung öffnen
und dann sagen, wenn es die Anwendung unterstützt,
öffne diesen Inhalt von dir
in einer anderen Anwendung.
Also iOS ist alles in allem,
finde ich,
benutzerbedienungsmäßig
deutlich konsistenter als das
Android ist. Dafür kannst du einfach
mit Android individueller was
machen.
Das finde ich sind auch so die größten zwei Unterschiede.
Für den 0815 Casual-Noob,
der das benutzt,
kannst du beides benutzen, macht eigentlich überhaupt keinen Unterschied.
Nur wenn du nur
Standardsachen machen willst.
Software gibt es auch das meiste unter beiden
Systemen. Na, so wie Asus
dieses Tablet infiziert hat mit Asus-Zeug,
wäre halt unter iOS nicht möglich
gewesen. Erstens mal gibt es keine
iPhones von Asus,
das ist schon mal das erste, aber selbst
wenn es das geben sollte,
also wenn die da quasi...
Du kannst halt da nicht viel machen.
Du hast halt das Betriebssystem,
das ist von Apple, und bist du nicht
eine Anwendung von Apple, die eine Sonderrolle
hat, darfst du
in deiner Anwendung machen, was du willst, und ansonsten
hast du halt die Finger vom
Betriebssystem zu lassen, beziehungsweise hast du gar keinen
Zugriff drauf. Fertig.
So muss das auch sein. Deswegen ist halt
das relativ konsistent.
Und dass das iPhone X jetzt so teuer ist,
das finde ich richtig beknackt. Das war ja so die
zweite Frage
von dir.
Eternal Lit?
Ich hätte auch einen Custom-ROM drauf
gemacht, aber es gibt für das Asus-Ding keinen.
Ich habe jetzt halt einfach alles
deinstalliert, beziehungsweise deaktiviert.
Bis auf die Sachen, die halt
nicht zu deinstallieren, sondern zu deaktivieren
gehen. Ich habe euch
auch letztens das Video gezeigt von der
Performance-Optimierungs-App. Könnt ihr euch da noch dran erinnern?
So eine Scheiße
kennt man normalerweise nur unter Windows als
vorinstallierte Kack-Software.
Aber nein, Asus liefert sowas halt mit aus.
Vorletzten Stream gezeigt
und auf Twitter gepostet. Die meisten haben es
wahrscheinlich gesehen.
Dieses komische Optimierungstool, was da dabei
ist, was einfach nur dummes Zeug anzeigt.
Richtig
skamast die App
einfach nur. Der Stream läuft immer
noch, ja. Und guckt mal oben links
hin. Wir haben 96%
bis Nacht. Ich muss jetzt mal ins
Discord gucken, ob der Fabian irgendwas geschrieben
hat oder so.
17 Uhr hat er was geschrieben. Seitdem ist er
AFK.
Hier muss er wohl RL-Stelzen.
Da kann man da nichts machen.
Wenn der RL-Stelz too strong ist,
kannst du
dich nicht dagegen wehren.
Und so wie ich ihn kenne, wollte er nicht RL-Stelzen.
Er wurde wahrscheinlich dazu gezwungen.
Bin ich jetzt hier
gelandet?
Ah, hier sind weder keine Mobs.
Ich gehe einfach wieder zurück.
Der Spot da vorne war doch eigentlich ganz gut. Da war kein Mensch.
Man muss von...
Weil ist da gerade Diskussion? Es gibt eigentlich überhaupt
keinen Grund, warum du unbedingt von Windows
das Apple-Dateisystem
lesen musst und umgedreht.
Oder? Fällt jetzt da keiner ein?
Höchstens... Doch!
Wenn du Dual-Boot machst.
Ja, wenn du Dual-Boot machst, dann könnte es Probleme geben.
Was ich meine ist, normalerweise, wenn du jetzt
irgendwelche Dateien freigeben willst bei dir im Netz,
dann machst du das ja über das Netzwerk und nicht
irgendwie, weil du da so Festplatten umbaust oder so.
Na USB-Sticks, da nimmst du irgendwas,
was beide lesen können.
Zum Beispiel nimmst du da FAT
oder ex-FAT oder was weiß ich.
Hast du eigentlich ein
iPhone oder ein Android-Phone? Ich habe ein iPhone.
Ich habe ein iPhone und
drei
Android-Tablets. Also ich habe da ganz gut
einen Einblick, wie die unterschiedlichen Systeme
sind. Deswegen
denke ich, kann ich auch genau das dazu sagen,
was ich eben dazu gesagt habe.
Wo ich die Unterschiede sehe.
Boah, ich sitze hier den ganzen Tag schon vorm Rechner
und grinde. Oh, der Rücken weh.
Muss mal wieder anders hinhocken.
Es gibt... Ne, da gibt's
nicht nur FAT32. Ne, ne.
Boy, ist bald der Abo-Button
da. Ne.
Ich habe mich immer noch nicht drum gekümmert.
Kannst mir...
Wenn du mich abonnieren willst,
kannst du mir 5 Euro donaten.
Oder wäre das der
Prime-Sub gewesen?
Jetzt mach...
Ich mache ja... Ich labere ja immer so rum, so nach dem Motto
Ja, ich kümmere mich nicht um den Abo-Button.
Ich sehe das jetzt...
Hat für mich keine Priorität. Blablabla.
Sonst was.
Nur mal so gefragt, so an
die Leute jetzt hier so.
Mal angenommen,
ich hätte einen Abo-Button.
Wer
würde mir seinen Prime-Sub geben?
WTF?
Okay, das sind ja doch ganz schön viele.
Dann gibt's neben YouTube
Money demnächst ja auch noch
Twitch-Money. Was soll ich denn machen?
Soll ich mir noch ein Klo kaufen?
Ja gut, wir haben ein zweites Bad.
Da muss auch noch eins rein, ja?
WTF? Das ist so viel...
Okay, okay, okay, Leute. Ich habe nichts gesagt.
Ich habe nichts gesagt.
Ich dachte nicht, dass es so viele sind.
Ich dachte nicht, dass es
so viele sind. Okay.
Moment, wo...
Ich blick gerade nicht durch. Wo sind wir denn?
Vielleicht sollte ich doch mal
Twitch kontaktieren.
Vielleicht sollte ich doch mal Twitch kontaktieren.
Ich habe jetzt echt nicht damit gerechnet, dass es so
viele sind.
Ich meine, das ist schon geil, ja?
Ja, das wird... Also, wenn ich
einen Sub-Button habe, dann gibt's natürlich auch eine Sub-Notification.
Ich habe heute Morgen
mit dem
TippyStreamAlert
Creator rumgespielt,
ja? Da kann man richtig geile Sachen mittlerweile machen.
Nicht einfach nur so ein Vogel,
der abgeht, wie ich jetzt gerade habe.
Für Follow und Donation.
Sondern mehr.
Katna, Joe... Naja, jeder,
der aufgepasst hat.
Oder sagen wir mal so, die meisten, die aufgepasst haben,
sollten
mittlerweile eigentlich wissen, wie ich ausschaue.
Es gab
ja schon genug
Spiegelungen und
vor allem Videos, wo ich mal im Hintergrund
rumgelaufen bin und so.
Aber wie gesagt,
ich habe mir eh überlegt, ob ich nicht mal
ein älteres
Foto zeigen soll.
Ich meine, ich sehe immer noch im Prinzip so aus,
bloß dass ich jetzt einen Bart habe und 20 Kilo mehr wiege
als auf dem Bild.
Weil das einfach so ein richtig schönes, schleimiges Foto
ist.
So von der Frisur, von dem Kehl in den Haaren,
ey, boah.
So ein richtiges
Business-Outfit, ey.
Fehlt eigentlich bloß noch der Anzug.
Es ist nur Hemd auf dem Foto, ja.
Aber was für eins, ey.
Da, wo du noch
geschwommen bist... Ne, das war schon danach, das Foto.
Die Zeit, wo
ich noch viel geschwommen bin, da war ich
so Strich in der Landschaft, quasi.
Warum gehe ich eigentlich immer wieder
zurück zu diesem Spot? Der Spot ist kacke, haben wir doch
jetzt schon gesehen. Gleich ist Nacht.
Aber muss der Hardcore
Client gestartet werden.
Sicher, dass du ein Foto mitentfällst?
Das Foto kann ich zeigen.
Aber das mache ich irgendwann mal, also jetzt nicht
morgen oder so.
Das kann ich zeigen. Wie gesagt, ich habe
jetzt mittlerweile...
Ich sehe ja zwar noch so aus, allerdings
ein paar Jahre älter und
mit mehr grauen Haaren und Bart und so.
Ich glaube nicht, dass auf Grundlage
dieses Fotos dann Leute kommen und sagen
in der Bahn, hey Max, bist du es?
Was ja immer noch der Hauptgrund ist, warum ich da keinen Bock
drauf habe.
Ich habe keinen Bock drauf, dass ich morgens
in der Bahn hocke um 6 und
am pennen bin oder sonst wo
und mich irgendwie Leute erkennen oder so.
Oder wenn ich
auf der Arbeit irgendwie Mittagessen
bin mit ein paar Kollegen da, dann habe ich
keinen Bock, dass dann irgendjemand kommt oder so.
Ich weiß halt gar nicht, was ich da sagen soll.
Ich glaube nicht, dass die Leute...
Also ich glaube nicht, dass es nervig wäre
in dem Sinn, ja.
Aber es wäre mir irgendwie peinlich, so.
Weil ich dann nicht wüsste, was ich sagen soll.
Oh fuck!
Fuck! Fuck! Max, was machst du da?
Ich habe gerade den Boss angegriffen.
Alter! Lull!
Hier muss ich echt aufpassen. Ist der Boss weg?
Ja, und wenn ich dann beim Mittagessen
irgendwie angesprochen werde, dann kriegen das auch
noch mehr Leute mit, dass ich irgendwas im Internet
videotechnisch mache, als vielleicht Leute, von denen
ich gar nicht will auf der Arbeit, dass sie es mitkriegen
und so.
Das ist eigentlich der Hauptgrund. Wenn ich nicht arbeiten würde,
wo ich nicht vorhabe
aufzuhören,
dann würde ich jetzt hier wahrscheinlich mit Facecam da hocken.
Von Bud Spencer.
Ganz egal, ganz so schlimm
ist es nicht.
Wobei...
Also ich meine, es gibt Schlimmeres, als zu sein wie Bud Spencer,
oder?
Kannst du eine Maske in der Bar tragen?
Das ist auch überhaupt nicht auffällig, ne?
Warum liegt da Stroh? Warum hast du eine Maske an?
Das ist dann der erste Witz, der kommt in der Bar.
Ein Wikinger-Bart?
Äh...
Nein, ich würde...
Eigentlich habe ich so den typischen Gordon Freeman-Bart.
Oder wie der Fabian mir immer erklärt,
hat einen schwulen Bart.
Was ich nicht wusste.
Kappa-Pride-Bart.
So, 96.
96,2 vor Nacht ungefähr.
Ich sage euch
Leute, da ist...
Heute ist noch 60 drin.
Kein Ding, heute ist noch 60 drin.
Na, wie geht's
dem Fabian denn? Ey, ich sage euch,
da muss ich mal ganz schnell
wegstellen.
Als ich das letzte Mal beim Fabian war, war man
einkaufen, kamen schon gleich die ersten
an den Start, ey.
Hey Friseur, bist du es?
Habe ich mich ganz
unauffällig weggestellt um die Ecke.
Und ich frage mich halt, ne, wenn das beim Fabian
schon so ist, der ja im Vergleich
jetzt zu großen Channels
ist es ja nicht viel, was er an
Zuschauern hat und Leute, die ihn kennen.
Also wenn jetzt mal da irgendwie, keine Ahnung,
nehmen wir einfach mal
Unge oder so, der kann doch eigentlich
gar nicht mehr auf die Straße gehen.
Ich frage mich, wie das sein muss.
Klatze habe ich nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, warum
das einige denken.
Beim Kaboom haben ja auch immer alle gedacht,
er hat eine Klatze. Vielleicht sieht es in den
Spiegelungen so aus oder so.
Jetzt ist Nacht, jetzt sind alle Mobs weg
oder was?
WTF?
Okay, hier muss ich aufpassen, hier ist der Boss wieder.
The grind is real, ja.
Der ist sehr real,
der grind.
Oh, oh, oh, ich kann Black Spirit noch holen.
Ich habe schon wieder Buff Food vergessen.
Wo habe ich denn jetzt aufgehört?
Buff Food, XP, ne?
So, Black Spirit, Black Spirit, XP
noch. Jetzt geht es ab.
Der Kaboom hat doch keine
Refuse gemacht.
Der hat Guides gemacht.
Auf kleiner Wizard, der hat da drüber.
Hat es einen Grund, Tommy, warum du
Opera verwendest?
Ich habe den Browser eigentlich verbannt von meinem
Rechner, seit es an irgendwelche Chinesen verkauft
wurde, das Ding.
Ich benutze jetzt Vivaldi
von dem ehemaligen Opera
Chef.
Ja, hast recht.
Hast recht, Mr. Unlocker. Ja, das war schon
so ein bisschen Review-mäßig.
Aber hauptsächlich hat der eigentlich Guides gemacht.
Okay, Opera auf Android.
Okay, ja. Ja, da gibt es ja
Vivaldi nicht.
Opera Mini habe ich auch auf
auf dem iPhone drauf.
Okay.
Interessant. Wie gesagt, ich kenne nicht
viele, die Opera verwenden. Was geht mit dem Wizard ab?
Warum hat er sich jetzt gerade so nach vorne geworbt?
Desert Combat
Desert Naga Combat
Monka S ist da.
Ist genau gesehen.
Da ist ein
Piss dich, Alde.
Pass auf, die überholen wir
jetzt. Jetzt rennen wir einfach wieder
zurück zum alten Spot.
Gibt kein better Twitch
TV für Opera. Laufen da nicht
die...
Chrome Addons drauf?
Ah, schön viele Möbster hier. Fashion.
Easy Win.
Discord. Äh,
Discord ist nicht der neueste Shit, aber
ist schwer angesagt.
Also TS, Skype
und das ganze Zeug sind aus.
Heutzutage verwendet man Discord.
Also, wenn man cool sein will, ja, dann verwendet man Discord.
Wo wir gerade bei Chrome sind?
Ähm,
ich glaube, ich habe es schon 500 Mal gesagt, gefühlt.
Weil ich wollte gerade sagen, ich wusste nicht,
ob ihr schon wisst, so nach dem Motto.
Piss dich, Alde.
Äh, dass Discord quasi
also die
Discord-Desktop-Anwendung
dass es quasi ein Chrome ist
bloß in einem eigenen Fenster.
In Chrome und
Node.js im eigenen Fenster.
Und dass deswegen
Discord auch gleich mal 500 MB RAM
braucht. Aber
Discord gleichzeitig die einzige Anwendung
ist, von wo ich das okay finde.
Genau.
Deswegen kann man auch CSS editieren in Discord.
Das ist einfach
eine ganz normale JavaScript-Anwendung im Browser.
Auch wenn man die lokale Desktop-Anwendung
verwendet.
Die sollen sich mal alle verpissen hier, was ist hier los?
Eax heißt das, wir spielen wieder
Overwatch zu Season Start.
Moment, sollten hier nicht eigentlich
noch mehr Mobs sein?
Ach, da oben waren die Mobs, genau.
Ich muss jetzt maximale XP ausnutzen
hier nachts.
Genau, Beatport.
Genau deswegen finde ich es auch okay,
dass
Discord Elektron-Anwendung ist.
Allerdings für die
25. Notiz-App
ist es Overkill.
Keiner möchte
Cross-Plattform-Audio-Video selbst programmieren.
Keiner.
Erstens, weil es das schon gibt
und zweitens, weil das scheiße ist.
Wo sind Mobs? Ich brauch Mobs!
Unten sind Mobs.
Hehe.
Ja Eax, dann müssen wir wieder Overwatch spielen.
Season Start.
Season Start ist ja glaube ich 31.
oder war es der erste? Ich weiß es nicht genau.
Zumindest die Placements
machen wir, danach gucken wir mal.
Ups, der etwas drückt da.
Wie voll es hier ist.
Ich fasse es nicht.
Ich muss mich gerade auf
Monster-Crime konzentrieren.
Weil die Nacht und den Black Spirit
XP-Boost will ich richtig ausnutzen.
Guck mal, wir haben schon 97.
97 gleich. Easy.
Easy.
Wie gesagt, ich lese gleich den Rest.
Ja Tommy, demnächst programmieren wir was.
Wieder im Stream. Und zwar einen Food-Timer
für BDO.
Der anzeigt, wann man welches
Buff-Food nehmen muss.
Weil ich mich immer wieder verdrücke.
Oh, wie tap ich bin überladen gleich.
Jetzt keine Zeit, keine Zeit
irgendwie abgeben zu gehen. Keine Zeit.
Muss ich wegschmeißen.
So, jetzt haben wir wieder Platz.
Der ist tot.
So viele Leute hier.
Ich brauch doch EXP.
Oh, oh fuck.
Wieder den Boss gepullt.
So, hier dazwischen ist aber glaube ich keiner
so richtig. Zwischen den beiden
Spots. Hier sind ja auch genug Mobs.
Da kreiseln wir einfach uns jetzt hier einen ab.
Damn.
Ja gut, das ist ja
da habe ich jetzt ja schon seit ein paar Monaten
nichts mehr gemacht. Aber
das will ich auch noch fertig machen.
Vor allem muss ich in dem einen Comet mal
meinen
diesen, diesen
Int-Cast-Wahnsinn, den ich da
aus Gag im Stream eingebaut habe
rausnehmen. Wenn das hier irgendjemand sieht,
denkt er noch, ich meine das ernst.
Damn. Okay, nice.
Bis dann, Erx.
7 Uhr 9, 7 Uhr 9.
Es geht ab. Guck mal an die Nacht, die geht noch eine Weile.
Jetzt dreht er auf,
der Wubbler.
Jetzt dreht der Wubbler auf.
Hier unten dürfte jetzt wieder Respawn sein, oder?
Moment, wo sind wir lang
gekommen?
Piss dich, Alte.
6 Level ist Max. Ne, ne, Max Level
gibt es nicht. Also
62 ist erreichbar.
Zwar mit wahnsinns
Grind, aber erreichbar.
Alles da drüber braucht einfach
zu lang.
Ich glaube in Korea ist der höchste
63, oder wie war das?
Aber 60 reicht.
So, als, als, erstmal als Ziel.
Dann kriegt man alle Spells,
die man so braucht.
60 ist quasi das neue 50.
Moment, wir sind zu schnell.
Die Mobs sind durch, wieder Respawn.
Sackt.
Hier, hier, Respawn jetzt.
Sind sie schon wieder.
Zu wenig Mobs, zu viele Spieler.
Guckt euch das mal an. Und es ist Nacht.
Da ist ja schon wieder der nächste Typ.
Äh, bei mir hängt kein Stream.
Ich hab die Vorschau an, da hängt nix.
Wie BDO manchmal.
Vielleicht ist hier oben
der Spot frei.
Ist eigentlich mal ein Pet.
Ja, Balkonern, das Gefühl hab ich auch.
Da sind auf einmal viel mehr Leute da, als noch vor ein paar Stunden.
Da vorne ist schon wieder
der nächste.
Hier ist auch alles weg.
Das ist halt BDO Maxpunch.
Das ist halt BDO.
BDO läuft nicht gut.
BDO ist halt ziemlich kacke.
Von der technischen Seite aus.
So Performance mäßig.
Mein Gott, ey. Wie viele Lo-
So.
Ich wechsel jetzt einfach Channel.
Wie findet ihr eigentlich das Bild von der Katze?
Was für ein Bild von der Katze
gefällt euch besser?
Das aktuelle, oder das was wir gestern hatten,
wo es auf der Decke liegt?
Ich finde, dass das aktuelle
sieht eher so porträtmäßig
aus.
Denker Katze quasi.
Majestätisch.
Genau, Casino Café.
Das ist das richtige Wort.
Erhaben.
Denker Katze passt zu den Themen heute.
Oh ja, das stimmt.
Was wir heute schon wieder alles für Zeug erzählt haben.
Von schwarzen Löchern
zu
Ach, was weiß
ich alles.
Welche Fragen man Außerirdischen
stellen würde, war ja alles dabei.
Hier ist keiner. Das ist gut.
Kann ich alle überhaupt selbst recken.
Das ist halt das Schöne am Wizardcrime.
Du kannst da stehen, drückst drei Spells,
alles tot, gehst zum nächsten Pack.
Keine Verrenkung, keine Tastenkombination.
Einfach
Stelle stehen, Bäm, Attack.
Und wenn noch was steht, den da und gut ist.
Schon wieder Loot wegschmeißen.
Das war besonders
optimiert in der Casting-Animation jetzt.
Geht 144
Hertz mit einem Laptop
ohne Displayport?
Über DVI?
Eventuell.
Wenn das der Notebook hat.
Dual Dingsbums
DVI oder wie das genau hieß.
Dual, ich habe vergessen wie es heißt.
HDMI geht glaube ich auch
ab HDMI 2.
Spielst du auch PvP?
Dafür sind Zaubere immer schlecht.
Wizard ist in dem Game mit
einer der besten PvP-Klassen.
Und das Geile ist,
sowohl
im Massen-PvP oder bei Belagerungen
als auch tatsächlich im Duell.
Ich habe es selbst nicht für möglich gehalten.
Aber, ähm,
eine der letzten
One-on-One Turniere hat ein Wizard gewonnen.
Nein, Tommi, ich glaube
das wird nicht funktionieren.
Habe ich so das Gefühl.
Außer gibst du
300 Euro für Adapter oder so aus.
Also am besten ist, du hast Displayport
oder ich glaube HDMI 2.
Mit HDMI 2
geht es auch.
Ja, ist ja auch so. Also, äh,
Duellmäßig gibt es ja auch, ähm,
Ninja
und so, die sollen wohl auch ziemlich gut sein. Aber,
ich glaube die
OPste One-on-One-Klasse
zurzeit ist Valkyre, wenn ich das so
was man so an offiziellen
was so im Forum liest und so, ne?
Oder auf Reddit besser gesagt.
Valkyre müsste so zurzeit mit
die OPste One-on-One-Klasse sein, aber
für sonst wenig zu gebrauchen.
Aber hier spricht jetzt
nicht der Profi, sondern der Reddit-Leser
und, wie gesagt, der
bestausgerüstetste Noob in BDO.
Kalzion für
15 Minuten Bell? Easy.
Oh, kann ich schon wieder wechseln?
Moment, ich kann doch nicht wieder wechseln.
Naja, egal.
Pech gehabt.
Außerdem ist da wahrscheinlich eh voll. Da cryne ich
lieber die Nacht hier noch in Ruhe.
Ist grad schön leer.
Achso, Sibaro, brauchst du gar kein HDMI 2?
Ok, aber HDMI 2 kannst
du dann auf jeden Fall.
Wo sehe ich was für HDMI habe? Guck ins Handbuch
von einer Grafikkarte.
Oder beziehungsweise auf die Webseite
vom Hersteller,
wo es das halt
gibt, die Details zu dem
Laptop.
Würdest du den ganzen Cryne auch machen, wenn du
jetzt nicht mit dem Chat labern kannst?
Also Chat labern
macht es natürlich interessanter.
Auf jeden Fall.
Aber ich würde es wahrscheinlich auch so
machen, vielleicht jetzt nicht so
übertrieben intensiv, wie jetzt.
Aber man muss es ja nicht oft machen.
Ich cryne jetzt bis
16, dann ist gut.
Dann werde ich mir den Spot hier auch
die nächsten zwei Monate nicht mehr angucken.
Machen wir das eh. 60 ist das Beste.
Ich hoffe, ich habe überhaupt
genug Skillpoints, um dann alles auszuspecken.
Kann das sein, dass ich kein
Pet habe?
Deswegen sterben die Mobs nicht.
Hier ist schön leer, hier ist keine Sau.
Was willst du machen, wenn 60 bist?
Mit dem Fabian
im neuen Gebiet.
Rumstelzen.
Und seinen Ranger ein bisschen
Wizard carryen.
Wobei, bald ist er ja OP mit einem der nächsten
Patches, dann kann er
mich wieder carryen.
Was machst du? Nach dem Cryne ist vor dem Cryne.
Ich meine, das ist BDO.
Dass es in Woe ist nach dem
Raid auch vor dem Raid.
Oder ich werde zum krassen
Lifeskiller und Angler.
Dann machen wir Angelstream.
Dann fahre ich dann oben
aufs Meer, suche mir einen Fisch-Hotspot und
angel. Und ihr könnt bald zugucken.
Was bestimmt
sehr spannend ist.
Wenn ich dann 5 Stunden
Tasten drücke und Quicktime-Events
mache.
Ey, das Geruckel von dem Game.
BDO, oh man.
Das liegt aber auch nicht an meinem Rechner, weil es sind immer
die gleichen Stellen, an denen es ruckelt. Es ist halt BDO.
100 Viewer, easy.
Schon die ganze Zeit in dem
Trainer.
Und das geile ist, seitdem ich jetzt aktiver
streame hier,
habe ich quasi
kontinuierlich Viewer, also
Durchschnitt, ne? Viewer-Zuwachs.
Und wir liegen
jetzt eigentlich immer, und das
ohne Ankündigung wohlgemerkt.
Das ist das, worum es mir geht.
Ich mache keine Ankündigung zur Zeit auf Twitter
oder YouTube oder sonst was.
Ich meine, mit Ankündigungen früher hatten wir
immer auch easy. 100, 130,
40, 50, je nachdem.
Aber ich bin ohne
Ankündigung haben wir quasi jetzt
fast so viel wie vorher mit Ankündigung.
Also es lohnt sich auf jeden Fall, aktiv zu streben.
Und ich werde mich jetzt
auch mal ums Subbutton kümmern, nachdem ich ja eben
gerade erfahren habe, dass
das wirklich, dass sich da
viele mitmachen würden, was ich gar nicht
gedacht hätte.
Warum ich keine Ankündigung mache?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Frag mich, durch so komplizierte Sachen.
Wahrscheinlich, weil ich keine Leute habe,
die die ganze Zeit sagen,
oh, scheiß MMO,
lull, spiel mal Battlefield,
oder was auch immer.
Obwohl, eigentlich sind ja meine Zuschauer
nicht so schlimm.
Ja, vielleicht mache ich Ankündigungen
zum Sylvester-Stream.
Die ganzen NoLife-Leute können dann vorbeikommen.
War es mich unter den
empfohlenen Kanälen empfunden? Okay.
Weil du sonst
BDO guckst?
Oder, das würde mich jetzt interessieren,
was guckst du denn sonst so?
Wie kommt Twitch darauf,
meinen Channel zu empfehlen?
Weil ich meine,
die wissen ja nicht,
dass du mich von YouTube kennst.
Oder kennst du mich gar nicht von YouTube?
Dann kannst du die Frage vergessen.
Das würde mich ja mal interessieren,
wie sie das verknüpft haben.
98% Hype, jawoll.
Es sind noch 2 Stunden Ingame-Nacht.
Oh, Buff-Food.
Leute, welches Buff-Food ist dran?
Ich glaube, das hier.
Das da. Jawoll.
Richtig.
Easy Clap.
Ich habe mal den richtigen Knopf gedrückt.
Meistens Final Fantasy 14.
Okay.
Kann man das zur Zeit wieder spielen?
Also, wir haben das ja auch
lange gespielt.
So 500-600 Stunden, würde ich mal sagen.
Und was uns
über Final Fantasy 14 genervt hat,
also mit uns meine ich jetzt den Friseur nicht.
Du machst Computer-Videos.
Auch.
Ich dachte, du bist hier über YouTube gekommen.
Dann habe ich das...
Das ist ja noch geiler.
Dann funktioniert ja tatsächlich
das Empfehlungssystem auf Twitch
im Vergleich zu YouTube.
Was wollte ich jetzt sagen?
Final Fantasy 14.
Das Problem, was wir mit Final Fantasy 14 hatten,
war, dass es sich limitiert.
So nach dem Motto, ja, ihr könnt euch
Ausrüstung kaufen
für irgendwie die und die Kristalle.
Aber man konnte pro Woche nur so und so viel
dieser Kristalle sammeln.
Und man hatte schlicht und ergreifend nichts zu tun.
Und das, obwohl wir nicht
die High-End Raider waren oder so in dem Game.
Was es ja so
auch nicht wirklich gab.
Bis auf ein paar ultraschwere Herausforderungen
für ein paar
so normale, bisschen schwerere Raids gab es ja gar nicht.
Es gab so dieses
GG Eats Zeug, was jeder geschafft hat.
Oder halt
damals noch Alexander,
was so ultraschwer war.
Also nicht
der normale Alexander, der Epic Raid
oder wie das da hieß.
Deswegen haben wir dann gesagt,
wir hören mit Final Fantasy 14 auf.
Weil es keinen Sinn hatte.
Quasi
Patch kommt raus,
man hat nach ein paar Tagen alles
und wartet dann wieder einen Monat auf den nächsten Patch.
Das war blöd.
Worum geht es denn gerade?
Äh, Final Fantasy 14.
Warum wir damit aufgehört haben.
Könntest du auch mal Spiele zeigen?
Was meinst du? Final Fantasy oder was?
Naja, da bin ich durch mit.
Die neue Erweiterung habe ich auch gar
nicht gekauft.
Und ich habe auch gelesen,
mit der neuen Erweiterung sollen wohl
an die 30-40% der Spieler aufgehört haben.
Weiß ich jetzt nicht,
ob das offizielle Zahlen sind
oder ob das so wieder übertriebenes Reddit Gelaber ist.
Weiß ich nicht.
Oh fuck, Inf ist voll.
Wie ist das denn?
Oh fuck, Inventar ist voll.
So als müsste man da viel machen.
Man drückt jetzt einfach zwei Knöpfe,
dann hat man wieder bis zum Morgen
zumindest genug Space.
Als wäre das jetzt sonderlich schwer gewesen.
Naja, trollt euch nur im Chat.
Ich kann das gerade nicht hundertprozentig verfolgen.
Ich muss die letzte Stunde
XP-Grind ausnutzen.
Alter BDO,
immer an der gleichen Stelle ruckelt der Scheiß.
Piss dich, Alde.
Weiß gar nicht,
ist es denn der Alde?
Ja, ist es.
Alles weg. Speed an.
Weiter.
Nächster Spot.
Wieder zurück.
Komm, 9.90, 9.90, bevor die Nacht zu Ende ist.
Easy, 9.90, bevor die Nacht zu Ende ist.
Ja, Beatport, genau.
Die Massen an Fangrills.
Ich sag dann, ich bin ein Wisser.
Darf ich dich verzaubern?
Das muss man RPG-mäßiger sagen.
Ich bin ein mächtiger Zauberer.
Darf ich euch verzaubern?
Dann guckt doch mal,
Hanfwand,
guckt doch mal auf dem, auf der Homepage
vom Hersteller, auf der Support-Seite
von deinem Notebook-Modell
nach. Das haben die Hersteller doch alle
mittlerweile auf ihrer Seite stehen. Da gehst du in den Support-Bereich,
gibst ein, was du für ein Notebook hast,
da steht doch genau da, was das für technische Eigenschaften
hat. Das haben doch alle Hersteller mittlerweile.
Richtigen Endgame-Content
gibt's in BDO nicht.
Was verstehst du in Endgame-Content?
Du kannst hier saumäßig
viel machen.
Also Endgame-Content in Form von Gruppen-Rates
mit Dungeon-Finder gibt es nicht. Ne, das stimmt.
Braucht man aber auch nicht.
Theoretisch sollte jede Grafikkarte
die gleichen Anschlüsse haben.
Allerdings bei Notebooks weiß man
das nie so genau, weil da oftmals so Special-Dinger
drin stecken.
Also entweder so ein bisschen aufgebohrt oder
abgespeckte oder was auch immer für Versionen.
Also
im Desktop-Bereich ist es halt so,
da ist vielleicht die
Bestückung
ein bisschen anders.
Dass du dann irgendwie, keine Ahnung,
3x HDMI statt 2x HDMI oder sonst was
hast.
Aber da machen sie im Prinzip auch das, was
geht. Also ich glaube nicht,
wenn das geht, ein HDMI 2 zu
verbauen, dass dann irgendein Hersteller noch sagt, nö,
dann machen wir bloß 1.4.
Alter, was wollen die denn? Das sind meine Mobs.
Hör mal Awakening-Buff an.
Reicht die Nacht vorbei? Wir haben noch immer
keinen 99.
Nacht vorbei.
Oh, ich hab jetzt so in einer scheiß Haltung
die ganze Zeit da gesessen. Ich muss mich jetzt mal
irgendwie so
halb hinlegen.
Da merkt man, manchmal merke ich,
dass ich 33 bin.
Manchmal merke ich's.
Früher konnte ich 10 Stunden
vorm Rechner in scheiß Haltung
sitzen und grinden
und leveln
und campen
und, ach, keine Ahnung, alles,
ja. Und heute
tut man nach ein paar Stunden der Rücken weh, wenn ich scheiße sitze.
Ey, Lothric spielt
gerade Fortnite. Lass ihn doch spielen, wenn ihm das
Spaß macht. Flankt er dabei
auch 20 Viber weg?
Oh, Mann. Ich bin froh, wenn wir das
hier fertig haben. Ich geb jetzt
gleich nochmal
ähm, Loot
ab. Und dann machen wir, wenn wir
99% haben, geben wir Loot ab.
Also ich geh jetzt, ich geh jetzt zu
zurück. Und dann haben wir
99% geben, Loot ab, dann haben wir das letzte
Prozent noch. Beste AE.
Nix mehr da. Ähm,
die Map ist kaputt. Seht ihr's auch?
Die Map ist kaputt.
Wenn ich ranwarp,
die Map ist immer noch kaputt.
Jetzt ist die Map nicht mehr kaputt.
Technik Wunder
BDO.
Die Map hat sich selbst gefixt.
Wo geht's hier überhaupt zurück? Ich blick
da mal durch grad, wo wir sind. Wo sind wir denn überhaupt?
Ah, hier sind wir.
Plus, an nem ziemlich
scheiß Winkel, um hier runter zu gehen.
Äh,
äh, da.
Hüpft da runter, der kleine Wizard.
Die werden gebasht!
Die wollen gebasht werden. Ich seh's denen an.
Die sagen, Max, bashe mich. Für Level 60.
Easy Bash.
Äh, komm, Nonsens. Mach ich, mach ich.
Sogar schon aufgenommen.
Da fliegt die XP
hier. Sekunde, ich muss mal kurz
was aufschreiben. Sag mal,
kennt sich jemand mit der Geschichte von BDO
aus? Und kann mir jemand
sagen, wie die Welt von BDO heißt?
Also, wie heißt
die, wie heißt die Welt von BDO?
Jede Fantasywelt
hat nen Namen sonst.
Aber die Welt von BDO ist namenlos.
Äh, Attik Summer fragt,
ähm, ich mach
gerade die Ausbildung zum Fachinformatiker
Systemintegration.
Ähm,
im letzten, naja, ich hab leider überhaupt
keine Ahnung, was ich als Abschlussprojekt
machen soll. Irgendwelche Vorschläge.
Ja, was für ne Firma bist
du denn?
Was machen die denn so?
Hahaha, zack, das,
das wär ein richtig guter Name dafür,
ja, das stimmt schon.
Okay, ihr habt auch keine Ahnung, wie die Welt heißt. Wahrscheinlich
hat da Pearl Abyss oder
wie auch immer die genau heißen, haben nicht dran gedacht.
Hab ich gerade, wie die Welt brauchen Namen.
Das ist egal, die Welt braucht erstmal Grinding Spots.
Wenn die Welt Grinding Spots
hat, dann können wir ihr vielleicht auch einen Namen geben.
Aber sie hat jetzt ja Grinding Spots.
You feel,
was you feel like? Ich hab's nicht
gelesen. Ich bin lighter und kann schneller
rennen. Ich bin nicht mehr so
sick. So,
Loot abgeben, 1% noch.
Easy Clap, Easy Win,
Easy Level 60.
Huge Mercy Plays.
Massive Mercy Plays.
Guck mal, da brennt
der Wizard. Seht ihr das?
Der brennt, deswegen rennt der auch so
schnell. Das ist wie Mario, wenn er
mit dem Hintern in die Lava fällt.
Jetzt brennt er nicht mehr.
Bist du mit dem Ride hier langsamer?
Komm auf, das reibt hier an.
Also, mit meinem Kack-Ride.
Moment.
Wo zum Teufel bin ich denn jetzt hingerannt?
Tja, hier war ich ja noch nie.
Ist gar nicht,
dass es hier überhaupt lang geht.
Man's not hot.
Man never hot.
Wir sind gerade ein bisschen zu weit gerannt.
Aber das ist der eigentliche
Pro-Weg. Der geht hier
lang.
Hier habt ihr ihn zum ersten Mal gesehen.
Moment. Ha, hier geht's
lang. So.
Letztes Mal sellen.
Brauchen wir nicht rappen.
Never rap.
So. Letztes
Prozent, Leute. Letztes Prozent.
Oh, jetzt ist er wieder hot.
Also, Atix, du kannst fast alles
als Abschlussprojekt machen,
wenn du das ordentlich
verkaufst.
Und wie gesagt, ein Abschlussprojekt
braucht
nicht unbedingt
wahnsinnig viel
technischen Inhalt.
Also du musst jetzt nicht sagen, ich mach das
und weil dir das zu wenig vorkommt,
machst du jetzt noch irgendwie das, das, das und das mit dabei.
Das ist nicht Sinn und Zweck der Sache.
Du musst halt zeigen, dass du in der Lage bist
sowas umzusetzen.
Und dazu gehört auch beispielsweise Analyse,
welche Produkte du auswählst und einsetzt.
Und die eigentliche technische Umsetzung ist oftmals
bei einer Abschlussarbeit das kleinste.
Was das Ganze auch irgendwie witzlos macht.
Aber so ist es halt laut IHK.
Willst du wissen, was ich
gemacht hab als Abschlussarbeit?
Atix?
Da muss ich nämlich nochmal kurz in mich gehen, wie ich das genau
genannt hab.
Klar, sag an.
Ich kann mich an den Titel nicht mal genau erinnern.
Also
stell dir das Ganze einfach schön umschrieben vor.
Ich hab ein
VPN gebaut.
Von Standort A nach Standort B.
Das wars.
Im Kern wars das.
Also daran sieht man, man muss nicht viel machen.
Es muss aber die Sache drum herum halt stimmen.
Ich hab ein VPN gebaut.
Ein Layer 2 VPN.
Von Standort A nach Standort B.
Damit man an Standort B mit den Telefonen
mit der Telefonanlage an Standort A
also dass man die Telefone an Standort B
mit der Telefonanlage an Standort A verbinden konnte.
Und dazu hab ich
ein Layer 2 VPN gebaut.
Und
das wars.
Allerdings hab ich das ein bisschen
schöner umschrieben.
Wart mal, das Projekt hieß irgendwie
ähm
Standortkopplung bla bla bla bla
Boah, ich kriegs nicht mehr richtig
zusammen.
Wie war das denn?
Standortkopplung
Irgendwie sowas.
Standortkopplung zur transparenten
Anbindung von End...
Ne, das ist zu kurz. Das war mehr. Irgendwie sowas in der Richtung.
Irgendwas wie Standortkopplung zur transparenten
Anbindung von Endgeräten mit bla bla bla bla.
So.
Und dazu gehört
neben diesem VPN aufbauen
erstmal die Auswahl
der richtigen VPN Technologie.
Das ist was da steht die IHK drauf.
Also wenn du nicht einfach
sagst, ich verwende jetzt OpenVPN
weil ich Bock hab OpenVPN zu
verwenden, dann
begibts in zwei Wochen.
Sondern wenn du quasi ne Tabelle
machst und reinschreibst
die und die Produkte hast du dir
ausgesucht, untersucht und
am Ende kommst du halt zu dem Schluss, dass
OpenVPN das beste
ist um dein Vorhaben umzusetzen.
Dann musst du noch rechnen
was kostet es denn Arbeitsaufwand
was kostet denn die Hardware
und machst da so ein bisschen BWL Scheiß
wo die IHK auch drauf steht
und dann am Ende machst du
das eigentliche Projekt.
So und nachdem das bei mir 10 Jahre her ist
kann ich das hier im Stream erzählen
weil das juckt eh keine Sau mehr.
Ich hab mein Abschlussprojekt gar nicht gemacht.
Ich hab mein Abschlussprojekt
nie aufgebaut.
Ich hab Doku geschrieben
ich hab
Produktauswahl gemacht
den eigentlichen Aufbau
VPN mäßig.
Das hab ich in der 4M bei mir auf dem Rechner gemacht.
Ich hab nie 2 Standorte
gekoppelt.
Auch wenn ich das in der Doku so geschrieben hab.
Aber da gehts ja letztendlich auch gar nicht drum.
Der IHK gehts auch viel eher
drum, dass du halt zeigst, dass du die anderen Seiten
kannst, dass du ein bisschen
die kaufmännische Seite kannst, dass du Produkte auswählen kannst
und ein Projekt von Anfang bis Ende halt
richtig angehst.
Und auch wenn ich geschrieben hab, dass ich
2 Standorte gekoppelt hab
hab ich nicht wirklich 2 Standorte gekoppelt
weil das technisch überhaupt nicht umsetzbar war
zum damaligen Zeitpunkt.
Sondern hab 2 VPNs gekoppelt und das halt
simuliert. Aber das ist ja auch okay.
Ich hab halt nicht genau das
gemacht, was im Titel drin steht.
Und
hab ich das schon mal erzählt
am Tag
von meiner Abschlussprüfung
Am Tag von meiner Abschlussprüfung
ruft mich jemand
an von
ne
genau
mich ruft jemand von der Arbeit an
am Tag der Abschlussprüfung
meine Abschlussprüfung war um 14 Uhr
und mich ruft am Tag der Abschlussprüfung
jemand von der Arbeit an und meint so ey
Max die IHK hat hier gerade angerufen
irgendwas stimmt mit deinem
mit deiner Abschluss
mit deiner Abschlussarbeit nicht
hab ich gesagt hä was wollen die denn
das haben die doch schon längst bekommen
und haben das doch schon seit Wochen
schon auf
hab ich bei der IHK angerufen
und
da hatte ich dann jemand von der IHK
dran und hab gesagt
ich hab erfahren irgendwas stimmt nicht
was ist denn da los und da sagt die mir am Telefon
sie sind durchgefallen
was ich wie
ich bin durchgefallen meine Prüfung
ist erst um 14 Uhr
wie kann ich durchgefallen sein
meine Prüfung ist erst um 14 Uhr
es geht nicht ich kann nicht durchgefallen sein wollt ihr mich verarschen
oder was?
was meinst du
sie sind durchgefallen sie haben ihre
Abschlussdokumentation nicht eingereicht
was
na klar hab ich die eingereicht
vor keine Ahnung vor
einem Monat oder so schon
ich hab sogar noch die Bestätigungs E-Mail
von euch
das ihr die bekommen habt
so
und da hab ich mich dann
eingeloggt auf der Arbeit remote
dann musste ich muss man sich mal überlegen
ja die Bestätigung
E-Mail von der IHK raussuchen
ich stell euch mal vor ich hätte die gelöscht
ich mein
das ist eine Bestätigungs E-Mail
da erwartet man das nicht das man die mal irgendwie braucht so wirklich
ja und hab die dann
der Frau von der IHK geschickt
und da meint die so oh
ah ich sehe gerade die Uhrzeit wo sie abgeloadet
haben 5 Minuten später sind unsere Server abgekackt
also hat sie ein bisschen schöner formuliert
also sprich die IHK Server sind
5 Minuten abgestürzt nachdem ich meine Abschlussarbeit
hochgeladen hab und hab meine Abschlussarbeit verloren
ja und dann hab ich gesagt ich hab meine Abschlussarbeit verloren
ja so und
dann meinte sie ja ok das ist natürlich nicht ihre Schuld
dann gehen sie heute Mittag trotzdem zu ihrer Prüfung
hab ich schon an der WTF
ich wäre garantiert auch zu meiner Prüfung
so gegangen ja
gehen sie doch jetzt zu ihrer Prüfung
und ob das möglich ist dass ich das
nochmal ausdrucke und mitbringe
sie sagt ja klar kein Ding druck ich aus
bring ich nochmal mit und letztendlich
war das für mich dann sogar ganz gut
ich hab dann dann meine Präsentation gemacht
ein bisschen erzählt und getan und gemacht
und
und der Teile daran war der Prüfungsausschuss
hat quasi
meine Abschlussarbeit
mein Projekt zum ersten Mal
10 Minuten vor der Präsentation gesehen
die hatten keine Ahnung
die hatten wirklich absolut
keine Ahnung
und konnten sich halt auch null drauf vorbereiten
und quasi
als ich da reingegangen bin hab ich ihnen
die Zettel in die Hand gedrückt die ich ausgedruckt hab
so
und dementsprechend lief das halt auch
ich hab mein Zeug erzählt
und die haben halt da gesessen
haben genickt
und normalerweise ist es dann so
danach gibts dann noch eine Fragerunde
also sprich wenn du fertig bist präsentieren
fragen die dich noch was zum Projekt
oder zu was wovon sie Ahnung haben
manche haben halt von dem wo man das Projekt
gemacht hat keine Ahnung
und meine Fragerunde lief ungefähr so
Herr sowieso hat alles funktioniert
ja
hat alles funktioniert
ok das wars
länger ging die Fragerunde nicht
95% am Ende
easy clap
das war der easiest clap of my life
diese Präsentation da
einmal bitte easy clap
ich brauch jetzt bisschen easy clap im Chat
das war wirklich easiest clap of my life
ja danke
so ist gut
soweit zu meiner IHK Abschluss Prüfung
golden dagger easy
wisst ihr
Kakao hat meine Story auch gefallen
also Attix ich hoffe nicht das es
bei dir auch so planlos läuft ja
aber man darf nicht vergessen es ist die IHK
ich
was die
Existenz der IHK
rechtfertigt habe ich bis heute auch nicht verstanden
warum es die gibt
und
was die macht
auch wenn sie mich schon zu zig Seminaren
eingeladen haben
wo sie mir erklären wollen was sie machen
und das ist ganz tolles aber
na
bin schon nie hingegangen
geh ich auch nicht hin
Wonka Shake
gibts nicht mehr als Emote ich hab leider nur 5
bei der Abschluss Prüfung
ist die IHK selbst die Prüfung
ja so kam mir das echt vor
Wahnsinn oder
oh man
ja Beatbrot
es ist erstaunlich wie viel
ähm
also wie viele Berufsschulen
und äh Läden die
eigentlich quasi den Leuten es beibringen
sollen wie man es macht es selbst nicht können
ah gut
Berufsschulen sind Schulen und über Schulen haben wir uns ja letztens
erst ausgelassen da fehlt es auch
schlicht und ergreifend einfach an Leute die Ahnung haben
und vor allem Ahnung und Zeit
und an Geld
60 wenn naja
weiß nicht
halbe Stunde
15 Minuten halbe Stunde
15 Minuten halbe Stunde so
ich hab schon wieder alles gebasht hier
jetzt ist es mir auch egal ob hier irgend jemand
mit den Mobs streitig macht
das die letzten paar Prozent packen wir auch so
ist überhaupt kein Ding mehr
der Fabian wird gucken wenn ich 60 bin
äh
das hätte er nicht für möglich gehalten dass das so schnell geht
bei welchem Buff Food sind wir an stehen geblieben
ich vergesse das immer
Hauptsache ich hab XP Food
dann ist das wieder dran
ja Atex Tschüss
ja Hanfwand
gibt jede Menge stärkere Mobs
aber zum Expen und Crinden ist natürlich am besten
wenn man Mobs basht die
easy sind
weil mehr Mobs mehr Exp
vielleicht Crinden ich morgen
und übermorgen mit dem Fabian im neuen
Gebiet ein bisschen
da gibt es stärkere Mobs
ja Patrick da hast du Glück gehabt
was dir passieren könnte ist natürlich
dass die dich irgendeinen Mist fragen von dem sie Ahnung haben
bei mir haben sie einfach nur
gefragt hat es funktioniert habe ich gesagt ja
ich meine es hat ja auch funktioniert
das ist ja nicht gelogen ich habe es ja gemacht
ich habe es ja mit VMs gemacht
anstatt wirklich
zwei Standorte zu koppeln weil es einfach damals
nicht funktioniert hat
also organisatorisch so konnte ich nichts für
findest du es
wichtig öfters den Arbeitgeber
zu wechseln für immer das die Leute
bei 50 Firmenwaren haben da aber
selber noch gar kein Bock drauf weil mir meine Firma
gut passt nö
wenn dir die Firma gut passt
warum ich meine
da gibt es ja keinen Grund zu wechseln
wenn dir das Aufgabengebiet gefällt
wenn dir die Bezahlung passt
und vor allem wenn dir das Umfeld gefällt
es wird von vielen Leuten viel zu
wenig gewichtet finde ich
gibt es auch keinen Grund
ich war auch nur bei einer Firma vorher
aber jetzt bin ich
ewig schon bei der wo ich
seit 2012
glaube ich
bei der wo ich jetzt bin
hättest besseres gear könntest du
Schulz fahren Schulz?
du meinst Sausen?
ach ne du meinst den Spot
neben Sausens
doch den könnte ich auch so fahren
die Mobs krieg ich kaputt
aber die halten ein bisschen zu viel aus
zum solo grind
Duo ist das super
Duo ist der
benachbarte Sausen Spot richtig gut
und wenn dir irgendwas nicht
mehr passt an der Firma dann wird es ja auch
soweit sein das merkst du ja dann
Mobs wo seid ihr denn
aber wenn du irgend
wenn du irgendwann mal sagst
hey mir gefällts hier nicht mehr
woanders krieg ich mehr Kohle
und es ist bei deiner Firma nicht mehr drin
und es nervt dich so sehr und du brauchst unbedingt mehr Geld
oder willst es haben oder denkst was auch immer
oder du hast irgendwelche Kollegen
die dir mega abfacken
was weiß ich
dann kannst du ja immer noch sagen du gehst woanders hin
vor allem wenn dir die Firma
also auch noch irgendwie
dir bietet also ich mein damit jetzt nicht unbedingt
Schulungen machen oder so
dass man sich in
interessanten und
dass man sich
dass man ein bisschen üben kann
und Sachen machen kann die einem was bringen
also zum Beispiel
die Versionsverwaltung
also die Softwareverwaltung
Repoverwaltung die ich bei uns mache
das ist zwar das eine
allerdings kenne ich mich deswegen halt
ich würde es jetzt einfach mal von mir behaupten
ziemlich gut mit Git aus
und Git ist ein Skill der vor allem
wenn man da mehr kann als die simplen
Sachen die jeder hinkriegt
ist ziemlich begehrt zur Zeit
also wie gesagt
mehr als diesen Standard Scheiß den jeder kann
allgemein wenn man sich in Gebieten
richtig gut auskennt ist das
nie verkehrt
weil es gibt so viele Leute
die ein bisschen Windows Server mit ein bisschen
AD machen können ohne sich wirklich auszukennen
aber Leute die von was wirklich
Ahnung haben und nicht nur labern oder
nicht nur in irgendeine Knowledge Base gucken
oder sonst was
die gibt es halt überall viel zu wenig
und die musst du halt auch gut bezahlen
sonst
gehen sie halt woanders hin
oder halt andere Anreize bieten
kennst du ein gutes Buch für Git?
also wenn du es
du kannst dir das
gitscm.com ist das glaube ich
kannst du dir durchlesen
das ist mehr oder weniger so das offizielle Tutorial
weil die Gitman Pages kann man komplett vergessen
sind einfach Scheiße
ich habe noch nie so Crap gelesen wie die Gitman Pages
und ansonsten auf Deutsch
es gibt ein deutsches
Buch mit rotem
roter Schrift
git bla bla bla bla bla bla
ich weiß nicht mehr
wie war dann der Titel von dem Ding
weiß ich nicht mehr
ich glaube von Markt und Technik oder wie dieser Verlag heißt
Technik
es gibt 1-2 gute deutsche
Git Bücher
Stack Overflow Carried
sogar auf Stack Overflow suchen
kriegen viele nicht hin
so blöd es klingt
ich habe keine Ahnung
und das ist eines der wichtigsten Sachen
was man heute eigentlich kennen muss
jemand ordentlich sucht
du musst viele Sachen nicht wissen
du musst in vielen Sachen dich insoweit auskennen
dass du eine Ahnung hast
und das ist heutzutage auch nicht mehr so easy
wie das heißt nach dem du suchen musst
also du musst dich schon in der Tiefe auskennen
aber du musst halt auch nicht jeden Scheiß wissen
du musst nicht wissen was jede Option heißt
du musst aber wissen nach was du suchst
das ist SCM genau
Source Control Management
dachte ich zumindest bisher immer
dass SCM Source Control Management ist
so 99,9
gleich haben wir es
ja BeatBrot genau
ja
die wenigsten Entwickler können gut Git
so blöd das klingt
du brauchst halt so ein paar Sachen
du musst dir vielleicht mal eine Branch aufmachen
und da fängt es ja bei vielen schon an
oh Branch ist
weil es eine der einfachsten Sachen ist in Git
die können halt so ein Merch Request machen
oder ein Pull Request
die können was Committen Pullen Pushen
und so die Basics was du brauchst
du bist ja als Entwickler im Prinzip erstmal Anwender aus Gits Sicht
aber du kannst mit Git alles machen
es gibt glaube ich nichts was du mit Git nicht machen kannst
und beim Rebasen fängt es schon an
wie oft ich schon neben Leuten gestanden habe
und mit denen ihren Monate alten Feature Branch
rebased habe
das kann ich dir mal erzählen
oder sind sie immer über Git Magic begeistert
wenn es dann doch so einfach funktioniert
wisst ihr ich brauche noch ein paar Mobs
was ist das für ein Hackertalk hier
ist der Git Good Talk
haha Milchmann
da bin ich mal gespannt wenn du Probleme hast
wie du das mit deinem
IDE Click Rebase machst
ja BeatBrot gibt es
es gibt GitFS
und es gibt so ein paar andere Sachen
wo mir die Namen nicht einfallen
gibt es aber
also GitFS von Github ist so mit das
verbreitetste zum Binary einchecken
also du checkst nicht wirklich Binary ein
das ist irgendwie sehr trickreich gemacht
du checkst bloß ein das es dieses Binary
irgendwo anders gibt
das ist ganz cool
weil Binary ist direkt ein Binary
aber man muss sich erst mal
drauf achten
dass die Binary nicht
irgendwo anders sind
weil Binary ist direkt
ein Binary
also wenn du jetzt
Das ist ganz cool, weil Binary ist direkt ins Git, das ist für den Arsch.
Heute noch eine 60.
Mal gucken, wie viel XP ich kriege, wenn ich jetzt hier einen Mob bashe.
Naja.
Okay, das ist schon langsamer.
Das ist langsamer.
Das ist deutlich langsamer.
Oh, scheiße, das ist langsam.
Ich würde sagen, ich brauche jetzt so viel.
Ich brauche jetzt so viel für 0,1 wie früher für 1%.
Also 59 auf 60, 1% ist so viel wie 0,160 auf 61.
Oder noch langsamer.
Oh, das ist langsam.
Das ist langsam.
Auf, verpisst euch, ihr komischen Mobstar.
Ich will jetzt zurück, paar Skills lernen.
Wieso sehe ich manche Emotes nicht?
Weil du kein Better Twitch TV oder Franker Faces Z mit Better Twitch TV...
drauf hast.
Ich empfehle Franker Faces Z mit Better Twitch TV Add-on.
Funktioniert schon fast alles, weil bei der Twitch TV funktioniert ja fast nichts.
Oh, ist wieder hochgebeamt.
Freudisch.
Hallo, I look...
Easy 60.
Easy 60, genau wie der Titel sagt.
Was habe ich für eine Uptime?
Kann mir jemand Uptime machen?
Oh, 6,5 Stunden und morgen habe ich nochmal ungefähr 45 Minuten ohne Stream gelevelt.
Die erste Nacht des Tages.
Irgendwann heute Morgen um 10 oder so.
6 Stunden 30, fuck ey.
Das ist ja für meine Verhältnisse fast schon 24 Stunden Stream.
Also ich würde sagen, mit 33 kann man 6,5 Stunden quasi aufrunden zu 24.
Oh, das Pad nervt.
So, mal gucken, ob wir genug Punkte haben, um die Skills zu trainieren, die wir brauchen.
Pillar Hype.
Ja, wenn der Fabian da ist, dann...
So, guck mal, was haben wir denn für Skills?
Haben wir schon.
Woran sehe ich denn, was ich noch nicht habe?
Habe ich auch schon?
Ah, hier, da wo ein Plus ist.
Easy eigentlich.
Das brauchen wir.
Was macht denn das jetzt eigentlich, Unerschied?
855% mal 7?
954% mal 7.
Okay, Accuracy ist ein bisschen mehr.
Plus 30, Casting Speed plus 10.
Wo ist der Unterschied?
Ein bisschen mehr Damage, hä?
Aber das war es dann.
Also was heißt ein bisschen mehr?
Ist schon ordentlich mehr.
Ist die Range höher?
Wenn du FFZ-Erweiterung hast, musst du noch das Better Twitch TV Add-on für FFZ installieren.
Den Flow.
Ah!
Oh, sehr nice.
Oh, das ist ja geil.
Also sprich, wenn ich den Skill hier mache, klar,
dann kommt noch mein Pet dazu und basht mit.
Oh, das ist sehr nice.
Den brauchen wir noch.
Ich meine, habe ich nicht genug Punkte für alles?
Okay, das Ding brauche ich eh fast nie.
Okay, dafür haben wir keine Punkte mehr, aber sonst haben wir alles.
Ne, das...
Oh, das kann...
Ich kann mein Rechtsklick nicht skillen.
Das ist Sauerei.
Wie viele Punkte brauche ich denn?
42.
Ich habe 35.
Kann ich noch hier irgendwas raus specken?
Habe ich hier noch irgendeinen Mist gespeckt?
Okay, nachdem ich das ja quasi eh nicht verwende, sehe ich hier irgendwo, wie viele Punkte ich wiederkriege, wenn ich das hier jetzt raus specken würde.
Mach's gut, MaxPunch.
Wir reiten mal nach Velia.
Also erstmal neuen Skill ausprobieren.
Oh, das ist ja nice.
Nice.
Nice zu, nice zu.
Oh, das ist ja geil.
Wo ist denn mein Gaul?
Wo habe ich denn mein Gaul stehen?
Äh, ist mein Pferd verreckt?
Kann das sein?
Ich glaube, mein Pferd ist verreckt.
So, wir reiten jetzt mal nach Velia.
Die kannst du animieren.
Ja, du kannst GIF-Emotes einstellen in FFZ.
Kein Problem.
Ich habe mein Pferd wahrscheinlich einfach nicht gesehen.
So, wir reiten ja nach Velia.
Mal gucken.
Ähm, vielleicht, vielleicht Respec ich den einen Skill, dass ich mir den Wasser-AE kaufen kann.
Auf der anderen.
Seite.
Ich meine.
Meine sieben Skill-Punkte kriege ich eigentlich auch so relativ schnell.
Ach echt?
Da fliege ich wohl zu schnell.
Also im Prinzip fehlen uns jetzt eigentlich keine Skills mehr.
Außer dem Range-Wasser-AE und diesem komischen Knockback-Ding, was ich quasi nie verwende.
Verwendet das irgendjemand?
Schlechte Grasen-PVP.
Wir sind jetzt hier.
Eigentlich fehlt mir nur noch das hier.
Sehr nice.
Das gefällt mir.
Jetzt machen wir auch noch mehr Tamage.
Das kann man hier eigentlich skillen.
Casting-Speed.
Das ist auch voll.
Requires Level 62, 66, 70, 74, 78 und 82.
Ist klar.
Also wir sehen uns dann am Ende des Universums wieder auf Level 82.
Die Musik nervt mich gerade.
So, mehr AP kann man immer gebrauchen.
Das Ding müsste ich auch mal öfters verwenden.
Da kann man quasi was Instant-Casten mit.
Das habe ich noch nicht mal auf einer Quick-Bar drauf.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Das ist eigentlich einer der geilsten Wizard-Spells.
Nö, kein Bock.
Braucht der Max nicht.
Instant-Casten overrated.
Was für ein Level ist der Friseur als 61?
Dann drücke ich das vielleicht mal.
Ich mache das jetzt dahin.
Dann benutze ich es vielleicht mal.
Der Friseur, da ist er ja.
Da ist er ja.
60, easy, ne?
Und ich habe sogar genug Skill-Punkte bis auf einen Spell.
Fehlen mir noch 10 Stück oder so.
Dann kann ich mir den auch noch holen.
Der Wizard.
Was geht da ab?
Ja, 0 Playtime, Full Boss Level 60.
Halt mit sehr viel Glück.
Und den Friseur mit Game-Knowledge.
Der weiß, wie man ordentlich enchantet.
Ah, übrigens, Fabian.
Ich hatte heute in der Box leider keinen Ogre-Ring.
Ich habe irgendwie einen Layton-Stone drin gehabt.
Nee.
Oder?
Hast du den nicht gesellt?
Doch, ich glaube, den hast du gesellt im letzten Enchantment-Stream.
Ich gucke mal.
Ah, ich habe heute übrigens noch...
Ich habe noch mehr Seraph-Necklace getroppt.
Einfach mal bei RNG-Luck und so.
Nee, den habe ich nicht mehr.
Sell Ogre.
Warum?
Und kauf einen Laytons.
Ja, das...
Bist du morgen da?
Ja, morgen Nachmittag.
Dann können wir den Kram zusammen machen und dann noch ein bisschen Kreisel-Grinden.
Ich gucke gleich auch auf den Bersi, ob ich den nicht da habe.
Nur bis 16 Uhr?
Ja, kann man theoretisch davor.
Easy, ich bin ja früh wach.
Morgen ist doch nicht Silvester.
Silvester ist das Übermorgen.
Ach, ihr kriegt Besuch oder so, ne?
Lohnt sich das überhaupt jetzt?
Irgendwie das Zeug quasi nur auf Duo zu enchanten?
Oder sagen wir mal so, wir machen jetzt das auf Duo.
Morgen, meine ich.
Also, mal genau, wir machen jetzt der Schmuck-Teil auf Duo.
Lohnt sich das dann?
Also, man kann schon quasi dadurch den Set-Bonus zu verlieren, den man mit den Drop-Schmuck-Teilen hat.
Ah, ne, 20 AP, das lohnt sich.
Das lohnt sich.
Ich meine, 20 AP und dafür verliert man 3 DP und 20 Akku.
Oh Mist, ich hätte aus dem Bazaar meine Items mitnehmen sollen.
Aber da muss ich heute nicht mehr on-stream hinreiten.
Mir geht das erstmal noch weh.
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, warum ich nach Velia wollte.
Ah ja, weil ich da Respecs habe.
Aber ich respecke ja gar nicht.
Warum reite ich denn überhaupt nach Velia?
Egal, ich reite jetzt nach Velia.
Easy Velia-Rit.
Einfach, weil es geht.
Ich bin jetzt Level 60, jetzt kann ich so viel rumreiten, wie ich will.
Guck mal.
Jetzt ist XP-Buff an.
Jetzt.
Jetzt, wo ich fertig bin.
Heute den ganzen Tag nicht.
Der Wubbler-Wubbel.
Also ich sehe es ja gerade unten im Vorschau auf dem zweiten Monitor im Stream.
Die Katze, die guckt echt sehr dramatisch da unter dem Chat hervor.
Wach, das war ein paar Tricks.
Was ist das da oben eigentlich für ein Knopf?
Gilden-PVP.
Gildensiege, ohne in der Gilde zu sein.
Ups, reit weiter.
Horse.
Ja, aber das ist schon geil.
Das ist easy 60, genau wie es der Titel gesagt hat.
Jetzt fehlt mir halt schon der Skill hier.
Level 60, was ist das denn für ein Knopf?
Ich habe es heute, glaube ich, schon 20.000 Mal gesagt.
Ich bin der bestausgerüstetste Noob in ganz BDO.
Wie viele Stunden hast du schon in BDO gesteckt?
Ich glaube, das weiß der Fabian eher.
Wo sieht man das?
Wobei, das war mein AFK-Char.
Mein AFK-Fisch.
Wo sieht man das überhaupt?
Profil?
Wo sieht man dann Spielzeit?
Today.
Today-Upload.
Ich bin nur 11 Stunden heute in BDO gewesen.
Ja, also.
Nur 11 Stunden.
Wo sieht man dann Playtime?
Steht das irgendwo da?
Also, der Wizard vielleicht.
Ich glaube, ein bisschen mehr als 60 Stunden.
Der Wizard schon.
Guck mal, allein heute 11.
Wo steht das denn?
Ja, und davon ist locker die Hälfte.
Aber 31, es sind keine 31 Tage.
Der Wizard war mein AFK-Fisch.
Ach hier, Time Pass, hier unten.
Ja, genau.
31 Tage, das war mein AFK-Fisch-Char.
Zumindest im Vergleich zu anderen ist es wirklich nichts.
Ja, 6-7 Tage Played.
Das denke ich, kommt ganz gut hin.
Es ist halt RNG-Glück ohne Ende gewesen.
Weil da ein hottes, rothaariges Grill.
Sehr realistisch.
So, was wollte ich jetzt in Velia machen?
Respecken, aber ich respecke doch gar nicht.
Also mache ich jetzt nichts in Velia.
Ich bin jetzt einfach in Velia.
Das hat es jetzt ja gebracht, dass ich hergeritten bin.
GG.
Also, ich würde ja sagen, ich mache Schluss, aber ich bin noch nicht wirklich müde.
Tja.
Ogre verkaufen.
Wenn du das sagst, verkaufe ich Ogre.
Ogre.
It's Ogre.
Shracked.
Erstmal collecten.
So.
Erstmal schön collected.
Und jetzt registrieren.
Und dann machen wir den Ogre auf Maxpreis.
Oder, Fabian?
Maxpreis.
Oder macht man das nicht?
Sicher, dass du einen Layton hast.
Komm, ich gucke nochmal nach.
Ich gucke nochmal auf den Berser.
Habe ich doch, oder?
Stream.
Wir haben doch vorhin zusammen die Box aufgemacht.
Da war doch ein Layton-Stone-Dingsbums-Necklace drin.
Guck, der Berser hat auch 34 Tage.
Und den habe ich ja auch kaum gespielt.
Der war dann halt...
Also, ich meine, Wissert.
Wissert, gespielt habe, AFK.
Fischer.
Also, können wir sagen, so von jedem die Hälfte so wirklich gespielt.
Mein Inventar ist so ordentlich, ich sehe nichts mehr.
Ah, hier, da.
Ja, da ist er doch.
Da ist er.
So, wir gucken jetzt gerade nochmal hier im Vault, ob ich nicht doch noch einen habe.
Ne, ne, da müsste er hier oben bei Necklace stehen.
Okay.
Ah, war ich.
Äh, wie schreibt man das Ding?
Layton.
Äh.
Nope.
85.
Gibt es denn für 77?
Too late.
Aber dann verkaufen wir erstmal den Ogre jetzt.
Ah, ist schon weg.
Chatlag.
Get rekt.
So, ich stelle jetzt mal den Ogre rein.
Oh, ne.
Da bieten wir jetzt nochmal mit.
Oh, für eine 85-Million-Kanzler mitbieten, oder?
Easy.
Easy life.
Eat Sniped.
Gut, dann stellen wir jetzt den Ogre rein.
Weil ich brauche ja auch genug Geld, falls ich nochmal dann das snipen muss.
Und mein Sniping-Glück, da klappt das schon.
Ähm.
Nein, nicht pre-order.
Okay.
92 Millionen.
Bei dir läuft's.
Ah.
So.
Dann haben wir morgen wieder Kohle.
Da hüpft er dann besser.
Ja, wie gesagt, eigentlich bin ich fertig für heute.
Aber ich bin noch nicht müde.
Was mache ich denn jetzt?
Ich reite.
Ich reite jetzt wieder nach oben.
Ah, Golden Dagger können wir noch verkaufen.
Nee, nee, ich enchante jetzt nicht selber.
Dafür bin ich zu müde.
Nee, nee, das machen wir morgen.
Machen wir morgen Mittag.
Morgen müssen wir Scrolls machen.
Oh, ich habe ganz viel Zeugs.
Nee, ich habe Schiss, selbst zu enchanten.
Keine Ahnung von dem Game.
So.
Ähm, jetzt sind wir eigentlich fertig.
Oh, ich habe eine Donation gekriegt.
Alter.
Mal gucken.
Z-Glados, 3 Euro.
Das Geld ist dein, das Sein ist mein.
Ah, kann ich...
Kann ich jetzt machen, ja?
Mache ich jetzt.
Komm, Mario, live on stream.
Live on stream.
Profile seinen.
Alles klar.
So, dann signen wir mal dein Profil.
So, jetzt haben wir noch Profile gesigned.
Jawoll.
Jetzt haben wir unsere Pflicht für heute aber echt erfüllt.
Was, zeig mal Chars und Stacks.
Ähm, ja, 6 und 3...
Nee, Quatsch.
0, 28, 0, 34, 0.
Aber ich habe noch ein paar Valk-Dinger.
Vor allem, wenn ich schreibe morgen in Discord,
wenn ich am Start bin.
Du kannst ja einfach...
Sag einfach Bescheid, wenn du auch da bist.
Wie kann man eigentlich von seinem Charakter das Bild aktualisieren?
Mein Wizard sieht überhaupt nicht so aus.
Auf dem Bersi sind 28.
28 auf dem Bersi und auf meinem Feldstärk-Char hier sind 34.
Und das war's.
Das Take-Portrait oben...
Ach, da!
Oh, da geht er ab.
Der Wuppler.
Da geht er ab.
Da fuchtelt er mit seinem Stab.
Der Wuppler.
Äh.
Ah, Spacebar.
Oh, easy.
Jetzt haben wir ein neues Bild vom Wuppler.
Da ist er.
Ja, dann drück mal den Laten drauf.
Ey, du musst morgen...
Wir müssen morgen nicht bei dir einloggen.
Das mache ich morgen so.
Aber ich bin jetzt zu im Arsch, um noch irgendwie da nochmal zu enchanten.
Auch wenn es nichts Großes ist.
Oh!
Okay, Leute.
Irgendwie 7 Stunden Uptime oder sonst was.
7 Stunden.
Hahaha.
Wir können das, wenn du willst, können wir das...
Okay. Ja, ich mach das jetzt.
Leute, sollen wir das noch enchanten?
Sollen wir das Teil jetzt noch enchanten, ja?
Chat.
Sollen wir enchanten?
Gut, dann enchanten wir das jetzt noch.
Oh, ich habe es jetzt gar nicht ins Inf gelegt.
Haha, ins Inf gelegt. Ganz toll.
Okay, Fabian.
Also, auf welchen Char soll ich gehen?
Also, erstmal muss ich nochmal auf den Wizard locken und das in die Truhe legen.
Mit 0 Feldstacks auf Wuppler?
Also, auf den Bersi, genau.
Dann lege ich jetzt...
Okay, mache ich.
Und nicht auf den mit 34 Decks.
Auf den mit 28 Decks.
Okay, mache ich.
So.
Siehste?
Ohne den Fabian würde ich das ja... würde ich nichts enchanten.
Kein Plan von...
Okay.
Ähm...
Dann kann der...
Der Wuppelt kann sich das jetzt ja mal aus der Truhe holen, damit enchanted.
So.
Jetzt haben wir hier zweimal den Stone.
Und nun hole ich wahrscheinlich...
rufe ich den Black Spirit, ne?
Black Spirit, Enchantment und da haue ich jetzt die zwei Dinge rein.
Ist das richtig so?
Skip. Skip.
Stimmt. Wichtig.
So machen das ja die Pros, habe ich gehört.
Bam. Grip.
Kaputt.
150 Millionen.
Im Arsch.
So. Dann machen wir jetzt aber Schluss.
Ich laufe nochmal auf den Wizard auf.
Ja, man kann ja nicht bei allem Glück haben.
Nicht der Zeraph.
Naja, wir haben...
Wir haben schon mal vier.
Das reicht zwar nicht für Ted.
Aber wenn man noch ein paar Karten hat...
Sollten wir mal kaufen.
Sollten wir wahrscheinlich mal mindestens Duo kriegen, hoffe ich.
So.
Jetzt waren wir aber echt schluss.
Jetzt reicht's.
Also Leute, ich hoffe euch hat's gefallen.
Macht's gut.
Bis zum nächsten Mal. Tschüss.